hey everyone welcome to simply learn
today we will be learning the project
management's fill course we will begin
this video by talking about what project
management is project planning how can
it be done using excel cost quality
communication and other forms of
management the best project managing
tools how you can prepare for the pmp
exam the role of a project manager
interview questions and much more by the
time you are done you will be well
versed with some of the most important
concepts in project management for this
training with me we have a specialist
chandra mr and ishan together they will
take you through these different topics
so let's start by answering our first
question
what is project management so before we
begin make sure to subscribe to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon so that you can never
miss an update from simply learn
hi
welcome to project management tutorial
from simple learn i am chandra mr a
professional consultant and coach
in best practices related to project
management and i.t service management
today as part of this tutorial we are
going to learn the basic
understanding about the project
management and the required knowledge
for a project manager to become
successful in managing projects so as
part of this tutorial we are going to
look at
what is project management what is
project components of project management
project life cycle key focus areas in
project management job roles in project
management and project management
certifications so what is project
management now as defined in pmis pmbok
project management is application of
knowledge skills tools and techniques to
project activities to meet project
requirements so every project will have
an objective to accomplish similarly the
objective of project management is to
make the final deliverables in a finite
time and budget this involves having
clear understanding about the
deliverables of the project require
resources for the project resource in
terms of human resources technical
resources financial resources etc
project managers should have a full
picture of those aspects we can call it
as constraints or aspects and manage
those throughout the project life cycle
for which a project manager should have
a full view about a project and what is
that this project has to accomplish that
objective should be clear
so as part of project management the six
constraints which project manager should
look at are scope time quality cost risk
and resources so each of these areas has
very important role to play in project
management the clarity in scope the
clarity in terms of schedule within
which the project has to be delivered
the cost what it incurs to that
particular project once it is finalized
one cannot vary when cannot change
without any proper approvals similar to
that we have quality management which
has to ensure the scope the
specifications what are defined project
output will be accordingly achieved risk
every project is taken up for a specific
reason by organization so organization
should assess the risk associated with
the project and similarly as project
progresses various different risks has
to be identified like risk related to
project management risk related to
technology area risk related to
resources risk related to financial
things so broadly risk management plays
a very important role so there will be
something called contingency reserve
kept for a identified risk above the
cost what is estimated for various
deliverables from the project so every
projects require resources resources may
be in terms of human resources financial
resources technology resources
environmental resources so all these
resources are used to produce the output
of the project so these resources has to
be managed with the sufficient
optimization and standardizations
required now let us understand the
definition of a project so what is the
project pmi defines a project as a
temporary endower undertaken to create a
unique product service or result the
temporary nature of a project indicates
that the project has a definite
beginning and end so when i say product
unique product it means every output it
may be similar products you are
producing with the same features and
functionality but the output of every
project is unique because it is unique
in terms of all the six constraints what
we just discussed now now when i say
product it is very easy for us to
visualize it may be a desktop it may be
a laptop
it may be a car it may be a machine etc
but how do i visualize a service a
project output is a service now it is
it's about building a capability a
project by through a project a
capability can be built to ensure
services can be provided that's what the
output of project is service for example
if i think about a taxi services for
providing a taxi services i need a
mobile app i need taxi i need a server i
need a data center
so all these are various different
products and services here service
example can be internet service so
combination of all the services and
products builds the capability for an
organizations who can provide the taxi
services so building that capability we
say it is an output of a particular
project which is called service
similarly results can be
improvement of something improvement in
customer satisfaction increase in
some specific objectives or specific
results needs to be achieved in
performance perspective so
output of every project will be unique
product or a service or a result this we
need to clearly understand so when we
say there is a definite beginning and
end every project starts at a certain
point in time and ends at certain point
in time so it has a definite beginning
and end that is the reason it is
temporary in nature it is not an ongoing
business activity right so every project
will have a life cycle a beginning and
end so when it starts till end until the
result or a service or a product which
comes as an output of a project project
lifecycle is not ended so interestingly
in a product life cycle or in a service
lifecycle you come across
many project life cycles so one project
life cycle means one project is
initiated to introduce a product or
services next project or
initiated would be to enhance the
capability of a service or a product
next project initiated after some time
is to optimize something similarly at
the end of the product lifecycle project
is initiated to retire that product or
services so in a given product life
cycle there will be multiple project
life cycle so what is involved in the
project life cycle it involves five
areas five groups we can call it as so
initiation planning execution monitoring
and closure so when i say initiation
it's all about understanding what is
project giving the basic understanding
of the project collating the details and
having key stakeholders identified once
that is done one will move towards
planning so here in the initiation
it is very clearly one has to understand
is project is worthwhile of doing so one
has to check the feasibility one has to
measure that particular investment is
making sense
and then confirm yes it makes sense to
invest now next planning as we have a
basic understanding of yes this project
has to be done and a discussion with the
key stakeholders have happened
now that moves towards planning now in
planning one will understand the project
in entirety if it is a waterfall
approach one has to have a clear
articulation of entire project a
comprehensive details holistic approach
now if you go if you are going in a
project in a agile way of approach now
in this planning you may have a big
skeleton as you go in each of the
iteration you may go deep dive into
detailed planning if it is agile
approach so planning provides you the
clear insight towards what needs to be
done in this project how it has to be
done and what are the results which can
be achieved out of that particular
project so this involves making that a
clear blueprint often project objectives
what we are supposed to achieve so this
will become a reference point throughout
the project lifecycle then execution as
you have a blueprint of the project as
the direction of that project is set
detailing of the project has been made
one will go ahead and execute the
project executing the sense
implementation acquiring resources and
implementing it so execution phase
involves the allocation of resources and
making the deliverables as required you
acquire resources you configure a
resource you ensure right resources are
required if it is human resource one has
to educate that human resource with the
project required knowledge or details or
one has to
provide that assignment in such a way
that skills of that individuals what
they should have is acquired by those
individuals so that deliverables can
happen and they need to be managed the
entire team needs to be managed for that
a clear structure has to be created
similarly when you do technology
resource perspective those components
has to be tested configured then
integrated again tested for uncheck the
performances so collective action of
this results in a deliverable during the
execution so as the deliverables are
happening in the execution it is quite
obvious project manager has to monitor
review control that particular
deliverable and also the processes tools
resources used during the project even
those needs to be monitored so that they
are complying to the defined processes
so during monitoring there may be a
deviation one can found during
monitoring there may be the project is
running the way it is required so in
this monitoring phase it involves an
action from project manager to monitor
and control the work of the project so
comparing with the blueprint of plan
what is accomplished what is created
during the planning
phase of this project and as the
execution happens monitoring and control
is monitoring it and checking is that
activities what is being done is
according to the plan or not similarly
the deliverables which comes as an
output of our projects are tested
thoroughly whether those have a specific
features and functionality and are they
functioning the way it is required now
project has to be delivered to the scope
what is defined it should not go beyond
that or below that similarly the
schedule what is made for the project
within that schedule project
deliverables needs to be accomplished
within the cost what is budgeted for the
project so during the project your
project manager may find there are
certain
deviations which are occurred there are
additional challenges which has come in
so for this reason one has to ensure
continued monitoring as the execution
happens and identify those deviation and
ensure whenever there is a deviation
there is a correction whenever there is
an additional things coming in that
needs to be considered carefully whether
that need to be involved as part of this
deliverable or should be taken it
separately so this requires lot of
conversation with all the stakeholders
of the project during the entire project
life cycle especially during planning
execution monitoring and control since
they are not the one which is happening
in sequence so planning can also come
back again where there is something
which you may require to modify
so may require to have a change in the
blueprint itself by adding that new
change which is coming in so you go back
to planning so planning execution
monitoring and control are going hand in
hand so that project deliverables are
happening as needed
similarly all the process work
instructions all those templates what is
given are used one is complying to those
requirement it is very important and
project is done within the scope
schedule and time and the quality
metrics defined then as the completion
of the project happens as the monitoring
and control says yes deliverable has
happened according to the requirement
then the project moves to the closure
the closure may be closure of a specific
project phase a milestone deliverable or
a faisal deliverable
or it can be a deliverable at the end of
the project which is the ultimate
deliverable so processes in closing has
to be triggered whenever there is end of
the phase whenever there is a
deliverable to conclude and also at the
end of the project to conclude the
entire project so during the closure one
has to ensure capturing all the details
in terms of what is accomplished against
what is defined what went wrong what
went well what is a learning one has to
take to the next level or the next phase
or to the next project and at the same
time a sign-off has to be obtained
formally and everything should be
summarized and have a good handshake
with the project stakeholder mainly a
business or customer and also
disseminating of team means you will
dismantle the entire team and send them
back to their specific units or
specialization and they may get assigned
to new project or if it is a functional
they can go back to their functions to
do their functional activities so that
was about entire project lifecycle what
happens now while doing this i mentioned
there are six constraints that is scope
schedule cost quality risk and resources
so keeping these in mind one has to
ensure project is successful in all
aspects so to become successful there
are few key areas which has to be looked
at so
first six key areas are scope schedule
cost quality resources and stakeholders
now let us look at the scope what does
scope means scope is about what needs to
be delivered what is in scope what is
out of the scope so this refers to all
those deliverable scope all those
activity scope basically we speak about
two things one is product scope and
project scope product scope is all about
ensuring the features functionality of
products are well defined and understood
and signed off and while delivering that
product that is tested against those
defined features and functionalities
whereas projects go focus on all the
activities needs to be done all those
templates which has to be used all the
process which has to be complied with
all the skills which is required to be
applied so it is going as defined so by
doing this activities which is defined
as part of project scope the result the
deliverable will come out which will be
in line with the deliverables features
and functionality which is defined as
part of product scope it is very
important to ensure entire projects
happens within this particular scope
there should not be any deviations from
this schedule perspective for that
specifications what were defined for a
product and project so these needs to be
done in a specific point in time means
in a specific schedule there will be
start time and time right so
one has to plan how long a project would
take and what are the deliverables
should happen in what sequence what
activities are required to accomplish
this
so all these needs to be understood so
while performing the schedule management
one has to look at a specific
deliverable at a specific point in time
by applying a specific set of activities
required so this will tell you the
duration of the project this will
provide the sequence of project this
will also help you to understand the
dependency between one task to another
task this will also help you to
understand how the deliverables
happening in what sequence which helps
in prioritizing your deliverables third
is cost so as we know to do any project
it is very essential to ensure project
happens within that budget so project
cost is estimated initially then that
estimated cost will be checked checked
in terms of is the assumptions
considerations are right or wrong is
that really so much of a monetary
resource are required for the project
and then after understanding the
justification and obtaining the clarity
budget is i mean monetary resources are
allocated and confirmed approved then it
will become a budget that will be a cost
baseline so these estimation allocation
of budget once it happens that will
become a base and any deviations from
that cannot happen so easily so any
deviations because of additional of
scope that can be handled through change
management but idealistic scenario the
cost should not escalate or come down
organization can also set certain
tolerances at the project level
considering various different scenarios
like scenario of risks scenario of
something which deviated from the
deliverable so to what extent it can
deviate that tolerance will also be set
at the economic or monetary value
perspective that is about cost
now quality
as we know quality is a very important
area which ensures the project is
delivered in time with all the
specifications defined
by using all the methods means by
following all the processes work
instructions templates
and delivering as needed where it
enables the project to monitor it easily
so basically the requirement of
compliance and standardization and
optimization is to ensure everyone
follows the same steps do the activity
so what quality management focus is to
ensure the intended objectives of a
projects are achieved already there is a
definition done in terms of various
different practices or processes needs
to be followed similarly specification
of each of the products are defined and
from that there should not be any
deviation so quality management should
focus on ensuring those activities are
done as defined those deliverables are
done according to the specifications
what is different it is very important
that way so for that there is a layer of
quality management there should be a
layer of quality management where
auditing or control activities are
initiated periodically so that any
deviations can be seen easily and
remember
a project manager can become cannot
become part of quality management like
project manager cannot audit project
manager should have a team or take the
help of a team who can able to do mostly
the one which is who is not part of the
project is always better resources
now as i mentioned earlier every project
need resources it may be human resources
it may be technology resources it may be
any other resources which are required
to do the project so organization
acquires resources configured and then
deployed
for example in the project you acquire a
server
you configure a server you deploy a
server technology resource human
resource is on board recruited project
induction is given then at the same time
the skills and capabilities of
individuals are according to the
requirement of project that needs to be
ensured and what needs to be delivered
and how it has to be delivered should be
clear to the particular human resource
so looking at all the aspects of
resources to acquire to build and manage
it is very important to look at the
resource management so this will help in
carrying out a specific task in the
project in the best possible manner so
interestingly when i say human resource
always there is a possibility that
a conflict can occur so when i say
conflict conflict of interest may be in
terms of what the individuals has to do
conflict in terms of the preferences in
terms of solutions what they are looking
at conflict in terms of using resources
different opinions different preferences
various reasons conflict can come across
so it is very important to project
manager to understand this dynamics of
human resources
and manage this conflicts project
manager cannot shy away from handling
conflicts project manager has to hone
and resolve those conflicts in the favor
of project not in the fear of any
individuals so there are various
techniques to look at resolving
conflicts so that is like compromising
problem solving smoothening
accommodating
so whichever helps for that project
scenario for the project objectives that
needs to be applied that technique has
to be taken up so here the resolution is
not at the specific individual's
preference it is with the objective of
other projects as any impact what kind
of impact positive or negative if it is
negative no that's not the direction the
direction should be ensuring project
gets that value through this conflict
resolution so project manager should own
it it's an accountability of a project
manager then as the human resources are
acquired there are five stages
team dynamics are involved so one has to
bring them
then educate them about a project as
education on the project happens one has
to go and do the job on floor that needs
to be observed means one has to manage
by looking at it and
any corrections needs to be done that
needs to be guided so it is very dynamic
thing when it comes to human resources
similarly in technology resources
standardization there is no ambiguity as
such but right resources with the right
configurations should be acquired that
is very important the next stakeholders
so who can be stakeholders every project
will have a stakeholder who are internal
and external to the project so the
internal stakeholders are those who are
part of the project who are part of the
organization who are part of the
customer organization or part of
supplier organization a competition to
my business means my organization's
business all this we can call it as a
stakeholders now every stakeholders will
have a specific interest a power an
ability to influence now through their
position through their distance from the
project
they will get impacted at the same time
they will also impact the project
similarly they influence and they get
influenced because of the project so a
project manager should identify all the
stakeholders and understand this what is
the kind of stakeholder is this in terms
of power in terms of legitimacy in terms
of influence in terms of impact after
understanding that there should be a
strategy for handling the stakeholders
how am i going to engage with these
stakeholders it is very important and
accordingly the engagement should happen
and then stakeholder engagement should
resolve in the favor of projects again
so if it is a customer customer should
get that inputs required through review
or periodic updates and the engagement
required with the customer so that
customer is having up-to-date
information about the project if it is a
team continued monitoring and control
and ensuring team delivers the results
what is required so focus of a
stakeholder should be in such a way that
your strategy should enable project to
become successful and get a proper
response from the stakeholder means a
supporting engagement so next few key
focus areas to mention is communication
risk
procurement critical success factors
deliverables and work breakdown so this
list is not exhaustive as we deep dive
into project i think you can just keep
listing the key focus areas more than
this but whatever we have indicated are
the minimum which needs to be looked at
so when i say communication
communication is basically a
conversation exchange of message which
happens between two entities now
whenever we communicate it is necessary
to understand that it has to happen with
two individuals or two entities there
should be sender there should be a
receiver in the absence of receiver if
sending is happening that communication
doesn't make any sense there should be a
receiver and there should be an
acknowledgement from the receiver now
this is one of the most ignored area in
many of the projects even the
communication happens more often more
frequently but what people face
difficulty in realizing that as they
communicate generally informally
formally they just take those for
granted now when you identify the
stakeholder one has to understand what
is the communication requirement for
those stakeholders what is that
communication why is that communication
what is the content of that
communication
how frequently we should do that
interactions or communications intent of
that particular communication what is
the expected action or response from
that communication all this needs to be
very very clear and this can be
articulated it has to be articulated so
when it is articulated once there is a
picture in terms of what kind of
communication has to happen it is quite
obvious there should not be any
deviation from the agreed communications
requirements and whenever there is a
need of change to the communication
requirements from the stakeholders that
needs to be updated for this one has to
have a stakeholders identified so
stakeholder management and communication
are very closely linked and associated a
engagement with the stakeholder will
become successful within effective
communication approaches next is risk so
every project which is undertaken by
organization that will have certain
amount of risk which organization will
evaluate similarly within the project
life cycle lot of risk comes up which
would have such an impact to the project
now risk refers to by definition an
uncertain event it has an uncertainty an
event which is uncertain and when it
occurs it will have an impact on the
project positively or negatively now
current scenario in everywhere in the
projects what you observe closely people
tend to look at the risk which are
threats that is negative only but they
fail to recognize the risks which are
opportunities the positive risks so
another gap which we see when do the
risk management is that is done in the
initial phase of the project as the
project is kicked off someone will do
the risk assessment have a list of risk
identified but unfortunately there is no
categorizations for that risk and how is
that going to impact the project that is
not clear thirdly risk management or
list of risk
are created only once it is not done
repeatedly so risk identification and
analysis and assessment of that risk has
to be done throughout the life cycle of
a project reason being the risk which
looks as in high impact when project is
initiated as the project progresses the
impact levels will vary maybe in the
middle of the project the impact may be
very high or low so likewise the impacts
of the risk will vary throughout the
project life cycle it may be positive it
may be negative so as you identify the
stakeholder throughout the project life
cycle as i said that is also a dynamic i
cannot just have a list of stakeholders
and i keep it as it is i need to update
that also regularly risk identification
assessment and analysis should also be
done regularly periodically so that one
will have a clear understanding about is
that risk still valid is that risk is
there still or not what is the level of
variations in terms of impact of the
risks so this clarity will be there so
that neces organization or project
manager can get ready to face those risk
if it is a negative risk definitely
should have a mitigation or avoidance or
acceptance whatever the mitigation plan
you have to eliminate the negative
impact of the risk when it occurs if it
is a positive risk it's quite obvious
one has to take the advantage of that
one has to enhance exploit share a
positive risk so that organization is
benefited further procurement so
whenever a project is initiated whenever
a project is taken up the organization
who is doing the project cannot create
everything cannot develop everything in
that project life cycle so organization
would take a decision make a decision
stating that some of the deliverables we
make ourselves some of the products we
make ourselves some of the products we
purchase some of the services we
purchase so to purchase that has to
happen from a
specific supplier you cannot go with
every supplier you should evaluate the
suppliers qualify the suppliers and then
select onboard the supplier and then get
the services or products supplied by
that particular supplier so while doing
this one has to understand what type of
contracting they need to enter with so
three types of contracts we speak
basically one is about
a cost plus contract where cost is fully
known to the project manager and to the
organization so apart from known cost a
fee will be paid to the supplier another
one is fixed price where project manager
or the organization who is awarding that
contract to a supplier will not know
what is the cost instead it is a fixed
price but important here is the scope of
work needs to be clearly articulated and
defined another type of contracting can
be time and material where
the building will happen based on the
amount of time one is spent on that
particular i hire a resource or on-board
resource on a timeline material basis
and what is that effort that resource
has been put based on that building will
happen so three types of contracts
depending on the different scenarios of
the project will be signed with the
contractor however before doing that it
is very essential to identify those
suppliers sign off with them and monitor
and manage them so if deliverables are
not there it is very essential to look
at the
termination one has to terminate
otherwise one has to ensure instead of
uh
terminating should be able to put some
effort to educate them also so that they
come up to the mark so project is
benefited so depending on what needs to
be done that call has to be taken on a
regular basis then critical success
factor so for every project there should
be an articulation of critical success
factor so based on that one can confirm
yes project has achieved his objectives
our project has not achieved his
objectives so key critical success
factor should be supported through the
metrics key performance indicators so
key performance indicators provide those
metrics to say critical success factor
is achieved for example if i want to
become successful in an exam critical
success factor is scoring or passing the
examination or let me say to pass the
examination key performance indicator is
scoring 60 percent and above so critical
success factor for me to get promoted is
to pass in this particular exam so to
pass in this exam minimum i should score
is 60 percent that is kpi passing in the
exam that is critical success factor so
how will i measure that success factor
is kpi so every project which it
produces a specific product or services
by using a specific resources and each
of these the resources the processes the
templates the deliverables all these
needs to be measured on a continual
basis so there are critical success
factors defined and those are measured
by defining kpis to that critical
success factors so basically critical
success factor provides the insight
towards what needs to be measured and
when you measure what should be the
focus and to achieve those critical
success factors the indicator is key
performance indicators when you measure
yes the moment you achieve that your csf
is achieved next deliverables so
deliverables are those which comes as an
output of the project right it may be a
product it may be a service it may be a
result so this refers to the output
within the scope of a project so there
can be one or more deliverables within a
single project so these deliverables may
be the items that are to be sent
externally to a customer or a
stakeholder so every deliverable will
have a defined scope will have a defined
specification so those deliverables has
to be measured tested and one has to
confirm yes this deliverable is
performing as we are intended to have
the performance accordingly the decision
will happen should we accept this
particular deliverable or not if there
is deviation that has to go back for
correction so that's the reason we have
monitoring and control all the control
processes like control quality focused
on the product state whether it has
achieved the results or not is that
functional as needed or not one has to
ensure these deliverables has all those
features and functionalities only then
that can be handed over to the
respective stakeholder customer or
operation whoever the stakeholder it is
next is work breakdown structure so when
we say work breakdown structure when i
look at a specific piece of product or
services and have a bigger picture i
cannot even visualize the various
different components various different
actions involved in achieving that
bigger deliverable so if i say a car so
i can think of a body external i can
think of a mirror on that body i can
think of a
glass in the front side as well as the
back side and also i can think of
interiors like seat then accelerator
steering dashboard all this i can
visualize but since i am not a
technology expert relating to car can i
visualize all those parts which are
working inside for car to move like
engine the battery assembly i don't know
what to say further so all these can be
visualized by an expert so every product
or services should be broken down into
multiple pieces i'm not saying go and
break that product i am saying that
product will have multiple components
which are involved those needs to be
segregated for example if i say cars
exteriors cars interior so cars
exteriors external items you can see
whatever you visualize body body
structure mirror mirror assembly
headlights uh then tires so likewise
whatever i can visualize i will make it
as a line items under the exterior so
under for example under a mirror mirror
i can speak about mirror glass mirror
cap mirror pedestal and mirror of
assembly where it moves where you can
move the mirror so these are the various
components involved in a mirror so i
need to ensure
by breaking down the product into
multiple levels but depos decomposing it
to multiple levels i can able to
visualize the product very clearly what
is there in detail so once i have the
details i will articulate those what is
that particular work breakdown element
is product breakdown element is then i
will look at what skills and
capabilities required for that product
and i will assign the resources
accordingly so once activities resources
everything is assigned automatically
this will become our breakdown structure
further after creating our breakdown
structure one will go and sequence the
activity look at sequencing will happen
based on in what priority deliverable
should happen what order deliverable
should happen then once the sequencing
is done it will be checked to see
whether anything can be optimized
anything can be
done in such a way that smooth flow of
the project can happen there is no
dependencies which will make project to
delay like as the flow happens smoothly
so you would find the various techniques
like critical path method network
diagramming critical chain method so all
these are used the floats of an
activities are checked then leads and
lags of the activities the relationship
between activities so accordingly full
visualization in terms of how the
project will flow and how in what order
the deliverables are happening can be
easily visualized so that is the reason
first activity is to do the product
breakdown which would result in work
regular structure so those are the
points still now whatever i mentioned
are the basic understanding one should
have about a project and project
management so as you deep dive into
various best practices like
pmp by pmi prince2 by axelos scrum mass
fragile scrub master similarly you have
certified scrum master so many agile
practices so when you look at any of the
best practices that will tell you
clearly articulate what should be the
practice for you to
adopt and adapt that practices so that
your project can become successful so
any of those approach you touch upon all
those refers to these basic things in
the absence of these basic things none
of those best practices discusses the
project management now typically in the
industry there are a lot of job roles to
the project management which we have
seen so based on that this information
is captured here on various job rules in
a project management so some of them are
like project manager senior project
manager project lead resource manager
pmo that is project management office
analyst steering committee member
so
not necessarily all the project
management roles are limited to this so
these are the roles which commonly you
see and we are trying to capture that to
give the insight right when i say
project manager the project manager is
the owner one has to take an
accountability for the project right so
project managers takes the project
according to the plan and plays a lead
role in all the steps of the project
management right so responsibilities
should be managing reviewing and
prioritizing the task wherever necessary
looking after risk management
stakeholder management and project
communication management some of the
salary what we found while we were doing
the survey the success ratio of a
project depends majorly on the project
manager so the demand for project
management is rapidly increasing in the
market so accordingly uh
thousand four seven four per year that
is the usd in inr it is fifteen hundred
thousand so this is what the salary uh
on an approximation what was found next
role we look at senior project manager
where senior project manager is ahead of
the overall project management plan the
role demands in-depth knowledge of all
the project aspects on a specific on the
specifics of the project the
responsibilities would be planning and
coordinating complex projects visiting
project sites to check progress and
handle complex issues so salary
looks like one or four thousand dollars
per year here 20 92 000 inr per year so
the role of senior project manager is
one of the highest paying rules in the
industry as we have seen having several
allowances and bonuses because of the
criticality involved in the project and
the accountability level of that
particular individuals in the
organization next role project lead so
project leads are the one who leads the
people throughout the project and
provide them with all the information
required throughout so responsibilities
involve motivating the team beneath
taking care of their needs and paying
attention to what they feel ordering or
controlling the project team since the
project lead has more freedom than the
project manager salary project lead
makes sure that project gives the best
possible outcome and is hence the demand
for the project lead in the company
never reduces so in usd 82 000 per year
whereas in inr it is one million two
sixty nine thousand per year next role
we look at on resource manager so
resource manager is the human resource
needed to make the project success right
so one has to manage those resources
responsibility involved assigning the
right people to the right projects at
the right time managing employees
currently and determining hiring needs
depending on the project's requirements
so salary would be around 64 000 usd
which comes around 966 794 in inr
project management office analyst for
this role the project management office
analyst works with pmo means project
management office and does not look at
the project or manage the project
directly instead does most of the data
driven work which required for a project
to have our project to get supported by
that so that project managers will have
a better insight analyzing and
interpreting the data concerning the
project figuring out the future risks to
the project finding new ways to advance
the idea of the project management so
salary would be one or six thousand two
fifty three per year in usd whereas four
forty nine thousand three thirty seven
in inr per year so steering committee
member so the steering committee members
are the members who do not work on the
project themselves they are there to
help the project manager like providing
inputs during the development of a
project advising on the budget and
evaluating the project strategies taking
regular feedback from the project
managers and asking necessary questions
so salary would be around 68 497 dollars
per year so those were the various roles
and that is not that list is not an
exhaustive list various different roles
we come across but these are the basic
roles which is seen in the industry
these roles are being recruited now
there are various project management
certifications which are offered as i
mentioned earlier so those
certifications are pmp that is project
management professional from pmi agile
certified practitioner that is pmi acp
again from pmi then certified associate
in project management so difference
between capm and pmp is like capm would
act as a basic level of certification
for those who does not have a sufficient
project experience project management
experience whereas pmp is for those who
has some project management experience
similarly pmi sap is the one who is
aspiring to look at agility in project
management and they can go for it
certified scrum master yes it is a scrum
master certificate which will explain
the role of a scrum master in detail
similarly prince to
a certification from axolotls which also
speak about all the aspects of the
project what we discussed and provides
the framework for project management
axilla's also provides prince2
certification in agile also agile
prince2 certification so we will look at
each one of this certain details which
are required for us to know so project
management professional as i mentioned
is most acknowledged and value the
certificate value what it carries which
has resulted to the certified
professionals in landing up in highest
paid jobs in the world so certified
managers gets 20 more salary than the
average salary so to take up an
examination one has to go through the
formal training of 35 hours that is one
of the prerequisites and there should be
some experience of 400 hours of project
managing project by leading various
activities of a project and once the
person becomes eligible with that
prerequisites person will become
register in the pmi's website becomes
member and then go for examination so
examination fee for pmp would be 4.5
dollars for the members who are
registered with pmi and for those who
are not registered as a member with pmi
it is 555 dollars the duration of the
examination is 4 hours and the number of
questions will be 200 which are multiple
choice questions so each questions
carries one marks there is no negative
scoring now prerequisites one has to
have 4 500 hours directing and leading
the projects that experience has to be
filled in while filling the application
if a person is a bachelor degree holder
and along with that 35 contractors of
pmi pm education now prerequisites for
the one who is not a graduate who may be
high school or diploma is 7500 hours of
directing and leading projects 35 hours
of pm education so those are the
prerequisites before one will go and
appear for examination so once an
individual passes pmp examination that
certificate is valid for three years so
now after three years if the person
aspires to keep the certificate
continued they need to produce 60 pdus
professional development units which has
to be acquired during those three years
how to acquire one has to go through
additional learning one has to
contribute towards project management
knowledge base so those needs to be
evidenced and then renewable fee has to
be paid and certificate has to be
renewed then agile certified
practitioner as we saw for pmp here a
gel certified practitioner demonstrates
that one has relevant experience and
education to handle and lead agile
projects the organization has started
shifting towards agile as we know in
today's
industry which makes this certification
fast growing in the world so examination
fee would be 435 dollars for pmi members
495 for non-pmi members duration is
three hours and multiple choice
questions 120 questions prerequisites is
2 000 hours project management
experience with 100 hours agile
experience and 21 contact hours of agile
practices so maintenance 30 videos are
required for every three years and after
paying the renewal fee that can be
renewed now certified associate in
project management so here this is an
entry level certificate of pmi
especially for those people who has less
project experience it intends to
demonstrate fundamental knowledge
terminologies and processes of effective
project management so examination fee
would be dollar 225 for pmi members
whereas three hundred dollars for
non-members of pmi so duration of
examination is 3 hours and examination
will have 150 multiple choice questions
so prerequisites someone who has
secondary diploma 23 contact hours of pm
education is enough there is no
experience of doing the project is
required as we saw in pmp so maintenance
is again three years
someone who need to continue the
certification has to retake the
examination every three years next
certified scrum master so certified
scrum master is an entry level
certification that helps the
professionals to begin as the scrum
practitioners is one of the most
sought-after certifications as other
after this one can get the designation
of certified scrum master which is
offered by scrum alliance so examination
fee which will change time to time which
is not revealed so one has to approach
the training organization where they
will get trained on certified scrum
master so duration of examination is 60
minutes and pattern would be 16 hours 2
days of training and 50 multiple choice
questions after that particular two days
of training then prerequisite is done
for maintaining these credentials so one
has to ensure it has renewed every two
years then projects in controlled
environment that is prince2 so prince2
is a method which is effective mostly
from the base of uk all the
organizations who are from uk region
prefers to have prince to certification
and it is as popular as any other
project management certifications like
pmp so examination fee would vary from
nine hundred dollars to thousand dollars
depending on where exactly you're taking
the examination and certification will
happen at two levels one is at
foundation level and other one is
practitioner so in foundation it is 60
questions multiple choice and in
practitioner it's 68 questions now 60
questions or 68 questions each carries
one marks for correct answer any wrong
answer there will not be any negative
scoring one has to score 55 percent to
clear the examination so prerequisites
for prince2 foundation is none whereas
prince2 foundation is a prerequisite for
princeton practitioner examination so to
maintain the certificate one has to
achieve 20 cpds every year continued
professional development hi guys my name
is ishan and i welcome you all to this
session of project planning today we
will be learning about different aspects
of project planning but before we begin
let's have a look at an incident here's
max an assistant project manager who
looks tensed and is pacing around the
room then jack a project manager who
works with him walks into the room and
asks him why does he seem so tensed to
which max replies he is facing
difficulty in estimating the budget jack
responds it might be because he is not
planning the project properly jack
reassures max and begins to tell him
about project planning so today we will
be learning about what is project
planning and check out the fundamentals
of project planning then we will see why
project planning is so essential for a
project to be successful after that we
will check the tools for project
planning and finally we will have a look
at the steps for project planning so
without any further ado let's begin with
what is project planning project
planning is the second step or phase of
the project life cycle project life
cycle has five different phrases from
initiation to closure today we will be
learning about this phase that comes
immediately after initiation in which
the project plan is documented and
further requirements are defined project
planning includes the following things
the first and foremost thing is
describing the objectives or outputs we
are expecting the project to yield
second we have is the elaboration of the
scope to make sure what the project is
all about and what all can be expected
from the project the third step we have
is forming a schedule this schedule is
important to run or perform different
tasks of a project each task having its
own start date and end date this helps
the project to finish in the scheduled
time and limit lastly we have making and
generating progress reports in which all
that went during the tenure of the
project is documented this helps in
evaluating the project and helps in the
forthcoming projects now let's have a
look at the project planning
fundamentals the first fundamental that
we have is the determination of scope
cost and resources that determination
helps us in having a rough estimate
about the time that is required to
finish the project it helps us in
determining the number of people
required and what should be their skill
set we can divide the project into
smaller manageable sections and this is
made possible with the help of work
breakdown structure the second
fundamental refers to identifying the
problem there are several techniques by
which we can collect information and
discover issues there may be several
problems in a project and in that case
several risks or issues are prioritized
and the risk that requires immediate
attention is dealt with first then comes
identification of stakeholders when we
can identify the stakeholders we can
know who all will be affected and in
what way which helps us having a better
understanding of the project
stakeholders may be anybody they may be
the part of the project team or project
managers or customers they help during
the project and contribute to its
success then the last fundamental we
will discuss is defining project
objectives a project plan is made
keeping in mind the requirements of the
project team and expectations of the
stakeholders if the project team can
meet the expectations of the
stakeholders then only we can say that
the project is successful now when we
know about project planning and its
fundamentals it's time to see why
project planning is so important project
planning reduces the cost and time of
the project as every step is monitored
and optimized in the best possible
manner project planning increases
employee satisfaction as every employee
who is a part is engaged in the team for
improved project performance project
planning helps in the implementation of
quality assurance as the output of every
step is duly tested lastly project
planning helps in reducing project risk
as planning helps to analyze prioritize
and deal with that risk moving on let's
have a look at the tools for project
planning the first tool that we have is
a gantt chart today gantt charts are one
of the most popular project management
tools they help in tracking the status
of the work at a particular time and
their independencies on each other gantt
charts help in showing different phases
and steps involved in a project the
second tool we will talk about is
critical path method or cpm critical
path method helps in scheduling the
project activities so that the project
runs properly the critical path method
focuses on the longest stretch of
dependent tasks and determines the time
needed to complete them the next tool is
project evaluation and review technique
or pert chart bird provides a graphical
representation of the project's timeline
explaining the independencies of
different tasks this tool not only helps
in making a schedule but also helps in
coordinating with all the team members
the fourth tool we will check is work
breakdown structure work breakdown
structure is a very common tool that
makes it possible for the team to break
its work into manageable sections work
breakdown structure is a step two step
process that helps in completing the
project efficiently the last tool we
will see is project documentation
project documentation is an integral
part of the project life cycle project
documentation helps in understanding the
mistakes done during the project and
more importantly provides guidelines for
the upcoming project now when we know
about different tools for project
planning it becomes essential that we
know the necessary steps of project
planning there are seven steps in
project planning let's have a look at
each of them in detail the first step is
identification of stakeholders as we
have discussed stakeholders could be
anybody they could be a part of the team
or a project manager or a customer when
we identify stakeholders we can find out
the expectations and requirements that
are to be looked upon in this project
this gives us a clearer picture of the
project and helps in establishing the
project scope so the next step we have
is defining the project scope this helps
in determining a list of specific
project goals and deliverables that are
to be achieved during the course of the
project after we have defined the
project scope it is time to set project
objectives and prioritize them the
initial ideas that were there before are
now elaborated and final steps to
complete the project are defined in the
next step the deliverables are
determined after all project
deliverables are the only reason why the
project is being created this step
involves finding out what these
deliverables will be and the deadlines
of the delivery then the step that comes
into picture is creating a project
schedule the project schedule refers to
the guidelines when a particular task is
to be started and when it is supposed to
end this helps in monitoring the growth
of the project and later helps in
generating progress reports the next
step is the step of risk analysis this
step plays an extremely important role
in the success of the overall project it
helps in identifying the risk
prioritizing them and taking steps to
limit them the last step in project
planning is to generate progress reports
in this step we update the stakeholders
about the project growth and it is done
so that all the concerned team members
can have a look at the progress of the
project after all this information max
thanks jack for the explanation and
looks forward to plan projects within
the budget and of better quality in this
session we will talk about project plan
in excel we will learn about a project
plan and how we can make an effective
plan in microsoft excel before we begin
let's have a look at all the topics we
will be covering today first we will see
the basics of a project plan then we
will check the process of project
management microsoft excel and why
should one refer to microsoft excel
apart from this we will learn about how
to make a gantt chart in excel towards
the end we will check some microsoft
excel templates so without any further
ado let's get started let's see what is
a project plan project plan is a basic
thing that is needed to execute a
project according to project management
book of knowledge a project can be
defined as an approved elaborative
document that guides the team during
project execution and project control
when we are making a project plan a
project plan must answer several
questions for us these questions are
like what are we expecting our project
to deliver how are we expecting to get
our deliverables within the desired time
who all will be a part of a project and
what tasks they will have in the project
when will the project start and when it
is expected to end that is the deadlines
of the project now let us learn about
project management in excel microsoft
excel is one of the most common
applications these days it is used in
both offices and at homes microsoft
excel is an easy project management tool
that allows the team members to easily
see the tasks in a project develop a
plan and track its progress before we
learn more about project management in
excel let's first have a look why do we
use excel microsoft excel is an easy
tool to plan a project so it can be used
by people who are beginners in terms of
project management in excel one can find
several analytical tools like
concatenate len and counter so this
makes data analysis easy and effective
as the entry of data is easy same is
tracking and controlling of project
status then there are several project
management templates in excel that help
us to have an effective distribution of
project data we will be checking several
project management templates towards the
end of this video now let's have a look
at the process of making a gantt chart
in excel before we begin this it's
important we know what is a gantt chart
a gantt chart is like an horizontal bar
chart that is used for project
management with the help of a gantt
chart we can check the status of the
task the date they start the date the
end and the dependencies on each other
gantt chart helps in coordinating and
monitoring different tasks in a project
now let's have a look at the steps that
will help us in making a gantt chart
first step we have is make a project
table we have several rows and columns
like here we have three columns in the
first column we have the tasks in the
second we have our start date and in the
third column we have the duration or
tenure of the task the second step is to
make a bar chart in excel for this we
will select the entire second column
then we will go on the insert tab and
click on the bar graph chart there we
can select stack bar graph in 2d bar
charts as a result we will have the
entitled bar graph on the screen in the
third step we will add the duration to
the bar graph we will right click on the
chart and in the menu that appears we
will select select data option a window
that appears on the screen in that
window we will select add option as
shown we can also see the start date is
already in the entry section then in the
dialog box that appears type tenure in
the series name and click on the rain
selection icon that's shown in the
figure now select the relevant data from
the tenure column and click on ok now we
can see a bar graph that has two colors
on the screen this bar graph now has the
duration of the tasks the fourth step we
have is adding description to the gantt
chart now we will open the box again and
in that box we will select the edit
option as shown in the figure then we
will select the tasks as we had selected
the duration of the tasks before and
click on ok we can now see the tasks
have appeared towards the left side of
the gantt chart the fifth and the
remarkable step will help us convert
this bar graph into a gantt chart we
will now click on the bars and select
the format data series option from the
menu that appears then in the format
data series dialog box we will select no
fill option we can find our gantt chart
on the screen now in accordance with the
data that we had entered now we can see
the tasks on the left side are in the
reverse order so what we will do next is
we will click on the task panel then go
to the format access dialog box and
select the categories in reverse order
option now we can find our tasks in the
right order one more thing we can notice
is gantt chart is starting with some
other date and not with the dates that
we had entered so for this we will copy
the first date in some other cell then
clicking on the copied cell we will go
to the home menu to select the dialog
box as shown in the figure then in that
drop down menu we will select the number
option we can now find a value displayed
in the copied cell we'll copy that value
click on the dates on the chart and as
the format access dialog box opens we
will paste that value in the box that
says minimum shown in the figure as a
result we will have our final gantt
chart on the screen in the last step we
can give several designs to a gantt
chart change colors and make it more
presentable for us now when we know the
basic steps of making a gantt chart i
will show that practically to you in
microsoft excel our first step is to
open microsoft excel and in microsoft
excel we will make a project table in
our project table we will have three
columns the first column will be task
the second column will have the start
date the third column will have tenure
or the duration of the task so beginning
with tasks we have task 1 in task 1 we
have 1.1 1.2 1.3
then comes task 2. in task 2 we have 2.1
2.2 2.3 and 2.4 then we have task 3 in
task 3 we will have two subsections 3.1
and 3.2 then we will start with the
starting dates in starting dates we will
put 1 january the task 1 1.1 will be 1st
of january then this will be 4th january
let's say this is 5th january then we
will put this as 11th of january and
this will be again 11th january only
this will be 15th january let's put this
as 17th january
let this be 19th january task 3 begins
on 23rd january
and it the 3.2 section begins at 26th of
january now let's put the tenure or the
duration of the task we will begin with
task 1 it takes 12 days then 1.1 takes 7
days we say this takes 4 days and this
takes 8 days then for task 2 it again
takes 12 days it takes 5 days
5 days
and let's say this takes six days and
this takes four days then we come to
task three this takes eight days and
let's say this takes six days and the
three point two section takes five days
so this is how our project table is
ready in the second step we will select
the entire second column after we have
selected this column we will go to the
insert tab in the insert tab we will go
to the bar columns and in this we will
select 2d stacked bar charts now we have
the entitled bar chart in accordance to
our data on the screen then comes the
third step we will add the duration of
the tasks to the bar graph we will click
on the chart and after we click on the
chart we will select
select data option in the select data
source dialog box we find the start date
is already there now we will click on
add and after we click on add in the
series name section we will put tenure
then in the series value
we will click on this icon and select
the entire tenure series and click on ok
so this is the bar graph that we have
now this is now in two colors the orange
color and the blue color this bar graph
now has the duration of all the tasks in
our project table now in the fourth step
now it's time for us to add description
to our gantt chart instead of this 1 2 3
4 5 we will put task 1 task 2 and the
sub tasks so what we will do is we will
again go to that box we will left click
on the gantt chart select the select
data option and then we'll go to the
start date here we'll select the edit
option in the edit option we will select
all the tasks and click on ok now we can
see all the tasks are aligned towards
the left of the bar chart as we can see
this is a bar chart or a bar graph and
not a gantt chart the next step we have
is converting this bar graph into a
gantt chart so we will click on the bars
and select the format data series option
from the menu that appears here we have
this format data series option now we
can see the dialog box on the screen
here we'll go into the color section
fill section
and then we will select no fill now we
can see the blue lines have disappeared
so this looks like a gantt chart so now
when we have a gantt chart on the screen
we can notice that the tasks here are in
the reverse order so what we will do is
we will click on these tasks and select
the format access option here we will
select categories in reverse order we
can see our gantt chart is now in order
like we have a task 1 on the top and
task 3 at the bottom the dates are
starting from 11th of december but the
dates we have provided are from 1st of
january now we will copy this cell then
go on the dates box here we'll go to
format access in the format axis we can
see
minimum in this minimum we will paste
this value and press enter as we press
enter we can see our gantt chart
starting from the date that we wanted to
start and that too in the correct order
starting from task 1 to task 3. now as a
result we have our final gantt chart on
the screen in the last step what we can
do is make our gantt chart more
representable we can change the color of
these bars we can give them shapes and
we can do many other things to make it
more presentable we will first select
the bars like what we will do is we will
select task 1 and let's say we give it
the color blue then task 2 we will give
it color green and in task 3 we'll give
give it the color black so here the sub
sections will give different colors to
the sub sections as well then we come to
task 2.1 this is how we can change the
color of these cells or apart from
changing colors we can select a bar
graph and do the gradient fill so this
is how we can make a gantt chart more
presentable after changing the colors or
changing the shapes we have our final
gantt chart on the screen finally let's
have a look at some microsoft excel
templates for project management
microsoft excel templates help in
collecting data putting them into order
and check the dependencies with each
other with the help of these templates
we can monitor the status of the tasks
and we can also check the progress our
project has made moving forward we will
check some important microsoft excel
templates the first template we have is
excel project review template this
template helps us have an overview of
the project we can have a clear
understanding of all the tasks that are
planned and that are completed this
helps project managers to measure the
progress of the project and take further
steps accordingly second template we
will check is excel budget template in
this template we can monitor all the
expenditures of our project it helps us
in managing the budget of a project and
also helps in comparing the budget of
our project at different phases let's
have a look at the budget template in
excel once we can download this template
from officetimeline.com the gantt chart
towards the right is in accordance with
the dates towards the left if we
fluctuate the date we can see the
template working the start date for task
1 could be changed to 10th june if we
change this date to 10 june we can see
the fluctuation in the gantt chart so
this is how we can use this template
directly let's have a look at the third
template now third template we will see
is excel sprint project tracker template
this template is used majorly in agile
projects where the project is made in
several sprints or sessions this
template includes the start date the end
date and the duration of each task we
can also see the percentage completed of
each task let's have a look at this
print project tracker template as well
we can see the gantt chart towards the
right and the data towards the left so
if we change any data we can see the
gantt chart changing for example we can
change the data in sprint to feature 3.
let's change the start date to july 2nd
we can see the gantt chart changing
this is how we can use this template
directly to track our sessions let's
have a look at the fourth excel template
this template is excel project tracker
in this template we have the data of all
the tasks with the status and owners we
can track the percentage of tasks
completed and also compare the plan
duration of the task to the actual
duration of the task after the critical
part tracker let's check the excel
project schedule template this template
helps in effective management of the
project as it helps in monitoring the
time that each task of the project takes
it provides a clear view of all the work
associated with the project let's have a
look at this template in excel once we
can see the gantt chart in accordance to
the data if we change the estimated
hours at two places let's say at the
design review we make it 15 hours
instead of 5 hours and at the create
staffing plan we make it 2 hours instead
of 20 hours we can see the gantt chart
fluctuating this is how we can use this
template to manage the schedule in a
project moving forward the next template
we will see is excel project status
report template this template helps us
having a list of project deliverables
and the risks associated with that
project this template helps the project
managers about different crucial
activities involved in a project after
this we have excel milestone tracker the
milestone tracker helps us in tracking
or monitoring different tasks in a
project project managers use this
template to monitor the project
performance with respect to the
timelines the last template we will see
is excel project planner excel project
planner includes a list of tasks with
the respected owners along with the
start date and the end date of that task
this helps in monitoring each task and
comparing the estimated task date with
the actual ones let's have a look at
this template in excel we can see the
gantt chart with respect to the data
entered let's make changes at several
places in the data we can make this 22
to 24 we will make this 23 go to 2 and
we can make this 5th september go to 15
september and when we make the changes
we can realize the gantt chart is
fluctuating so this is how we can use
this template to plan a project
effectively and efficiently in this
lesson we will focus on project time
management let us begin with the
objectives of this lesson
after completing this lesson you will be
able to
define project time management
explain project schedule get charts and
network diagrams
identify the key terms used in project
time management
describe the project time management
processes
explain various schedule network
analysis techniques
in the next screen let us take a quick
look at the project management process
map
there are 47 processes in project
management grouped into 10 knowledge
areas and mapped to five process groups
in this lesson we will look at the third
knowledge area that is project time
management and its processes
let us begin with the first topic of
this lesson
project time management
the purpose of project time management
is to ensure that the projects get
completed on time
this knowledge area is primarily
concerned with developing a project
schedule and ensuring that project goes
as per the agreed schedule
if there is a need to change the project
schedule the change should happen by
following a proper change control
procedure
another term used in the pmp examination
is schedule management plan
schedule management plan is part of the
project management plan and has
information on the planned project
schedule and its management and control
let us discuss the key activities of
project time management in the next
screen
the key activities that are part of the
project time management include
identifying activities estimating time
and resources and sequencing activities
it is important to identify a list of
activities that would be a part of the
project
next an estimation of time and resources
required for completing the identified
activities are done
finally these activities need to be
sequenced as per the dependencies
in the next screen let us discuss
project schedule
project schedule represents the time
dimension of the project plan and has
information like when the project would
start when each of the project
activities would happen
in what order the project activities
would happen
when project would be completed etc
usually software system is used to
develop the project schedule
the project team can enter the list of
activities in the software as well as
their dependencies and the software can
produce the project schedule as the
output microsoft project is the most
popular tool used for project schedule
development generally project schedule
is considered similar to project
management plan
project management plan is different
from project schedule
project management plan not only has
information about the project's schedule
but also other important project related
plans like risk management plan cost
management plan etc
let us focus on gantt chart in the next
screen
gantt chart is a type of bar chart that
illustrates a project schedule
it shows the dependencies between the
project activities as well as their
percent completion
a sample gantt chart is shown on the
screen
two summary elements of the work
breakdown structure are depicted
to complete those elements there are a
number of activities under them
some of these activities have
dependencies for example activity b and
c have a dependency
activity c can start only when activity
b is completed
the chart gives you an idea about when
specific activities are planned to
finish
and when the overall wbs element will
get delivered
create tasks and work with the gantt
chart this will make answering gantt
chart based questions easy and fun
in the next screen let us understand the
relationships that exist among project
activities
network diagram is extensively used in
the project time management knowledge
area to plot the activity dependencies
this is a graphical representation of
the project activities in the form of a
network
there are two ways to draw a network
diagram
in precedence diagramming model pdm or
activity on node aon
boxes represent activities and the
arrows indicate the dependency
this type of network can have all four
types of relationships between the
activities
in arrow diagramming model adm or
activity on arrow aoa
the arrows represent activities the
relationships and sequences can be
inferred from the direction of the
arrows and linkages between the
activities
in such types of network only finish to
start relationships can be shown
such diagrams may need to make use of
dummy activities to indicate some
dependency between the activities
there may be questions in the pmp exam
based on the network diagram so create
and work with the diagram
this will make answering network diagram
based questions easy and fun
in the next screen let us look at a
network diagram
a sample network diagram is shown on the
screen
activities a and c can happen in
parallel
b and d require both a and c to complete
whereas e requires both b and d to
complete activity on aero network
diagram makes use of hammock activities
they are used to show a comprehensive
summary activity combining several other
activities underneath for control and
reporting purposes in the next screen
let us look at a few important terms in
time management
when a successor activity can start
before the predecessor activity can
complete it is considered lead for
example you can start preparing the test
environment two weeks before the
development activity finishes
when the successor activity has to wait
for a few days after the predecessor
activity has been completed it is
considered lag
for example one needs to wait for two
days for the foundation to settle before
work on the pillars for the next floor
starts
rolling wave planning is an iterative
planning technique in which the work to
be accomplished in the near term is
planned in detail while the work in the
future is planned at a higher level it
is a form of progressive elaboration
in the context of estimating techniques
analogous estimating is based on the
previous project data
therefore if the last five similar
projects took six months to complete the
next one will also take six months
this technique employs expert judgment
another estimating technique is
parametric estimating
this technique uses a mathematical model
to calculate projected time for an
activity based on the historical records
from previous projects and other
information
a few common parameters are identified
based on the previous project data
and that parameter is used to predict
the time required to complete the next
activity or project for example you can
normally complete 10 kilometers of
highway construction lanes a week
effort is the total amount of work
required to complete the activity
duration is the amount of time it takes
in terms of a lab store calendar days
if you have an activity that requires 10
people to work for 5 days the total
effort is 50 person days but the
duration is only 5 days
in the next screen let us look at the
project time management processes
there are seven project time management
processes
they are plan schedule management define
activities
sequence activities
estimate activity resources
estimate activity durations develop
schedule and control schedule
the first six processes are executed
during the planning process group
the ultimate goal of these planning
processes is to develop the project
schedule
the seventh and the last process is a
part of the monitoring and controlling
process group
in the next few screens let us discuss
these processes in detail
we will begin with plan schedule
management
as defined in pmbok guide plan schedule
management is the process of
establishing the policies procedures and
documentation for planning developing
managing executing and controlling the
project schedule
it belongs to the planning process group
let us look at the inputs to this
process
the project management plan provides
other subsidiary plans and will guide
the schedule planning activities on the
project
the project charter provides an overall
context and the high level product and
project description which might help
determine the approach for schedule
management
few projects might have scheduling
constraint
for example
projects of olympics 2016 should be
completed at the same time
enterprise environmental factors provide
the organizational context to the
project including the culture of the
organization the infrastructure like
scheduling systems available key
personnel and so on organizational
process assets provide inputs such as
policies and procedures
templates past performance data and
estimates historical information and
knowledge base
now let us look at the tools and
techniques employed in this process
expert judgment refers to input received
from knowledgeable and experienced
resources
experts can draw from their previous
experiences the proper approach to
govern the schedule on a project
meetings may be organized to determine
the schedule management plan
anybody responsible for the project
schedule management such as the project
manager sponsor customer and other
stakeholders must attend these meetings
several analytical techniques may be
used to determine the schedule
management plan
these may include different planning
approaches and philosophies such as
rolling wave planning or
different scheduling software that
allowed to build
what-if scenarios
and study the effect of advanced
scheduling techniques like leveling fast
tracking and crashing
now let us look at the outputs of this
process
schedule management plan is a component
of the project management plan that
describes the criteria and activities
required to arrive at the project
schedule
as well as how the project may be
baselined monitored and controlled
in the next screen let us define
activities process
define activities is the process of
identifying the specific actions to be
performed
to produce the project deliverables
it belongs to the planning process group
the important input for the define
activities process is the scope baseline
scope baseline is a term used
collectively to refer to project
deliverables constraints and assumptions
of the project
in addition to the scope baseline the
other inputs in this process are
enterprise environmental factors
organizational process assets and
schedule management plan
a reason why enterprise environmental
factors is an input to define activities
is because the organization might be
using project management software to
define activities and that may influence
the activity definition process the
knowledge base containing historical
information regarding activities lists
used by previous similar projects is a
good example of organization process
assets applied to scheduling
the tools and techniques used in
defining activities are decomposition
and rolling wave planning
the last technique is expert judgment
where the experience of project team
members is used in developing detailed
activity lists
the output of the process is activity
list activity attributes and milestone
list
activity list contains a list of
identified activities
activity attributes are the additional
information about the activity itself
a milestone is a significant point or
event in the project
a milestone list identifies all the
milestones and indicates whether the
milestone is mandatory
or optional
let us move on to the next process
sequence activities
sequence activities is the process of
identifying and documenting
relationships among the project
activities and is also part of the
planning process group
for every activity and milestone except
the first and last one is connected to
or at least one predecessor and one
successor
the inputs to this process are activity
list activity attributes and milestone
list
all these are the outputs of the define
activity process
the other inputs are schedule management
plan and project scope statement
schedule management plan provides
guidance in terms of methodology to be
employed for many of the scheduling
activities on the project
organization process assets are also an
input to sequencing activities because
the organization might have some kind of
knowledge base for scheduling project
activities
the enterprise environmental factors
relevant to this process may be
scheduling tools in use
project management information systems
work authorization systems etc
one of the important tools and
techniques used in sequencing activities
is the precedence diagramming method
in this method the activities are drawn
on a network diagram and all the
different kinds of dependencies between
the activities are determined
while determining activity dependency it
is important to identify the type of
relationship or dependency between the
activities
the other technique is leads and lag
which is widely used for sequencing
activities
the output of the process is the project
schedule network diagram
which is a graphical representation of
the project activities in a form of
network which also shows the activity
dependencies
while designing the network diagram new
activities might be identified and that
would result in some of the project
document updates especially the ones
that list all the project activities
in the next screen let us look at the
estimate activity resources process
after sequencing the activities the next
step in project time management is
estimating the resources required to
accomplish each of the identified
activities estimate activity resources
process also belongs to the planning
process group
here resources do not mean only the
human resources but includes all other
resources like equipment raw materials
machinery etc
schedule management plan is the first
input
schedule management plan provides
guidance in terms of methodology to be
employed for many of the scheduling
activities on the project
the other inputs to this process are an
activity list and activity attributes
that are the outputs of the time
management processes
risk register is another input
risks to the project may influence the
decisions about the resources that need
to be deployed hence risk register
becomes an input to this project
in addition activity cost estimates are
another input
cost and resource estimates on a project
are interrelated and influence each
other
for example the cost might dictate the
number and type of resources that can be
employed or the time might dictate the
cost that may need to be incurred
along with this the resource calendar is
also an important input because it has
the information about the availability
of each of the resources
some of the enterprise environmental
factors that can influence estimating
activity resources are
availability of required resources
within the organization
the organizational process assets is
also an important input
as the organization might have standard
policies for staffing or for hiring
contractors on the project
with all these inputs available for
estimating activity resources
there are various techniques used for
estimating the required resources
the first technique is using expert
judgment
in this technique an expert in resource
planning and estimating can estimate
each of the activities
the next technique used is alternative
analysis
in this the activities are analyzed to
identify different ways of completing
them
this is to ensure only the required
resources are assigned to each of the
activities
this helps in resource optimization
along with the two techniques many
organizations routinely publish their
estimating data and this could be used
in activity resource estimation
another technique that is routinely used
in activity estimation is bottom-up
estimating
which is decomposing the activity
further down to understand it in more
detail and estimating at that level
later all such estimates are added to
arrive at the estimate of the activity
in real projects one has to use all the
estimate each of the activities
sometimes the project management
software also helps in estimating
the software estimates are based on the
inputs provided to it
software should only be considered as a
supporting tool in estimation and never
fully rely on its output
clearly the output of this process is
the activity resource requirements
along with this resource breakdown
structure is also prepared
the resource breakdown structure is the
categorization of all the required
resources in various categories
that is human resources equipment raw
materials etc
in the process of estimation several
other project documents may also be
updated
for example the resource estimates are
directly correlated with cost estimates
let us now move on to the next process
estimate activity durations
the next process is to estimate the
duration required to complete each of
the activities
the duration estimation should be done
by someone who is familiar with the
project
for example the same activity if done by
a high skilled resource would take less
time compared to a less skilled resource
this may vary regardless of the resource
used due to the project requirements
in addition the activity duration
estimation should be updated
continuously as you move ahead with the
project
because as the project progresses there
will be more clarity on the project
the inputs of this process are similar
to the ones in sequence activities
process
schedule management plan is the first
input
schedule management plan provides
guidance in terms of methodology to be
employed for many of the scheduling
activities on the project
for instance it may contain information
about the estimation techniques to be
employed
and the people who need to be involved
in the estimation process
activity resource requirements is also
an input to this process because
resources assigned to an activity would
significantly affect the activity
duration
that is the lower skilled resources
would take more time than the high
skilled resources
the other inputs include activity list
activity attributes and resource
breakdown structure resource calendars
are also an input to this process
the type and skill set of resources
available to the team may have an impact
on the time it would take to complete
the activities
risks to the project may influence the
decisions about the time required to
complete the activity
hence risk register becomes an input to
this process
the project scope statement defines the
constraints and assumptions affecting
the project duration
an example of enterprise environmental
factor that can affect duration is
organizations productivity metrics
which is collected based on the
experiences from multiple projects
the last input in this process is
organizational process assets
now let us look at the tools and
techniques used for estimating activity
durations
first is the expert judgment which means
using previous project experiences and
estimating the current project duration
this can be used with other estimation
techniques and used to reconcile
differences if different techniques
result in different estimates
three-point estimating is a method where
three estimates are used instead of one
it is part of a project management
philosophy known as program evaluation
and review technique
pert
estimating activity durations is often
done as a team exercise as each activity
may require multiple skill sets to be
applied
therefore it is important to use group
decision making techniques to arrive at
a consensus or at least an estimate that
is acceptable to all the team members
reserve analysis adds buffer into the
project schedule to deal with any
uncertainty the contingency reserve may
be added as a percentage of the activity
duration or fixed number of work periods
the other tools and techniques are
analogous estimating and parametric
estimating
the outputs of this process are the
activity duration estimates and project
documents updates
the activity duration estimates is
represented in terms of the range of
possible results for example
10 days plus minus two days that is the
activity would take minimum eight days
and maximum twelve days
in the next screen let us look into a
business scenario to understand this
concept better
after reading the problem statement
click the solution button to look at a
possible answer
develop schedule is the process of
analyzing activity sequences durations
resource requirements and schedule
constraints to create the project
schedule
it belongs to the planning process group
generally scheduling software is used
for developing the project schedule
entering the activities durations and
resources into a scheduling tool
generates a schedule with planned dates
for completing project activities
developing a project schedule is an
iterative process
revising and maintaining a realistic
schedule is a task in itself and it
continues throughout the project as the
work progresses
the most of the inputs of this process
are the outputs of estimate activity
durations process
they are risk register project scope
statement project staff assignments
resources calendars organizational
process assets
enterprise environmental factors
schedule management plan
activity list
activity attributes
project schedule network diagrams
activity resource requirements
resource breakdown structure and
activity duration estimates
various tools and techniques are used to
develop schedule process
schedule network analysis is a technique
that generates project schedule
it employs various analytical techniques
such as critical path method critical
chain method modeling techniques and
resource optimization techniques to
create the project schedule
the other tools and techniques include
leads and lags schedule compression and
scheduling tool
let us now look at the outputs of this
process
the project schedule consists of a
minimum plan start date and planned
finish date for each activity
although project schedule can be
represented in tabular format it is more
often represented graphically using
either bar charts or network diagrams
or a combination of the two
the final schedule which is the output
of the developed schedule process is
also called schedule baseline
once the schedule is baselined it can be
changed only through formal approvals
meeting the schedule baseline is one of
the measures of project success
scheduled data produced may include
number of resources key milestones etc
project calendars specify the available
working days and the number of shifts in
each day
it indicates how many hours and days are
available for the work of the project to
be completed
project management plan updates are a
result of the develop schedule process
many of the other subsidiary plans of
the project plan may get impacted which
may include cost management plan scope
management plan risk management plan etc
this may also result in other project
documents being updated
in the next few screens let us discuss
schedule network analysis techniques
it is essential to know if the required
resources are available at that time
along with the time estimate of each of
the activities
since schedule is calendar based it
helps in estimating the same
schedule network analysis technique
generates project schedule
there are various schedule network
techniques
critical path method relies on
determining the critical path on a
project schedule
critical chain method is a variant of
the critical path method wherein the
critical chain is determined based on
the logical resource and other kinds of
dependencies between the activities
what if scenario analysis is about
trying to vary a certain parameter to
observe the impact on the schedule
for instance you may want to check
result if you put in more resources on a
particular activity to reduce its
duration
resource optimization techniques try to
arrive at the optimal utilization of the
resources used on a project
ideally you would want the resources to
be fully utilized but you would also
want to build insufficient buffers in
case a certain resource is not available
due to various reasons
in the next screen let us look at the
program evaluation and review technique
program evaluation and review technique
is based on three-point estimates for an
activity
the pessimistic estimate refers to the
worst case scenario
whereas most likely estimate is what you
expect to happen in a realistic scenario
the optimistic estimate on the other
hand represents the amount of time an
activity would take in the best case
scenario
based on these three estimates the
expected duration of the estimate is
calculated as per the formula given on
the screen
the formula for calculating standard
deviation of an activity and variance of
an activity is also given
there is no question asked on variance
but the formula is important because if
the standard deviation of the whole
project is to be calculated the process
is to calculate the variance of the
whole project and then take its square
root to calculate the standard deviation
of the project
concept-based questions on pert can be
expected in the pmp exam
so make a note of the formulae while you
prepare for the exam
in the next screen let us understand
pert with an example
let us now figure out how we can apply
the three-point estimation that pert
uses in order to draw some useful
conclusions
assume that the optimistic pessimistic
and most likely estimates are 20 70 and
30 respectively
using these values you can determine the
expected duration and the standard
deviation as indicated
now if the causes of variation are
random you can assume that the actual
values would be evenly distributed about
the mean
and will follow the normal distribution
sometimes referred to as the bell curve
further you can use the properties of
the normal distribution
there is a 68 probability of the actual
value falling within first sigma from
the mean
95.4 percent probability for the second
sigma
and 99.7 percent probability of the
actual value falling within third sigma
extending this logic the notion of six
sigma is reaching a level of confidence
that only 3.4 times out of a million
would the actual value fall outside the
stated range pert allows you to plan
based on the intended level of
confidence in the outcome and determine
buffers accordingly
let us discuss the critical path method
in the next screen
critical path is defined as the longest
duration path through a network diagram
which determines the shortest time to
complete the project
float can be considered as a buffer time
available to complete an activity
float is calculated once the network
diagram is ready
it is also called as slack
there are three kinds of float
the first being the total float which is
the amount of time an activity can be
delayed without delaying the project end
date or an intermediary milestone
the second type of float is free float
which is the amount of time an activity
can be delayed without delaying the
early start date of its successor or
successors activities
the last type is independent float which
is the amount of time an activity can be
delayed if all the predecessors finish
at their latest finish dates and you
want to start all the immediate
successors at their earliest start dates
the slack of the activities on the
critical path is zero
because there is no scope to delay
activities on the critical path
critical path actually represents the
project duration delaying activities on
the critical path is as good as delaying
the project duration
concept-based questions on critical path
can be expected in the exam so it is
essential to have a clear understanding
of the concept
in the next screen let us learn how to
calculate float
float of an activity can be calculated
by two methods
however the first step in critical path
method is to identify the critical path
of the network
once the critical path is identified
follow the forward pass to find early
start and early finish for each activity
the float of the activities on the
critical path is zero
so they represent the overall project
duration
use forward pass or backward pass to
calculate the total activity time
calculate late finish and late start
using backward pass method
note the total float formula before you
start for the exam
in the next screen let us look at
forward pass and backward pass methods
in detail
in forward pass you can either go
through the network starting with time
zero and keep calculating the time
required to complete each of the
activities until you reach the last
activity of the project
the starting time for each of the
activity in this approach is called
early start and the end time for each
activity is called the early finish
alternatively in backward pass you can
travel through the network from the
project end date and calculate the time
required to complete each activity
the end date in this approach is called
the late finish and the start date of
the activity in this approach is called
the late start
the float of the activity is either the
difference between the late start and
early start or the difference between
the late finish and early finish
both the differences work out to be the
same
before the start of the pmp exam please
make a note of the total float formula
let us understand the critical path
calculation with an example in the next
screen
let us look at an example for critical
path
there are five activities in this
project and two paths in the network
diagram
start
one two four five and is one path
and start one three five and is the
second path
since the duration of the path start 1 2
4 5 end is 18 days which is more than
the duration of the path start 1 3 5 and
the critical path of the project is
start one two four five end
let us take activity three as an example
first calculate the early start and
early finish dates
activity three can start only after
activity 1.
since the early finish of activity 1 is
3 it becomes the early start of activity
3.
activity 3 cannot start earlier than 3
because activity 1 can be completed only
by then
therefore early start of activity 3 is 3
since the duration of the activity is 4
days
the early finish of activity 3 is 3 plus
4 equals seven days
now let us calculate the late start and
late finish of activity three
late start of activity five is fourteen
days
the activity three happens just before
activity five
so the late finish of activity 3 is 14
days
to calculate the late start you can
subtract the duration from late finish
therefore the late start of activity 3
is 14 minus four equals ten
in the next screen let us focus on
schedule compression
look at the four activities in the table
the normal cost of executing each of the
activities as well as how much each of
the activities can be crashed is also
provided
which activity would you crash to reduce
the project time by one day
activity a will be crashed if the
duration of the project is reduced by
one day as the per unit cost of crashing
the activity a is the least
all the activities are assumed to be on
the critical path here
while crashing if you end up saving time
on a path which is not the critical path
you will not end up saving time on the
project
in the next screen let us look into the
impact of schedule compression
different schedule compression
techniques have different impact on the
project
the impact of fast track leads to risk
additions and increase in management
time for the project manager
crash leads to cost addition and
increase in management time for the
project manager
reduce scope on the other hand saves
cost and resources but increases
customer dissatisfaction
likewise cut quality saves cost and
resources but increases risk resource
reallocation does not add cost or
increase risk
in the next screen
let us look into the other techniques
used in scheduling
there are several techniques that are
used in scheduling projects
what-if scenario analysis
in this technique questions like
what if a particular scenario changed on
the project would that produce a shorter
schedule
are put forth to understand the impact
of specific changes on the schedule the
goal is to produce a realistic schedule
monte carlo analysis
in this method a computer simulates the
outcomes of a project making use of
randomly generated values that map the
probability distribution of the input
variables
together these two techniques are called
modeling techniques
resource optimization techniques
these are also used to produce a
resource limited schedule
resource optimization results in more
stable number of resources used in the
project
critical chain method
this technique develops the project
schedule that takes into account both
the activity and resource dependencies
in the next screen let us look at the
last process in project time management
control schedule control schedule is
concerned with determining the status of
the project schedule determining that
the project schedule has changed and
managing the actual changes as they
occur
the project schedule is an important
input to this process
it is the actual schedule that needs to
be controlled
scheduled data contains information
related to the schedule that may need to
be monitored in order to take actions to
bring the project back on schedule
project calendar describes the working
hours and days for the project
work performance data has information
like which activities have started their
progress and which activities have
finished
the other inputs of this process are
project management plan and
organizational process assets
the key tools and techniques of this
process are the performance reviews
performance review is measuring
comparing and analyzing schedule
performance such as actual start and
finish dates percent complete and
remaining duration for work in progress
the other tools and techniques include
resource optimization techniques
modeling techniques schedule compression
leads and lags scheduling tool
and project
management software
in development schedule process
these techniques are used for the first
time to develop the project schedule
whereas in control schedule process
these techniques are used to update the
project schedule
the key output of the control schedule
process is the
work performance information
this is represented in the form of
schedule variants sv and schedule
performance index spi
as a part of the control schedule
process
the project team will generate forecasts
likely schedule for forthcoming
activities and project as a whole
the other outputs include organizational
process assets updates
change requests
project management plan updates and
project document updates in the next
screen let us look into a business
scenario to understand this concept
better after reading the problem
statement click the solution button to
look at a possible answer
here is a quick recap of what was
covered in this lesson
project time management includes the
processes required to manage the timely
completion of the project
a project schedule defines the start and
end dates of the project and the project
activities these activities are assigned
a duration and sequenced in a logical
order
gantt charts and network diagrams are
used to identify project activities and
determine the relationships and
dependencies between them
gat chart displays the start and end
dates of project activities the overall
project schedule and the logical task
relationships while network diagram is
used to plot the activity dependencies
plan schedule management define
activities sequence activities estimate
activity resources estimate activity
durations
develop schedule and control schedule
are the seven processes under project
time management
schedule network analysis technique
generates project schedule based on the
estimates of time and resource
requirements in this lesson we will
focus on project cost management
let us begin with the objectives of this
lesson
after completing this lesson you will be
able to
define project cost management
differentiate between cost estimation
and cost budgeting
explain control accounts
describe the project cost management
processes
apply earned value management technique
to track project performance
identify key terminologies used in
project cost management
in the next screen let us take a quick
look at the project management process
map
there are 47 processes in project
management grouped into 10 knowledge
areas and mapped to five process groups
in this lesson we will look at the
fourth knowledge area that is project
cost management and its processes
in the next screen let us understand the
concept of project cost management
project cost management involves
activities like estimating the cost of
each of the project activities adding
the cost estimates of the related
activities to arrive at the cost budget
and controlling the cost to ensure that
project activities are completed within
the defined budget in the next screen
let us discuss cost management plan
the cost management plan is a vital step
in project cost management it contains
information like planning the project
cost managing and controlling the
project in relation to the cost baseline
and managing cost variances
project cost management plan is a part
of the project management plan
the methods used in estimating the cost
of each of the project activities are
similar to the ones used in estimating
project time
for example
time estimation methods like expert
judgment analogous estimating bottom up
estimating and reserve analysis are few
of the techniques that are also used in
estimating activity cost
let us discuss control account in the
next screen
control account is an important concept
in the project cost management
project cost is generally estimated at
individual activity level
it becomes difficult to manage cost at
the activity level in large projects
therefore the cost is managed at a
higher level
this requires related activities to be
clubbed
and their cost being managed together as
one unit
this unit is called control account
while estimating the project time
wbs is created to break down the project
into smaller deliverables
these deliverables are broken down into
work packages and these work packages
are in turn broken into activities
control account is defined at a level
higher than the work packages for
example
if five work packages are part of the
one control account
the cost of all activities belonging to
these five work packages are managed as
one unit
in the next screen let us discuss the
project cost management process
project cost management has four
processes
they are plan cost management estimate
costs determine budget and control costs
the three processes plan cost management
estimate costs and determined budget are
a part of planning process group and
control cost process is a part of
monitoring and controlling process group
let us look at each of these processes
in detail
let us begin with the first process that
is plan cost management in the next
screen
managing costs on a project is a
critical exercise if the activities are
planned well it becomes easier to
achieve harmony with the overall cost
and budget of the project
plan cost management is the process of
establishing the policies procedures and
documentation for planning managing
expending and controlling the project
costs
let us look at the inputs required for
this process
the project management plan provides
other subsidiary plans and guides the
cost planning activities on the project
the project charter provides an overall
context and high level product and
project description
which help determine the approach for
cost management
for example
for some projects budget could be a
constraint whereas for others budget
would not be a constraint but subject to
the other objectives
enterprise environmental factors provide
the organizational context to the
project
including the culture of the
organization and the infrastructure for
instance the scheduling systems
available the key personnel and so on
organizational process assets provide
inputs such as policies and procedures
templates past performance data and
estimates historical information and
knowledge base
now let us look at the tools and
techniques employed in this process
expert judgment refers to input received
from knowledgeable and experienced
resources
experts can devise an approach to govern
the costs on a project by using their
previous experiences
meetings may be organized to determine
the cost management plan
everyone responsible for the project
schedule management such as the project
manager representatives from the
appropriate accounting or financial
organization sponsor customer and other
stakeholders must attend these meetings
several analytical techniques may be
used to determine the cost management
plan
these techniques help to map the impact
of various decisions on cost
for example how do risk management
processes impact cost etc
cost management plan is the primary
output of this process
it establishes the units of measure
levels of precision organizational
process links control accounts to be
used rules for performance measurement
and reporting frequency and methodology
of monitoring the costs and various
other details that lay the overall
framework for cost management on a
project
in the next screen let us discuss the
second process under project cost
management
estimate cost
estimate cost is the approximation of
the monetary resources required to
complete a project activity
cost of a specific activity is estimated
based on the information available at
that point of time
as the project team gets more
information about the project the
activity cost estimation may change
let us look at the inputs of this
process
scope baseline is the most important
input as it details out the project
scope of work
along with that project schedule is also
important
this contains information like when and
which resource is required for the
project it is good to remember that the
same kind of resources may have
different costs at different points of
time
human resource management plan is
another important input
various elements like personnel rates
rewards or recognition programs etcetera
are covered in the human resource
management plan which is important in
approximating the cost estimate
human resource management plan will be
discussed in detail in the human
resource management knowledge area
risk register is also an input because
risk mitigation costs should be
considered in cost planning
more information on risk and its effect
in the project will be looked at in
detail in risk management knowledge area
another input enterprise environmental
factors provides organizational context
to the project
organization process asset is listed as
an input as organizations might have
standard set of cost estimation policies
or templates
cost management plan is another
important input
the cost management plan lays the
framework for the cost management
processes in the project
it provides guidelines such as the units
of measure accuracy desired
methodologies and tools to be used etc
let us now look at the tools and
techniques used in this process
expert judgment reserve analysis
analogous estimating cost of quality
parametric estimating project management
software
up estimating three point estimating
vendor bid analysis and group decision
making are the various tools and
techniques used in this process
most of the tools and techniques used
here are similar to the ones used in the
time management knowledge area
vendor bid analysis is a technique used
to estimate project cost
for example a project requires material
procured externally through suppliers in
order to get that you invite bids from
three or four suppliers and assess their
quotations
based on their quotations you can get an
idea of the cost that will be involved
in getting the material for the project
group decision making technique is
another important technique for project
cost estimation
cost estimation is an exercise which may
be carried out by a group or committee
in order to gather well-rounded input
therefore group decision making
techniques may be used to arrive at a
decision that team can work with
the outputs of this process are quite
straightforward
estimates of each of the activities are
arrived at
basis of the estimate includes things
like how the estimate was developed what
were the assumptions made in estimating
etc
project document updates is also one of
the outputs because the cost estimates
may result in updates to other aspects
of the project for example quality risk
time etc
in the next screen let us discuss the
third process under project cost
management determine budget
once the estimate of each of the
activities is arrived at the next
project cost management process is to
determine budget
it is the process of aggregating the
estimated cost of individual activities
or work packages to establish an
authorized cost baseline
this is where the control account
concept comes into picture
the estimated costs of the activities
are aggregated to arrive at the cost
budget at the control account level once
approved this cost budget becomes the
cost baseline of the project
project cost performance is measured
against the cost baseline that is how
much more would the project cost be
compared to the original cost baseline
the cost baseline includes all
authorized budgets but excludes
management reserves
the inputs used in determining the
project budget are the activity cost
estimates and the basis of estimates
which are the output of the previous
cost management process
the cost management plan lays the
framework for the cost management
processes in the project
it provides guidelines such as the
budgeting cycle tools and techniques
used to prepare and approve the budget
etcetera
in addition to these two important
inputs scope baseline is also looked at
project schedule provides aggregate cost
in a particular calendar period to
ensure how much money can be made
available during that time
similarly
resource calendar provides information
on the resource which is assigned to the
project at a particular point of time
this information is then used to
indicate resource costs over the
duration of the project
risk register gives an understanding of
the overall level of risk on the project
and
therefore the level of contingency
reserves that need to be built into the
budget
agreements entered into with the
suppliers are also required to finalize
the budget
again organizational process asset is an
input because organization may have few
policies for reporting the cost budget
or there might be some cost budgeting
tools being used
there are various tools and techniques
used in determining budgets
cost aggregation technique involves
adding up the cost and aggregating them
at the control account level
so that the cost can be managed in a
better way
in reserve analysis once the costs are
estimated some extra amount is added to
the estimate as a management reserve to
take care of any unplanned activities
expert judgment is a technique in which
an expert's help is sought to estimate
the activity cost
expert is someone who might have worked
on a similar project in the past and has
a good idea to estimate the activity
cost involved
historical relationships are used to
predict the total project cost using
mathematical model this is similar to
analogous estimate or parametric
estimate method
funding limit reconciliation technique
is used to ensure that cost on the
project is budgeted or spent as per the
availability of the fund for example if
the project can get the funding of only
fifty thousand dollars a month the
project budget should be planned
accordingly
the output of this process is the cost
baseline
this is an authorized project budget
over a period
this is used to measure monitor and
control overall cost performance of the
project
in addition to this the project funding
requirements are also arrived at funding
requirements means how much fund the
project requires monthly quarterly or
yearly for the execution
the last output of this process is
project document updates
an understanding of determining budget
may be useful when answering questions
in the pmp exam so make a note of the
inputs tools and techniques and outputs
of determining budget
in the next screen let us discuss the
last process of project cost management
that is control cost
control costs is the process of
monitoring the status of the project to
update the project budget and managing
changes to the cost baseline
updating the budget involves recording
actual costs spent until date
any increase to the authorized budget
can only be approved through the perform
integrated change control process
some of the typical activities that
happen as part of the control cost
process
are ensuring that cost expenditure does
not exceed the authorized funding
monitor the cost performance to
understand variants and monitoring the
work performance against the funds
expended
the inputs to the process are project
management plan
organizational process assets
project funding requirements and work
performance data
performance data contains the
information about the project progress
the important tools and techniques used
in controlling costs are
earned value analysis management
forecasting to complete performance
index
other important aspects of controlling
costs are the review the performance
analyze the reserves to make sure the
project has enough budgetary reserves to
meet the expenses and project management
software which helps in tracking and
managing costs
now
let us look at the output of this
process
the key outputs of this process are work
performance information in terms of cost
variance cv
schedule variance sv and earned value ev
and forecasts about the cost performance
this process may also result in change
requests arising out of cost control
measures as well as updates to project
documents the project management plan
and organizational process assets
business scenario based questions on
project cost control can be expected in
the exam so if you have questions on
these concepts get them cleared as that
will help you score higher
in the next screen let us learn about
earned value management and its related
terms
earned value technique is an excellent
way to track the project progress
against the project plan
it is a method of measuring the project
performance objectively and comparing it
against the project baseline
results from an earned value analysis
indicate deviation of the project from
cost and schedule baselines
baseline is the initial approved value
along with approved changes
therefore schedule baseline is the first
approved project schedule along with
approved changes
there are various terms used in earned
value technique
planned value is the authorized budget
assigned to the scheduled work
earned value is the work performed in
terms of budget authorized for that work
actual cost is the cost incurred in work
performed
budget at completion is the budgeted
amount for the total work
estimate at completion is the expected
total cost for the project
estimate to complete is the expected
cost to finish all the remaining project
work
variance at completion is the projected
budget surplus or deficit
at the end of the project
all the parameters displayed on the
screen are measured in terms of cost
you may come across business scenario
based questions on earned value
management in the pmp exam so ensure
that you develop a clear understanding
of this topic
let us look at an example of a planned
value in the next screen
planned value is the estimated value of
the work planned
this value is measured in terms of
currency say dollar if the plan value is
three hundred forty dollars then the
work plan is worth three hundred forty
dollars
how do you calculate earned value the
solution is
add the budget allocated to each of the
activities that have been completed at
the point of time
the resulting value is the earned value
in the next screen let us look at the
formula used to calculate earned value
in cost variance negative means the
project is over budget
positive means the project is under
budget
similarly in schedule variance negative
means the project is behind schedule
whereas positive means the project is
ahead of schedule
the value of the next two parameters
cost performance index cpi and schedule
performance index spi values vary
between zero and one
for example a cpi of 0.8 implies that 80
cents of work is obtained for every
dollar spent in the project
similarly if spi is 0.9
it implies that project is progressing
at only 90 percent of the speed
originally planned
the next parameter is estimate at
completion or eac
there are different ways of calculating
the eac value the method used depends on
how the cost and schedule variances are
expected to play for the rest of the
project
bac by cpi is used if you expect that
the current cost performance will
continue until the end of the project
ac plus bac minus ev is used if you
expect that the rest of the project will
be managed at the budgeted rate
ac plus
bac minus ev by the product of cpi and
sbi
is used if you want to factor in the
impact of the cost as well as schedule
variances
ac plus etc is used if you want to
re-evaluate the project based on a
forecast value for the estimated cost of
the remainder of the project
the next parameter is estimate to
complete or etc
which is the cost of project from this
point to the end
this is calculated by subtracting the
actual cost from the estimate at
completion
in addition variance at completion can
be calculated by subtracting the
estimate at completion from the budget
at completion variance at completion is
the cost estimation whether it is over
or under budget
another parameter is the to complete
performance index or tcpi
this is the cost performance needed to
achieve a desired outcome
for example
if the project needs to be managed to
the original budget bac then tcpi that
is the cpi that must be maintained for
the rest of the project is calculated as
bac minus ev by bac minus ac
similarly if it has to be managed within
a revised target say eac
then tcpi is calculated as
bac minus ev by eac minus ac
before the start of the pmp exam please
make a note of the formulas of earned
value technique
in the next screen let us look into a
business scenario to understand this
concept better after reading the problem
statement click the solution button to
look at a possible answer
let us take the example of a software
development project there are four
phases and each phase takes a month to
complete and is expected to cost ten
thousand dollars
the phases are planned to be completed
one after the other the status of the
project at the end of the month three is
summarized in the table
requirements definition is completed and
actual spending on this is ten thousand
dollars
architecture and design is done and
actual spending on this is twelve
thousand dollars
development and unit testing is only
fifty percent done though it was
supposed to be completed by third month
it has cost nine thousand dollars until
date
system testing and go live has not yet
started
note s indicates start time
f indicates finish time and pf indicates
that it is partly finished at the end of
the month
based on the above information calculate
the cv sv cpi and spi of the project
let us look at a solution in the next
screen
before we end this lesson let us also
look at a few definitions that might be
useful for your pmp examination
law of diminishing return this means the
more you put into something the less you
get out of it for example doubling the
number of resources working on a project
will not necessarily have the time
working capital the amount of money the
company has to invest on the project and
the day-to-day company operations
funding limit reconciliation the process
of comparing the planned expenditure in
a given period with the available
funding for that period
large assets purchased by the company
lose value over time
this is called depreciation
there are two forms of depreciation
straight line and accelerated
same amount of depreciation is taken
every year for instance a car with a
price tag of ten thousand dollars and
useful life of ten years is depreciated
one thousand dollars per year
at the end of the tenth year the value
of the car is considered zero for all
accounting purposes accelerated
depreciation depreciates faster than the
straight-line depreciation for instance
a car with a price tag of ten thousand
dollars depreciates three thousand
dollars the first year one thousand five
hundred the next year one thousand the
third year and so on let us now check
your understanding of the topics covered
in this lesson
here is a quick recap of what was
covered in this lesson
project cost management includes the
processes involved in estimating
budgeting and controlling costs so that
the project can be completed within the
approved budget
cost management plan contains details on
how to plan manage and control the
project cost in relation to the cost
baseline and manage the cost variances
cost estimate is an educated guess of
how much an activity or project will
cost
budget considers the cost estimate and
accordingly sets aside funds for the
completion of the project
under control account technique related
activities are clubbed and their costs
are managed as one unit
the four project cost management
processes are
plan cost management estimate costs
determine budget control costs
earned value management technique
indicates potential deviation of the
project from the cost and or schedule
baselines in this lesson we will focus
on project quality management let us
begin with the objectives of this lesson
after completing this lesson you will be
able to define quality and quality
management differentiate between quality
planning quality assurance and quality
control
explain cost of quality and its
categories
describe the project quality management
processes
explain the seven basic tools of quality
explain six sigma
in the next screen
let us take a quick look at the project
management process map
there are 47 processes in project
management grouped into 10 knowledge
areas and mapped to five process groups
in this lesson we will look at the fifth
knowledge area that is project quality
management and its processes in the next
screen let us understand what quality is
the project manager is responsible for
quality in a project however it is also
the responsibility of each and every one
in the project to ensure that whatever
they do meets project quality
expectations quality is defined as the
degree to which a set of inherent
characteristics fulfills requirements a
project is said to meet quality
expectations when all the project
requirements agreed in the beginning of
the project are met and the resulting
product is usable
usable means that the intended users can
use the product without any problem in
the next screen let us look at some
quality related terms
it is important to discuss a few terms
to understand the concept of quality
better customer satisfaction is defined
as conformance to requirements and
fitness for use it is important to
understand the subtle distinction
between quality and grade
grade is a classification based on
technical characteristics low quality is
always a problem but low grade may not
be a problem
rather it would be a matter of choice
similarly it is important to understand
the distinction between precision and
accuracy precision is the granularity of
measurement that is how fine grained can
you measure the outcome accuracy is how
correct you are that is how close you
are to the desired value in the next
screen let us understand the concept of
optimal level of quality
quality comes at a cost more effort put
in quality will give better results
however you cannot keep on investing on
increasing the quality as there is no
limit to how much a product can be
improved investment in quality is
determined by knowing the optimal level
of quality
optimal level of quality as shown in the
diagram is said to be achieved at the
point where the incremental revenue from
improvement equals the incremental cost
to secure it suppose you are the
manufacturer of toys but the toys are
below quality and the sales are low to
improve the quality you invest in
identifying the demands of children
sharing few samples and recording their
feedbacks
once all these are captured and
implemented in the products you lure the
parents to buy them as the investment is
increased to manufacture good quality
toys the cost will therefore increase
and it might become prohibitive for
parents to buy
optimal level of quality is reached at a
point where you get maximum number of
buyers for the toys manufactured now
that we are clear on the concept of
quality in the next screen let us
discuss quality management
quality management involves performing
activities like creating standard
policies and procedures and ensuring
that those standard procedures are being
followed properly in the project it aims
to ensure that project meets all the
initial agreed requirements without any
deviation and that the specified
approach to quality is implemented on
the project three broad activities are
done as part of quality management they
are quality planning quality assurance
and quality control
quality planning is the first step when
quality related activities of the
project are planned
quality assurance is the next stage of
implementing those quality plans and
quality control is the last stage when
periodic checks are done to see if
project quality is improving
in the next screen let us look into the
differences between the three aspects of
quality management
it is important to understand the
different kinds of activities that come
under quality planning quality assurance
and quality control
once the quality planning is done the
quality management plan is ready
this quality management plan has
standards templates policies and
procedures to be followed in the project
it contains information on the level of
quality being aimed and the plan to
achieve that level it is the aim of
quality assurance activities to ensure
that the activities planned under
quality planning phase gets executed for
the project it is the task of quality
assurance to determine if the project is
complying with the organizational as
well as project policies and procedures
this is ensured by conducting regular
process audits to identify deviation
from what is planned in the quality
management plan
these audits are generally done by
quality department of the organizations
quality assurance focuses on the process
not on specific products the role of
quality control is to measure specific
project data or results against
standards to inspect and verify the
project's product defect repair and
measure whether quality indicators are
improving
quality control is about the product and
data for example
it was planned as part of quality
management that project would get
completed plus or minus 10 percent
within the cost budget
three months back when the measurement
was done project was over budget by 20
when the measurement was done a day
before it was only 15 percent over
budget
therefore the project has showed an
improvement of five percent in the last
three months and it is quite likely that
over the next three months project may
get within the planned limit of 10
percent
instead of showing improvement if the
data shows cost increase then corrective
and preventative actions are required to
get the project within the ten percent
limit
this is quality control
in the next screen let us discuss a few
quality management concepts
let us look at some terms that are
commonly used in quality management
parlance total quality management or tqm
is a quality management philosophy that
involves holistic thinking about meeting
the objectives of an organization
it places the responsibility of quality
squarely on the management kaizen is a
japanese term that stands for change for
better kaizen philosophy is one that
should always be looking for small and
continuous improvements in the process
deeming cycle or pdca cycle that is plan
do check act
is a process control and improvement
approach propagated by the famous
quality guru edward deming it means you
plan for something executed check the
output and based on the lessons you act
to bring the deviations under control
kanban is a poll-based management system
that originated in japan based on just
in time jit inventory management
the idea behind kanban is to minimize
the work in progress and achieve a
smooth flow in the process from start to
finish because building up inventory
only to paper over the imperfections in
the system tends to hide the problems
in the next screen let us focus on cost
of quality
cost of quality is the cost that needs
to be incurred to make a quality product
the sum of all the costs incurred is
ensuring that project conforms to
requirement is cost of quality
cost of quality can be broken down into
two major categories
first is the cost of conformance or the
money spent during the project to avoid
failures
this can further be subdivided into
prevention costs which is the cost to
prevent errors
like training the team creating
documents on equipment and in time to do
it right the other subdivision is
appraisal costs or the cost for
assessing quality like testing
destructive testing loss and inspections
the second category is the cost of
non-conformance it is the money spent
during and after the project because of
failures this is subdivided into
internal failure costs it is the cost of
failures that occur before the product
is released to customers for example
rework and scrap the second subdivision
is external failure costs it is cost
incurred on failures that occur after it
has been released by the team for
example liabilities warranty work and
lost business
concept based questions on cost of
quality can be expected in the exam so
please make a note of the categories of
cost of quality
let us look at the project quality
management processes in the next screen
there are three project quality
management processes
of which the first process plan quality
management is done as part of the
planning process group the next process
perform quality assurance is done as
part of the executing process group and
the last process control quality is done
as part of the monitoring and
controlling process group
in the next three screens let us look
into each of these processes in detail
the aim of the plan quality management
process is to identify the relevant
requirements or standards to execute the
project effectively to achieve the
desired quality level
quality planning results in the creation
of the quality management plan
aim of the plan quality process is to
identify the standards a standard is an
agreed-upon process to work or achieve a
result a standard can be set from within
the organization or government
once all the standards for the project
are identified the aim of the quality
planning activities involves determining
what work needs to be done to meet those
standards
before adhering to the standards you
should question their relevance with the
project
implementing all possible standards
applicable to the project in random will
have cost and time implications
let us look at the inputs to this
process
the project management plan provides the
scope schedule and cost baseline
all of which have an implication on the
quality management plan
quality plan has a direct correlation
with these
it might also have an impact on and be
impacted by other subsidiary management
plans such as risk management the
stakeholders of the project may have
specific requirements and views about
the quality parameters of the project
and these have to be considered
the risk register gives an indication
about the kind of risks that are
inherent in the project
and also those which must be considered
while planning the activities to ensure
quality the requirements for the project
need to be considered for planning
quality related activities
because quality is all about meeting the
requirements in addition to these
enterprise environmental factors and
organization process assets are also
listed as inputs because the standards
can be either from within the
organization or from government or other
external bodies
standards from within the organizations
are usually the best practices learned
over a period while executing numerous
projects an example of government
standards can be standards to control
air pollution by the motor vehicles
which vehicle manufacturers must adhere
to to accomplish quality planning first
analyze the benefits versus the costs of
meeting quality requirements next
identify the cost of quality and confirm
if that kind of investment in quality is
justified
in addition to these two benchmarking
helps in analyzing the quality of
activities of similar projects executed
in the past this helps in identifying
the particular quality of output of the
previous project which in turn acts as a
basis for the current project's quality
planning
design of experiments can also be used
for quality planning
this is a statistical way to determine
what variables will improve quality the
most for example in case of
manufacturing doors it can be determined
that increasing the quality of the wood
can have maximum impact on improving the
quality of the door in addition the 76
quality tools also known as the seven qc
tools are used to determine the plan to
achieve the desired level of quality
statistical sampling as a tool becomes
relevant whenever the quality plan
cannot be applied to all the artifacts
produced
for example if destructive testing is a
requirement then it can be carried out
only on a sample not on the entire
population
statistical sampling helps in arriving
at a representative sample that can give
useful information
other additional tools such as
brainstorming force field analysis etc
may be used to determine the quality
management plan for the project
conducting regular meetings is another
important tool the quality management
plan has to be determined in a
collaborative manner by consulting the
team members and other stakeholders
quality management plan is a key output
of this process
checklist is a list of items to inspect
for example many of the office buildings
have housekeeping checklists to ensure
that all floors cabins etc are cleaned
checklists are created during quality
planning and used in quality control
metrics are project specific data that
need to be measured to check the status
of the project
the simplest project metrics can be cost
and schedule metrics are also decided
during quality planning and used in
quality control
one of the roles of the project manager
is to not only manage the project but
also improve processes in the project to
decrease the instances of defects which
in turn saves time and money such
activities are listed in the process
improvement plan
which eventually becomes part of project
management plan
as a result of the planning activities
other project documents may also get
updated for example the quality
management plan may result in updates to
the cost or resource requirements
there may be questions in the pmp exam
based on the plan quality management
process so please ensure you have a fair
understanding of the concept before you
take the exam
in the next screen
let us discuss the second quality
management process
once the quality planning is over the
next process and project quality
management is quality assurance which
involves determining whether the
standards are being met and the
processes are being followed therefore
the input for this process is the work
that has been completed during the
quality planning stage
they are project documents quality
management plan
process improvement plan quality metrics
and quality control measurements
let us look at the tools and techniques
used in this process quality audit is
the process to check whether the project
is complying with the organization
policies standards and procedures
and determine whether these policies
standards and procedures used are
efficient and effective so a good audit
not only looks at this compliance but
also for the new lessons learned from
the current project that can help make
the future projects better
process analysis involves using the
lessons learned from doing the initial
few work to make the remaining work more
efficient
for example if the project involves
installing a software package then the
lesson learned from the first few
installations can be used to improve the
process on remaining installations
apart from these all the quality
management and control tools such as the
seven basic quality tools will be
relevant to this process
the key output of this process is
project documents updates to ensure that
if there is any deviation from agreed
standards it is corrected
also if there are any lessons learned
that can help improve the future
projects the organization process assets
get updated
this quality assurance may result in
improvement suggestions change requests
may be generated and the project
management plan may need to be updated
understanding characteristics of quality
assurance tools and techniques may be
useful while answering the exam so
prepare this topic well before you take
the exam
in the next screen
let us discuss the last process of
quality management
the key focus of the quality control
activities is on the correctness of the
work
quality control helps answer questions
like is everything okay with the project
does the project plan require changes to
successfully execute the project
will the project succeed etcetera
let us look at the inputs to this
process
the quality metrics measurements are
done continuously to see whether the
project quality is improving the project
deliverables are inspected against the
planned checklists quality control acts
upon the deliverables and work
performance data produced in execution
it also refers to the project management
plan for understanding deviations from
the plan it also considers the approved
change requests information from other
project documents and organizational
process assets there are seven popular
tools and techniques used in doing the
quality control activities
they are collectively known as seven
basic tools of quality other relevant
tools are statistical sampling
inspection or testing and review of the
approved changes quality control
activities result in quality control
measurements the verified deliverables
validated changes information about the
work being performed recommended changes
and updates to the organizational
process assets project management plan
and other project documents
in the next screen let us look into a
business scenario to understand this
concept better after reading the problem
statement click the solution button to
look at a possible answer
six sigma is a highly disciplined
process that focuses on developing and
delivering near perfect products and
services consistently if large volume of
data is plotted over a period of time
you would most probably have a
bell-shaped graph such graphs are also
called normal distribution graph
it's called as normal distribution
because any large volume of data is
plotted with the intent to track
variations would most probably be in a
bell-shaped curve the line corresponding
to the top of the bell curve is the
median of the data sample
standard deviation concept is used to
measure how far any data is from the
mean
standard deviation is also called sigma
one standard deviation from the mean
covers 68 of the data
six sigma means six standard deviations
from the mean
this would cover
99.99966 percent of the data
we will look at an example of six sigma
in the following screen
to understand six sigma let us look at
an example a tire manufacturing company
produces one hundred thousand tires a
day it is not possible to verify each
and every tire manually to ensure it is
defect-free instead random sample of
these manufactured tires are taken and
checked for defects assuming that the
thickness of the tires is a parameter to
measure defect any tire that has a
thickness more than or less than 10
millimeters is considered to be
defective
now if you measure the actual thickness
of all 100 000 tires manufactured daily
and plot them on a graph you get normal
distribution graph one standard
deviation from the mean covers sixty
eight percent of the data
meaning if the thickness of the one
hundred thousand tires are plotted sixty
eight thousand of them lie within one
standard deviation above or below the
mean
now if a company operates at six sigma
level
they would ensure that all tires that
are up to six standard deviations from
the mean are defect-free
therefore in such cases you can expect
only three defective tires out of a
million tires manufactured let us now
check your understanding of the topics
covered in this lesson
here is a quick recap of what was
covered in this lesson
a project is said to meet quality
expectations when all the project
requirements agreed in the beginning of
the project are met and the resulting
product is usable
quality management includes creating and
following policies and procedures that
meet the project's defined quality needs
quality planning defines the standards
templates policies and procedures
quality assurance determines if the
project is complying with the policies
and procedures quality control measures
specific project results against
standards
plan quality management perform quality
assurance and control quality are the
three project quality management
processes
seven basic quality tools are used to
plan and achieve the desired levels of
quality
at six sigma level there would be only
three defects out of a million units
manufactured
in this lesson we will focus on project
management framework let us begin with
the objectives of this lesson
after completing this lesson you will be
able to
define project project management
program management and portfolio
management
recognize the roles of project
management office
identify the project constraints and
their impact on the project
explain the role of a project manager in
stakeholder management describe
different organization structure
differentiate between a project life
cycle and a product life cycle
let's begin this lesson with
understanding what a project is in the
next screen
a project is a temporary endeavor
undertaken to create a unique product
service or result for example developing
a new product service or result
constructing a building industrial plant
or infrastructure and implementing
improving or enhancing existing business
processes and procedures
in the next screen we will focus on the
characteristics of a project
a project can be distinguished based on
its characteristics
the definition describes two
characteristics of a project
first it is temporary in nature
temporary here does not mean short in
duration a project can extend for long
duration based on the requirements for
example creating a new indigenous
missile defense system for a country
however there is always a definite
planned start and end date for a project
it cannot go on indefinitely
secondly the project is supposed to
produce a unique output
the output could be a product service or
result
there can be many common activities
between two projects but the outcome of
each project should be unique in some
way or the other
now let us look at what marks the end of
a project
a project ends when either the
objectives are met or the project is
terminated because the objectives will
not or cannot be met
the other reason to terminate the
project can be that the need for the
output of the project does not exist
anymore
usually the sponsor of the project takes
a call about the closure of the project
it is important to differentiate project
work from regular operational work
for example your office receptionist
does the same work every day of picking
any incoming call and directing the call
to the right person in the office
this is an ongoing repetitive work and
can be classified as operation
operations unlike projects are neither
temporary nor unique
creating a new software system to
effectively track your customer
complaint can be an example of a project
when the software is successfully
developed the project objective is met
which marks the end of the project
when you start using this software to
track customer complaints you are
entering into the operations phase
in the next screen let us now look into
project management
as defined in the pmbok guide project
management is the application of
knowledge skills and tools and
techniques applied to project activities
to meet the project requirements
project management is achieved by proper
application and integration of the 47
processes project application and
integration means these processes should
be executed in the right manner as well
as in the right order
in the next screen let us discuss how to
manage a project
program management is defined as the
application of knowledge skills tools
and techniques to a program to meet the
program requirements and to obtain
benefits and control not available by
managing projects individually as
defined in pmbok guide a program is a
group of related projects which when
managed as a group in a coordinated
fashion provides benefits and control
that are not available while managing
them individually these benefits could
be from decreased risk economies of
scale improved management of
dependencies delivery of additional
capabilities
optimal utilization of shared resources
and so on
let us now learn the various features of
program management
random projects cannot be grouped
together as a program
the projects in a program should be
related in some way or the other and
there should be some value added in
managing them together
a project may not be a part of any
program but a program will always have
projects a project can also be executed
as a standalone project
a program is designed to deliver some
strategic benefits value to the
organization
these benefits can be tangible or
intangible
examples of tangible benefit could be
increased profit margins or operational
cost savings
examples of intangible benefits could be
improved team morale or building up
certain competencies
while a project manager focuses
relentlessly on the fulfillment of the
project's requirements that is scope
cost time quality a program manager
needs to focus on ensuring that the
organizational benefits are realized
in the next screen let us understand
what a portfolio is
portfolio is yet another term used along
with project and program
a portfolio may have multiple projects
and programs that are managed as a group
to achieve strategic objectives
note that all projects and programs in a
portfolio may not be necessarily
interdependent or directly related
a portfolio can be created based on the
business objectives
for example an i t service company can
have a portfolio named japanese projects
which is formed with an aim to take over
the japanese market by giving more
attention to these projects
within this portfolio similar projects
can be managed as a program
and all banking projects from japan can
be managed as a banking program
in the next screen let us discuss
portfolio management
portfolio management is the centralized
management of one or more portfolios
this includes identifying prioritizing
authorizing managing and controlling
projects programs and other related work
to achieve strategic business objectives
therefore whether the company should
have japanese projects as portfolio or
not is decided by portfolio management
in the next screen let us understand the
relationship between portfolios programs
and projects
the image on the screen will help you to
understand the terms portfolios programs
and projects a portfolio is part of an
organization's overall strategy
it represents a conscious decision by an
organization to invest in the portfolio
the overall objectives of a portfolio
are then cascaded down to the lower
level components
the components could be sub-portfolios
programs or projects
these components can further be broken
down into smaller components for ease of
management
although a project may not contain
operations a program or a portfolio it
can include other work
this other work may comprise training
and development customer support and
services etcetera
if the other work has synergy with the
overall objectives and adds to the
capability to deliver the higher level
benefits
then it can be included in the program
or portfolio as well
in the next screen we will discuss
project management office
project management office or pmo is a
specific type of body or department
within an organization
pmo performs several roles in the
organization and these can broadly be
classified as primary roles and other
roles
typically the pmo may take up any one or
a combination of the three primary roles
it provides the policies methodologies
and tools and templates for managing
projects within the organization
it provides support and training in
organization on how to manage projects
and finally it provides project managers
for different ongoing projects in the
organization
pmo may also help in managing
interdependencies between the projects
selecting managing and deploying shared
or dedicated project resources if need
be terminating a project and organizing
lessons learnt sessions and maintaining
the project management knowledge base
for an organization in the next screen
we will discuss how to manage the triple
constraints
any project can be done successfully if
there is no constraint on time or there
is unlimited budget available
unfortunately that is not true in real
life
a project is performed within some
constraint and these constraints are
usually competing
therefore if you change one it would
affect the other for example if the
project duration increases it would lead
to increase in the project cost as well
triple constraint is a term that
originally referred to the three
competing project constraints within
which the projects are performed
these constraints are cost time and
scope
quality is a primary concern for a
project manager
therefore the project manager has to
make trade-offs to keep the scope cost
time quality plane in balance
to achieve the balance the project
manager also needs to manage other
aspects of the project for instance the
people stakeholders risks communication
and procurements
the project manager plays the essential
role of integrating all these different
aspects of project management
in the pmp examination you can expect
business scenario based questions
focusing on the triple constraints
in the next screen
let us understand who a stakeholder is
a stakeholder can be defined as the one
whose interests may positively or
negatively be affected or perceived to
be affected by the decision activity or
outcome of the project
as per the definition the project team
project manager project sponsor pmo
office customer etcetera are the
stakeholders of the project
a project sponsor is the one who gives a
go ahead for a project and provides the
necessary resources to execute the
project
therefore the head of projects in the
organization who provides a green signal
to start a project and allocates
required resources to the project is the
project sponsor a project sponsor is
usually somebody placed high up in the
organizational hierarchy of the
performing organization that is the
organization in which the work of the
project is being carried out
in the next screen let us look at
stakeholder management
one of the key responsibilities of a
project manager is to manage
stakeholders a project manager has to
involve the stakeholders from the
beginning of the project until the end
so they are aware of every step
a project manager has to take up
specific activities for stakeholder
management
identifying both internal and external
stakeholders
missing out any stakeholder can be
disastrous for a project
a stakeholder who has identified towards
the end of the project may come up with
his own requirement at that stage and
incorporating them can be risky
determining stakeholder requirements
after identifying all the stakeholders
the project manager also needs to ensure
that their requirements are clearly
identified
sometimes stakeholders might themselves
not know of their requirement and it is
the job of the project manager to get
them right by doing a proper stakeholder
requirement analysis
determining stakeholder expectations
stakeholders might also have some
unstated expectations
which need to be clarified to see if it
can become a project requirement
it is again the role of the project
manager to determine the stakeholders
expectation
communicating with stakeholders
once all the stated and unstated
stakeholder requirements are known the
project manager as part of stakeholder
analysis should focus on communicating
them regularly to keep stakeholders
involved in the project once you
understand the practices of stakeholder
management it will be easier for you to
answer scenario based questions in the
examination
in the next screen let us look at the
various organization structure
projects are performed in an
organization and the functioning of the
organization might affect the project
the different organization structure
types explained here are based on the
level of authority that a project
manager gets into in those organizations
in a functional type of organization the
organization is grouped by the area of
specialization within different
functional areas
for instance marketing accounting
engineering etc are departments within
the organization
each employee typically reports to a
functional manager
in such types of organization
normally projects are undertaken within
the department itself
if a project requires any assistance
from another department the request
moves from the head of the requesting
department to the head of the concerned
department the team members do their
normal departmental work in addition to
the project work
the next type of organization is
projectized organization in such
organizations there are no departments
the organization's resources mostly work
on projects team members report to a
project manager
the project manager has complete control
over the resources when the project is
completed either they move on to another
project or they look for some job
outside the company
they do not have a department for
themselves
the third type of organization is a
matrix organization
which is a blend of functional and
projectized organizational structure
a team member belongs to a department as
well as they are part of a project team
in such organization team members have
two bosses one their department head and
the second their project manager
since there are two bosses here this
type of organization is further
classified into three different types
they are weak strong and balanced matrix
organization
so out of the two bosses that team
members have in matrix organization if
the project manager has more authority
over the team member such organizations
are called strong matrix
where the functional manager has more
authority it's a weak matrix
organization
if they both share equal authority then
it is a balanced organization
there is another term that you might
find in the exam called tight matrix
this generally refers to a co-located
team that is a team that has been placed
in the same location to enhance their
performance
in the pmp exam if there is no mention
of the organization type you can assume
it to be a matrix organization
let us look at each of these
organization structures in detail in the
next screen let us look at functional
organization
in a functional organization the
resources of the organization are
grouped by functions sometimes called
departments
examples of functions could be sales
finance administration manufacturing etc
each function plays a definite role in
the organization and is headed by a
functional head or supervisor
all the resources in such an
organization report directly into their
functions
therefore a salesperson would report
into the sales organizational hierarchy
a purchase executive would report into
procurement and so on
you would notice that in a functional
organization
the project manager's role is not
explicitly called out
when a functional organization embarks
on a project each of the functions that
are involved may volunteer some
resources to work on the project
one of these resources may end up
playing the project manager's role
the resource assignments may not even be
full time and sometimes even the project
manager is part-time
since the project manager has no
authority over any of the resources they
are dependent on the functional heads
this makes it more challenging for the
project manager to coordinate in the
team
however functional organizations provide
an opportunity for specialization
for example if a purchase executive was
reporting into the purchase department
that executive would have exposure to
all the purchasing that happens within
the organization and has a well-defined
career path
in functional organizations project
management happens at the functional
head level
next let us look at the projectized
organization in the next
screen the projectized organization has
all the resources aligned around
projects
the project managers have complete
control over the resources working on
their projects
the biggest advantage of the projectized
organization is that the resources have
loyalty to their projects and project
execution becomes easier
this kind of structure is suitable for
organizations whose work is in the
nature of projects
there are few disadvantages in this
structure as well
firstly the role of the resource is over
once the project is completed secondly
highly specialized roles within a
project may not be fully occupied all
the time for example a purchase
executive may have worked for selected
periods on a project while purchase
activities are going on
however for the rest of the period their
capability may not be optimally utilized
there is less scope for functional
specialization as the project boundaries
limit the kind of work for the resources
each project manager is in charge of a
project and its resources
next let us look at the matrix
organization
in a matrix organization the resources
report to the functional managers and
are managed by the project managers as
well
there might even be a function that
represents all the project managers in
the organization which provides project
management expertise
the matrix structure has three variants
commonly referred to as weak balanced
and strong
in a weak matrix the authority of the
project manager is the weakest and
strongest in a strong matrix structure
the titles given to project managers and
functional or weak matrix organizations
are project expediter or project
coordinator
they would be called project managers in
a balanced or strong matrix structure
and have slightly more authority over
the time of the team members
the advantage of the matrix structure is
that resources can be optimally utilized
while preserving the capacity of the
project managers to get projects
executed efficiently
resources can specialize in their
functions and have stability in their
careers also contribute to the projects
at the same time potentially
the disadvantage of matrix organization
is that the communication overhead
increases significantly
this is because every resource in the
organization belongs into a project and
into a function
leading to a dual reporting structure
in a matrix organization project
management happens at project resource
level
in the next screen let us summarize the
advantages and disadvantages of
different organizational structures
each organization structure has its own
set of advantages and disadvantages
the advantage of functional
organizations is that resources may find
clearly defined career paths and achieve
specialization and skill development in
their respective fields
it will be a flexible workforce since
only one manager will be responsible
avoiding confusion the disadvantage of
such organization type is that project
work is hampered department work is
always given higher priority than the
project work
in addition there is no career path in
project management which leads to lower
interest in projects
in the case of the projectized
organization
one of the clear advantages is better
communication within the projects since
project work is the only work team
members are doing it also leads to
loyalty towards the project goals
the disadvantage of such organization
type is the inefficient use of resources
because every project team has their own
support function
therefore this might lead to the
duplication of effort
it also leads to the resources being
left with no work since their roles are
over once the project is completed
it also hampers skill development
because the project requirements dictate
what kind of work team members perform
at different stages on a project
now let us look at the matrix
organization
it also has the advantage of better
coordination and maximum utilization of
resources
however the disadvantage is the higher
potential for conflict among the
managers which might lead to
communication complexity and overhead
management
in the next screen let us focus on the
comparison on project lifecycle and
product lifecycle
project lifecycle spans the initiation
of a project until the closure of the
project the product life cycle on the
other hand also encompasses the
operational and maintenance phases
a typical product life cycle starts with
conception of the product and goes until
its withdrawal from the market
the withdrawal might be because it
becomes obsolete or there is no further
need for the product in the market
a product has a long life cycle
a product can require or spawn many
projects over its life
for example a project in product
conception phase could be to determine
customer needs whereas a project during
product maturity phase could be used to
perform competitive analysis
typically a product life cycle is longer
than the project life cycle
a project also has its own life cycle
and this life cycle depends upon the
industry and the organization within
which the project is being executed
sometimes different organizations within
the same industry use different life
cycles
there can be questions in the exam based
on the comparison of project life cycle
and product life cycle so understanding
the differences will be useful in
answering such questions
in the next screen let us discuss more
on project life cycle
a life cycle is composed of phases each
phase represents a discrete unit of work
required to be done on the project
there are different ways of classifying
project life cycles
let us first discuss the sequential
versus overlapping life cycle
in sequential phases the subsequent
phase starts only after the previous
phase has been completed whereas in
overlapping phases two or more phases
may run in parallel for some time
this could help fast tracking and
compressing the amount of time required
the other way of classifying life cycles
is how they go about the process of
planning
in predictive life cycles there is a
large upfront planning phase where all
the details of scope cost time are
planned before beginning the subsequent
phases
these phases then are executed in either
sequential or overlapping modes
they are suitable for large projects
where all the requirements are likely to
be known in advance and where upfront
planning effort is required to get the
necessary approvals
another feature of predictive life
cycles is that each phase may
potentially be different in the nature
of activities and may require people
with different skill sets for example
traditional software development life
cycle has phases like requirements
feasibility planning design construction
testing and transition
we will continue project life cycles in
the next screen
incremental and iterative life cycles
have a short upfront high level
definition and planning phase
the product is then developed through a
series of iterations
where iteration increments or adds to
the functionality by a little
all the activities are intentionally
repeated in iterations
adaptive or agile life cycles are
variants of incremental and iterative
life cycles where iteration is very
short typically two to four weeks
agile methodologies are becoming very
popular in the software development
industry and in other industries where
the requirements are highly changeable
and frequent feedback is beneficial
let us now check your understanding of
the topics covered in this lesson
here is a quick recap of what was
covered in this lesson project
management is the application of
knowledge skills and tools and
techniques applied to project activities
to meet the project requirements
pmo provides the policies methodologies
and tools and templates for managing
projects within the organization
project manager has to integrate various
project aspects like the people
stakeholders risks communication and
procurements with the project
constraints time scope cost and quality
identifying internal and external
stakeholders determining their
requirements and communicating with them
regularly is an important role of a
project manager
functional projectized and matrix are
the three types of organization
structures based on the level of
authority given to the project manager
project lifecycle spans the initiation
of a project until the closure while
product life cycle also encompasses the
operational and maintenance phases
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
in this lesson we will focus on project
communications management let us begin
with the objectives of this lesson
after completing this lesson you will be
able to define communication and project
communications management identify the
different communication methods
technology and channels explain the
elements of a basic communication model
describe the project communications
management processes in the next screen
let us take a quick look at the project
management process map
there are 47 processes and project
management grouped into 10 knowledge
areas and mapped into five process
groups in this lesson we will look at
the seventh knowledge area that is
project communications management and
its processes in the next screen let us
understand
communication
communication can be best defined as a
two-way process of exchanging
information between two entities as you
can see on the screen if project is an
entity the project needs to communicate
with other entities in the organization
like project managers senior management
of the organization and any other
stakeholder of the project similarly
these entities may also have to
communicate with the projects the
communication between project and the
stakeholders is always two-sided project
manager is responsible for ensuring
proper communication to and from the
project in fact a project manager spends
almost 90 percent of his or her time on
communication you can now understand how
important it is for a project manager to
plan this activity well in the next
screen let us discuss communication
methods
communication can be done in two ways it
can be done written or verbal both
written as well as verbal communication
can either be formal or informal formal
means communicating by following some
basic rules whereas informal means
taking a casual approach
these two combinations result in four
different communication methods they are
formal written formal verbal informal
written and informal verbal formal
written method is used for project
management plans project charter and
over long distance communication formal
verbal method is used during
presentations whereas informal written
method is applicable while writing notes
or emails informal verbal on the other
hand is applied during conversations
you can expect questions in the pmp exam
which require choosing a communication
method for a given situation so a fair
understanding of the communication
methods can help you score higher in the
next screen let us look at the various
communication technologies
communication technology refers to the
different media used for communicating a
few such technologies are listed on
screen
among which email fax and telephone are
a few popular communication technologies
in the next screen
let us understand the communication
channel with the help of an example
communication takes place between four
people in a team
the lines across the members represent
there can be six unique channels of
communication existing within the team
now if the team comprises ten members
how many unique channels of
communication will be calculated you can
use the formula
n multiplied with n minus one and the
resulting sum divided by two n is the
total number of people involved in
communication in this case n equals to
10. if this is put into the formula you
will get 45 as the result
therefore 45 unique communication
channels exist in a team of ten people
it is difficult to manage such a large
number of communication channels
therefore it is important to structure
communication otherwise everyone starts
communicating everything to everyone
and it can become a real chaos in the
project in the pmp exam you may be asked
to calculate the number of communication
channels in a scenario based question so
please make a note of the formula to
answer the question correctly
in the next screen let us discuss the
basic communication model
project communications management
includes the processes required to
ensure that information about timely and
appropriate generation collection
distribution storage and ultimate
disposition of project is prepared and
circulated to all project stakeholders
it is the responsibility of a project
manager to ensure that the information
requested by the stakeholder is
communicated to them
the frequency at which the information
needs to be shared may also vary from
stakeholder to stakeholder for example
think about a simple process of sharing
a project status report with the
customer and senior management this
knowledge area explains how it should be
done as per pmi
in the next screen let us discuss the
project communications management
processes
there are three project communications
management processes
process is carried during different
process groups plan communication
management is done during planning
process group
managed communications is done during
executing process group and control
communications is done during monitoring
and controlling process group
in the next few screens we will cover
each of these processes in detail
plan communications management is the
process of developing an appropriate
approach and plan for project
communications based on stakeholders
information needs and requirements
and available organizational assets
this belongs to the planning process
group
stakeholder register is an important
input to this process
it is a list of all the stakeholders the
project management plan has information
about a large number of the project's
requirements and the stakeholders who
need to receive communication of various
kinds
are therefore a critical input to this
process in addition to these two
organization process assets and
enterprise environmental factors are
also inputs to this process
many organizations have standard
templates to prepare communication
management plan which are part of the
organizational process assets and
enterprise environmental factors the
first technique used in this process is
the communication requirements analysis
where the communication requirements of
each of the stakeholders are analyzed
and categorized in this you try to find
how many of the stakeholders need
similar kind of information which can be
grouped together if you send information
through an email system all those
stakeholders who need similar
information can be marked in cc in the
email next you can decide on the
communication technology these days
email is the most widely used technology
but in few cases you might have to send
information using some other technology
like fax or registered post for example
all government communications are done
using registered post to keep a written
record
finally you need to understand how
communication really happens
that is the communication models and the
various communication methods used you
may need to conduct meetings before
agreeing on and finalizing the
communications management plan the
communications management plan is the
primary output of this process which
lays down the procedures around
communications in the organization
communication management plan has
information like which stakeholder needs
what kind of information at what
frequency and how as a result of this
process
some other project documents may also
get updated
there may be questions in the pmp exam
based on the planned communications
management process so a fair
understanding of the process will help
you answer such questions correctly in
the next screen let us look into a
business scenario to understand this
concept better after reading the problem
statement click the solution button to
look at a possible answer
manage communications is the process of
creating collecting distributing storing
retrieving and the ultimate disposition
of project information in accordance to
the communications management plan
it belongs to the executing process
group managed communications is done
throughout the project life cycle
everything cannot be planned during
communication planning so manage
communications takes care of responding
to unexpected requests for information
as well communications management plan
is an important input work performance
reports have information regarding
project performance and status
information organizational process
assets are the standard templates
created for the status report by
organizations in some organizations
there are guidelines for communication
distribution enterprise environmental
factors are the other inputs to this
process various tools and techniques are
used in this process communications
technology represents the means of
technology that is email instant
messaging telephone conferencing
etcetera that are used to exchange
information the use of communication
models helps you determine the technique
that is best suited for a particular
situation
communication methods are the various
methods used to communicate for example
whether it is interactive or offline
whether information is being pushed by
the provider or pulled by the recipient
etc information management systems help
design a framework for managing the
information within a project
that is how it is acquired where it is
stored and how it is distributed and
destroyed in performance reporting all
the information is synthesized in the
form of performance reports that are
later distributed to the appropriate
stakeholders and forms an important part
of the communications strategy on a
project the first and primary output of
this process is the communications
messages that are generated during the
project the other outputs include
project management plan updates project
document updates and organizational
process assets updates in the next
screen let us discuss control
communications process
control communications is the process of
monitoring and controlling
communications throughout the entire
project life cycle to ensure the
information needs of the project
stakeholders are met
it is part of the monitoring and
controlling process group the inputs to
this process are the project
communications project management plan
and issue log which has a list of issues
that are raised by different project
stakeholders data related to the work
being performed on the project and
various other project documents which
may have to be communicated other inputs
include work performance data and
organizational process assets let us
look at the tools and techniques in
detail the information management
systems provide tools to collect
consolidate and present the information
in the form of cogent concise
communications expertise must be sought
from different stakeholders on how you
should go about this process
several meetings may be needed to ensure
the efficiency and efficacy of the
communications the major outputs of this
process is the work performance
information which indicates that the
work performance data has been analyzed
interpreted and presented in an easily
comprehensible form this process may
also give rise to change requests
updates to the project management plan
project documents and organizational
process assets in the next screen let us
look into a business scenario to
understand this concept better after
reading the problem statement click the
solution button to look at a possible
answer
here is a quick recap of what was
covered in this lesson
communication is a two-way process of
transferring information from one entity
to another the four commonly used
communication methods are formal written
formal verbal informal written and
informal verbal the total number of
unique channel of communication can be
calculated using the formula n
multiplied with n minus 1 and the
resulting sum divided by two
by analyzing the communication model
problems in project communication can be
identified
project manager is responsible for
timely availability of information to
all stakeholders
the three project communications
management processes are
plan communication management management
communications and control
communications
in this lesson we will focus on project
human resource management
there are 47 processes in project
management grouped into 10 knowledge
areas and mapped to five process groups
in this lesson we will look at the sixth
knowledge area that is project human
resource management and its processes
in the next screen let us understand
project human resource management
project human resource management
includes the processes that organize
manage and lead the project team
one of the key elements of human
resource management is that each of the
project team members should have clear
assignment of their roles and
responsibilities
in addition even the team working on
project management tasks should be a
part of the project team and they are
responsible for project management
functions like initiating planning
executing monitoring and controlling and
closing along with other leadership
activities in the next screen let us
understand the difference between
functional and project manager
an organization may have both functional
managers and project managers the
difference
functional manager is the one who
handles a business function or
department for instance the hr manager
is responsible for the hr department in
an organization
therefore an hr manager will be a
functional manager
generally a functional manager is also a
subject matter expert
the roles and responsibilities of the
functional manager depend upon the core
business of the organization and overall
organization structure functional
managers normally own the resources and
provide the projects with necessary
resources they also negotiate with the
project manager regarding resources the
project manager on the other hand is
responsible and accountable for the
success or failure of a project and the
quality of the project
they are not technical experts the
project manager may not have authority
over the resources depending upon the
organizational structure
they often have to negotiate with the
functional manager for the resources and
are responsible for the product quality
a project manager will credit the team
with the success of the project and
accept the blame for the failure
now let us look at an example to
understand the roles played by
functional and project managers
the ceo of an organization initiates a
new project to secure an iso
9001 2008 certification for the company
now this project would require team
members from each of the company
departments
and whoever is the project manager of
this project will have to request the
functional manager to assign one of
their team members to the project
resources assigned to the project go
back to their respective departments
once the project is completed
let us now discuss the project human
resource management processes in the
next screen
there are four project human resource
management processes
the first process plan human resource
management is done as part of the
planning process group
the next three processes are part of the
executing process group these processes
are acquire project team develop project
team and manage project team let us now
look into each of these processes in
detail in the next screen let us begin
with plan human resource management
plan human resource management is the
process of identifying and documenting
project roles
responsibilities
required skills
reporting relationships and creating a
staffing management plan this process is
part of the planning process group in
addition to that finalizing the project
hierarchy of who reports to whom
and designing the staffing management
plan is also part of this process
the first input to this process is the
project management plan there could be a
lot of information in the project
management plan and subsidiary plans
that may be relevant to the creation of
the human resource management plan for
example the project life cycle processes
the timelines how the work will be
accomplished etc the other key input for
this process is the activity resource
requirement team members can be
identified based on these requirements
in addition to this enterprise
environmental factors like current
employment outlook etc are also
important for example if the economy is
booming and there are ample job
opportunities for the team members the
reward and recognition system can keep
the project team interested in the
project
organizational process asset
is also an input to this process
an example of the organization process
assets can be template or a form to
request for a new resource
let us now look at the tools and
techniques used to develop human
resource plan
the roles and responsibilities are
captured in the form of organization
charts and position descriptions
there are various ways to draw this
chart it can be either hierarchical
chart which shows the reporting function
or it can be text based
the other technique used for developing
the human resource plan is networking
this involves formal or informal
interactions within the organization and
outside by the project manager to
identify the best team for the project
depending upon various interpersonal
factors
organizational theory helps to
understand how individuals come together
and function as an organization
expert judgment and meetings are
required to put the human resource plan
together
the output of this process is human
resource management plan this plan
contains documents like staffing
management plan
project organization chart and roles and
responsibilities matrix
the staffing management plan is a
comprehensive document that describes
when and how team members would be added
to and released from the project
another component of the staffing
management plan is the recognition and
reward system
recognition and reward system helps
project managers motivate their team
the staffing management plan is relevant
to the projects of a functional or
matrix organization where project team
members are always caught in a dilemma
about prioritizing project work against
regular departmental work
in the next screen let us discuss
organization charts and role
descriptions
a project manager needs to make sure
that there is an organization chart
prepared specifically for the project it
should clearly identify the roles and
the reporting relationships between them
a sample organization chart is shown on
the slide
another way of clearly delineating
responsibilities among team members is
by using a responsibility assignment
matrix one form of responsibility
assignment matrix is the raci chart in
the raci chart r stands for responsible
a for accountable c for concerned or
consulted and i for informed for each
important activity or deliverable on the
project it needs to be clearly
identified who is responsible or
contributes to it who is ultimately
accountable who is merely concerned
about the success and who needs to be
informed or kept in the loop an example
of the raci chart is shown on the screen
in this case project manager john is
accountable for the project plan and the
other team members chris sally and ting
are responsible for completing the plan
similarly you can note the roles of each
resource in the other activities
in the next screen let us understand
resource histogram
resource histogram is a method of
depicting how many resources are
required for the life of a project if
you observe the chart shown on the
screen it indicates that the number of
staff hours required on the project
increases to a peak in 2014 and then
slowly tapers off especially for long
running projects the level of staffing
needed may vary considerably over a
period this has implications for other
parts of the plan as well for example
the cost will vary as the number of
resources change
this piece of information helps a
project manager to understand at what
time they need to onboard and off board
resources on a project in the next
screen let us look into the second human
resource management process that is
acquire project team
acquire project team is the process of
confirming human resource availability
and obtaining the team necessary to
complete project activities
this process belongs to the executing
process group
acquiring resources may not be required
in the planning phase therefore it is
done in execution phase though you may
plan to acquire few in the planning
phase major acquisition is done in
execution phase
this may be true where large projects
are run spanning over many years with
several detailed activities
the key input is the human resource
management plan
enterprise environmental factors help
understand which team members will be
available to work on the project
how much they will cost etc
organizational process assets will help
understand the hiring procedure of the
company the policies that govern the use
of team members on the project etc the
key technique for acquiring the project
team is negotiation as a project manager
you have to negotiate with the company's
senior management resource manager or
with prospective candidates to secure
the most suitable resources on the
project sometimes the resources may be
pre-assigned to a project
this typically happens when they are the
key resources without which the project
cannot take off sometimes the project
team is acquired by getting required
resources through external vendors most
of the bigger organizations have
approved a list of vendors who provide
resources on a contractual basis
nowadays the concept of virtual team is
also quite popular to get a project team
so even though the project is being
conceived in one country a big part of
the team can be in another country for
example if the project is conceived in
the usa
majority of the team can be in germany
and both the teams can coordinate over
the phone email chat etc
multi-criteria decision analysis is also
an important tool to achieve the
objectives while acquiring the human
resources for the project it is
important to consider a number of
factors such as availability cost skill
set experience attitude relocation needs
etc these criteria have to be considered
in totality and balanced out against the
project's requirements the output of
this process is project staff
assignments resource calendars and
updates on project management plan let
us now discuss the next process develop
project team
once the project team is acquired the
next step is developing the project team
develop project team is the process of
improving competencies
team member interaction and overall team
environment to enhance project
performance
this process belongs to the executing
process group
the inputs to this process include
project staff assignments resource
calendars and human resource management
plan
one of the techniques used in developing
project team is interpersonal skills
it is more of an art than a science and
this is where individual characteristics
of project managers matter a lot if the
project manager genuinely commands trust
and respects the team members developing
the team becomes easy team members look
up to the project manager not only for
getting project specific instructions
but also for their career advancement as
well social activities like celebrating
a team member's birthday going for
parties outside the office etc helps in
team building training is also an
important tool for developing the
project team as it helps in increasing
the knowledge of competencies of the
team members sometimes co-locating the
team members at a single place also
helps in developing team bonding this is
especially important if team members
work from different geographical
locations
knowing a person face to face does help
in reducing conflict project managers
can also encourage the team members by
providing recognition and rewards
personnel assessment tools give the
project manager insights into the
strengths and opportunities for
improvement in the team members these
tools also help in understanding members
aspirations so that the project manager
can better align the project goals with
the individual aspirations finally the
project manager should also set some
ground rules in the project to ensure
that team performs their work without
any problems some such rules can be
everyone should reach office for daily
meeting by 9 30 a.m sharp if there is
more than a 10 percent delay in
completing any activity assigned it
should immediately be escalated to
project manager if there are any
unforeseen circumstances it should be
immediately brought to the notice of the
project manager etc the output of this
process is team performance assessments
this is done by the project manager to
evaluate and enhance the effectiveness
of the team as a whole this is a
document which explains team
effectiveness
as information about the team evolves
the enterprise environmental factors may
also be updated questions that test a
project manager's role in developing a
project team can be expected in the pmp
exam so ensure that you have a fair
understanding of the role before you
take the exam in the next screen let us
discuss the manage project team process
managing the project team is different
from developing the project team though
it is also done during the execution
process group it relates to measuring
team members performance providing
feedback resolving issues and managing
changes to optimize project performance
to measure team members performance the
manager should know the work assigned to
them as well as their performance on the
assigned work hence project staff
assignments and team performance
assessments are listed as input to this
process the human resource management
plan serves as a guideline for managing
project teams some organizations have
templates and procedures to do such
assessment and that being the reason why
organization process asset is also one
of the inputs to this process the work
performance reports as well as issue
logs will be inputs because the team
management activities have to be
performed in this context
observation and conversation is a
technique where the project manager
monitors and discusses the tasks done by
the team this does not imply formal
project status reports but having an
informal interaction with the team
before documenting the project status
report knowing about the issue early
helps in resolving them early formal
performance appraisals are helpful in
evaluating the team members performance
on the project the project manager
creates these with the help of the team
supervisors it is an established
practice in most organizations to
evaluate team members for their work
this may have a bearing on their future
assignments salary promotions etc since
the power of appraising lies within the
project manager the project manager can
use this as an effective tool for
managing the team
since multiple resources work on a
single project it is quite natural to
expect conflicts
it is the responsibility of project
manager to resolve conflicts
conflict management has been discussed
in detail later in the lesson you can
expect questions on conflict management
in the exam
the other tool is interpersonal skills
the output of managing a project team
includes corrective action
recommendations like which team members
to be changed implementing some reward
system to motivate the team etc updating
the project management plans documents
organization process asset and
enterprise environmental factors are the
other outputs of this process there can
be questions in the pmp exam that test a
project manager's skill in managing a
project team
so ensure that you are aware of the
inputs tools and techniques and outputs
of managing a project team
let us discuss team dynamics in the next
screen any team naturally goes through
several stages as it gets together these
stages are forming storming norming
performing and adjourning in forming
stage a team formally comes together for
the first time in storming stage
disagreements start to surface this is
followed by norming when the teams start
working together and trusting each other
in performing stage they are able to
deliver results as a team finally the
team is adjourned when the work of the
project is completed or the project is
terminated
in the next screen let us discuss
conflict management
many organizations look for people with
diverse background to get different
perspectives about work
if people with diverse backgrounds and
culture work on a project it is quite
natural to expect conflict conflict
often results in opportunities for
improvement the root causes of conflict
can be scarce resources scheduling
priorities and personal work styles
while the popular belief is that
personality or ego can be the key reason
for conflict it is the least possible
reason for conflict
as a project manager if you find
yourself in between a conflict with a
team member sit across the table and
resolve it if not they should get their
immediate managers involved and try to
resolve it to avoid conflicts a project
manager should let everyone involved
have complete clarity about the project
assign the roles and responsibilities to
each of the team members clearly ensure
that there are no overlapping
responsibilities which could be a
possible cause for conflict sometimes
boredom at work can also lead to
conflict so one of the responsibilities
of project manager is to keep motivating
the team members and let them work on
interesting and challenging assignments
business scenarios based questions on
conflict management can be expected in
the pmp exam so it is essential to have
a fair understanding of the topic
in the next screen let us look at
conflict resolution techniques
there are five techniques of resolving
conflict they are withdraw or avoid
smooth or accommodate compromise or
reconcile force or direct collaborate or
problem solve in withdrawal or avoid one
retreats from a potential conflict
situation or defers the resolution to a
later date this does not resolve the
conflict but allows for more time in
smooth or accommodate areas of agreement
are emphasized to reduce the intensity
of the conflict again this does not on
its own result in a resolution but it
may succeed in changing the perceptions
about the situation in compromise or
reconcile there is some give and take in
order to bring some satisfaction to all
parties depending on how the process
went this may be perceived as a win-win
or a lose-lose situation because none of
the parties really get what they want in
force or direct a person in a position
of authority directs how the matter
should be resolved it may be necessary
to do this when the matter has to be
resolved immediately however this may
result in upsetting one or more of the
conflicting parties
in collaborate or problem solving the
parties in the conflict are asked to
come together to collaborate and look
for a resolution to the problem
this offers the greatest likelihood of a
satisfactory and permanent resolution
and should be resorted to whenever
possible
business scenario based problems where a
resolution technique has to be selected
can be expected in the pmp exam
so understanding the conflict resolution
techniques is essential
in the next screen let us look into a
business scenario to understand this
concept better after reading the problem
statement click the solution button to
look at a possible answer
one of the key responsibilities of a
project manager is to get work done by
the team there are certain powers that a
project manager can use to get the work
done
a project manager has to use a
combination of techniques to get this
accomplished various powers of a project
manager are legitimate or formal reward
penalty expert and referent in
legitimate or formal project manager can
formally assign a work to a team member
that he or she has to do project manager
can reward and recognize the team
members the reward could be as simple as
assigning challenging or sought after
work to a team member this can motivate
good performers on the project sometimes
project manager can penalize the team
members for poor performance some
project managers are able to command
authority because of their expertise in
a certain field project manager can be
considered as a reference of higher
authority to get the work done
sometimes referent authority also arises
from the personal charm or charisma of
the project manager legitimate reward
and penalty are the powers derived from
the project manager's position in the
company expert power exists when the
project manager is an expert on the
subject matter reward and expert are
usually the best forms of authority to
use penalty is the worst way of
influencing and managing the team a
project manager should resort to this
only as a last option regardless of the
project manager having formal reporting
authority over the team they are
naturally looked upon as the leaders for
their projects project managers need to
be familiar with the leadership styles
and be able to tailor their style
according to the needs of the project
and that of the team there are three
leadership styles the first one is
authoritarian or autocratic in this
style the leader sets clear expectations
of the team and expects complete
compliance in a participative or
democratic style the leader offers
guidance but also involves the team in
decision making
in a delegative or laissez-faire style
the leader leaves the work to the team
without offering much guidance in most
circumstances you would want your leader
to employ a participative style but
there may be occasions when other styles
might be appropriate in the next screen
let us discuss mckenzie's 7s framework
a popular framework in management
science is the mackenzie's 7s framework
there are seven elements that are
divided into two categories
an organization working on a project
will have these elements already in
place and hence these become the hard
elements the first three elements of the
7s framework are the strategy structure
and systems the leader or project
manager is expected to step in and
exhibit soft elements to earn the mantle
of leadership
the next four elements are shared values
skills style and staff
there are 47 processes in project
management grouped into 10 knowledge
areas and mapped to five process groups
in this lesson we will look at the
eighth knowledge area that is project
risk management and its processes risk
is an uncertain event or condition that
can affect a project positively or
negatively although most of the time you
view this uncertainty as bad sometimes
it also has a likely positive outcome
let us look at an example of risk having
a positive outcome you are using a
software for managing timesheet of your
team members due to budget constraints
you are forced to use a new software
though you were initially reluctant to
use it you found the new software to do
better than the current one it is more
efficient and has better reporting
facility an example of bad uncertainty
can be swine flu government declares
mandatory holiday to check flu spread
which may affect your project work
risks can be managed only if they are
measured quantitatively suppose there
are many risks identified in a project
and you have limited resources to manage
them you should know which risk is most
important that has to be managed first
therefore measuring risk becomes very
critical risk is measured by assigning a
monetary value to it and that value is
arrived at by multiplying the
probability and impact of the risk
can be categorized in various ways one
such categorization is external internal
technical or project management related
risk
external risk arises out of external
policies or regulations for example
government policy that the river water
can be used for drinking purposes may
hinder your production which is
dependent on the river water
internal risk arises from within the
project for example the complexity of
the work may result in time and cost
escalation
technical risks arise from the
technology being used projects in space
exploration have a lot of technical
complexity risks could be related to
project management for example if there
are many interdependencies between the
sub projects it is a risk from the
project management standpoint
the categorization of risk can be based
on the origin
risks can be classified as scope risk
resource risk
schedule risk
cost risk
and quality risk
scope risk can include redoing the same
task if the scope is not well understood
when the only resource is assigned to
some other project it is called resource
risk
a decision tree helps in analyzing risk
and its impact on making decisions in a
scenario where there is uncertainty on
the outcome suppose you want to buy a
car you can buy either a new car or an
old car
which one should you buy
which has more risk over a period of
five years
consider the concept of decision tree to
solve this problem the initial cost of
buying a new car is twenty thousand
dollars and the cost of buying an old
car is fifteen thousand dollars for a
new car the probability of it having any
problem fail scenario is only ten
percent that is there is a ninety
percent likelihood that it will just
work without any problems past scenario
and if it does have any at all the
impact of the problem is fifteen
thousand dollars the reason is that it
was bought at a higher cost
an old car has seventy percent
probability of having a problem the
reason being the probability is high
because the car was already used by
someone else in the past
however the impact here is low say ten
thousand dollars
if you add probability multiplied by
impact of both the options at the
decision nodes you will find buying an
old car over a period more risky than
buying a new car
the project cost will be arrived at
after considering the risk reserves of
both the known risks and unknown risks
there is a specific order in which these
reserves are calculated in the project
cost
first the cost of all activities is
identified
activities are the smallest unique
project tasks all the activity costs add
up to the cost of the work packages work
packages are the last level of
classification in a work breakdown
structure work packages cost adds up to
the control account cost one or more
work packages are clubbed together to
create a control account and manage the
cost of the work packages
next the project costs are identified
there can be multiple control accounts
in a project
now once the project cost is calculated
some reserve is added to take care of
any uncertainties you may have made some
assumptions to calculate the cost of the
activities and by adding some reserve
you would want to take care of those
uncertainties in this case make a note
that you are accounting for the
assumptions made and it can be said that
this reserve takes care of known
uncertainties this reserve is also
called contingency reserve
at this point you have arrived at the
cost baseline that is the cost for the
project that will be used for budgeting
and tracking purposes
once the planned cost is arrived there
is another reserve that gets added
called management reserve note that
management reserves are not part of the
cost baseline and are used during
emergencies only by adding contingency
reserve you have taken care of known
uncertainties and by adding management
reserve you take care of unknown
uncertainties that is those risks that
perhaps have not yet been identified
unknown uncertainties are added based on
experience or expert judgment
project risk management includes the
processes of conducting risk management
planning
identification analysis
response planning and controlling risk
on a project
the key objective of risk management is
to increase the probability and or
impact of positive events and decrease
the probability and or impact of
negative events
there are six risk management processes
plan risk management identify risks
perform qualitative risk analysis
perform quantitative risk analysis and
plan risk responses belong to the
project planning group and control risks
belong to the monitoring and controlling
process group in this lesson we will
focus on project stakeholder management
there are 47 processes in project
management grouped into ten knowledge
areas and mapped to five process groups
in this lesson we will look at the tenth
knowledge area that is project
stakeholder management and its processes
in the next screen let us understand who
stakeholders are a stakeholder is
anybody who has a stake in the project a
stakeholder may be an individual a group
or an organization who may affect or be
affected by or perceived to be affected
by a decision activity or outcome of a
project further the nature of the impact
can be positive or negative thus giving
rise to the notion of positive or
negative stakeholders irrespective of
whether a stakeholder is positive or
negative it is important to engage with
the stakeholders and get them involved
in the project this can make a critical
difference to the success or failure of
the project a single disgruntled
stakeholder can bring the entire project
to its knees whereas an actively engaged
and influential stakeholder can have the
opposite effect let us understand who
the common stakeholders of a project are
there are several categorizations of
stakeholders the project managers
themselves are important stakeholders
the project team members represent
stakeholders in the project the senior
management of the organization which is
working on the project has a stake in
the project the sponsor that is the
person or entity that provides the money
and resources for the project and
essentially champions the project is an
important stakeholder the customer which
may be different from the sponsor is a
stakeholder as well for instance and
many of the projects in the social
sector the sponsor may be the government
or a development agency whereas the
customers would be the people who
actually benefit from it the end users
which may be different from the
customers or the sponsors are
stakeholders too
the vendors or suppliers who provide
goods or services to the project are
important stakeholders people whose
lives may be impacted by the output of
the project are also stakeholders
for example if a highway project
requires possession of privately owned
land people whose land is being taken
away are the stakeholders if the
construction of a dam or water reservoir
benefits the downstream farming
communities they are the stakeholders
here competitors who provide alternative
goods or services are stakeholders too
sometimes environmentalists or other
social groups may become stakeholders
the government or political leadership
may become stakeholders for projects in
the public domain it is sufficient to
state that there could potentially be
hundreds of stakeholders for a large
project it is in the interest of the
project manager and the project team to
clearly identify all such stakeholders
up front and then actively manage them
throughout the project in the next
screen let us discuss the classification
models for stakeholder analysis
not all the stakeholders have the same
amount of influence or power over the
project
therefore the way to manage each
stakeholder needs to be calibrated based
on a proper classification of the
stakeholders
this is the role of the classification
model you can come up with a grid that
maps the power of the stakeholders the
interest they have the influence they
may have or the impact that they can
have on the project through the power
interest power influence or influence
impact grids it can be represented by
mapping stakeholders to a power or
interest grid the diagram on the screen
has x-axis which represents interest
level and y-axis which represents the
power level based on the various
combinations of power levels and
interest levels the grid can be divided
into four quadrants
the stakeholders on the top right
quadrant with high power and high
interest need to be managed closely
that is you have to monitor their
involvement and engagement very closely
the stakeholders on the bottom right
quadrant with high interest but low
power need to be kept in the loop that
is you should share information with
them and keep them regularly informed
the stakeholders on the top left
quadrant with high power but low
interest can be managed by keeping them
happy for example by making sure that
their interests and opinions are taken
into consideration the stakeholders on
the left bottom quadrant with low power
and low interest may be managed less
actively by simply monitoring how things
are going with them the salience model
describes classes of stakeholders based
on their power ability to impose their
will
urgency need for immediate attention and
legitimacy appropriateness of their
involvement level this is a useful
framework to guide the stakeholder
management strategy on a project
practice creating power grids for
business scenarios this will help in
understanding the level of engagement a
project manager needs to maintain with
various stakeholders
in the next screen
let us discuss the stakeholder
engagement assessment matrix
the stakeholder engagement assessment
matrix allows visualizing the current
and desired states of a stakeholder's
involvement in the project the five
levels of involvement are as unaware
resistant neutral supportive and leading
unaware is where the stakeholder is not
aware of the project or its impact
resistant is where the stakeholder is
aware of the impacts and is resistant to
change
neutral is where the stakeholder is
aware of the project and is neither
supportive nor in opposition to the
project supportive is where the
stakeholder is aware of the project and
its impact and is supportive of the
change leading is where the stakeholder
is aware of the project and impacts and
is actively engaged to ensure that the
project is successful
let us now look at the matrix the table
has one row per stakeholder identified
you place c in the column which best
indicates the current level of
engagement for that stakeholder then you
place d in the column which best
indicates the desired state of
engagement this table can be a quick
visualization tool that helps understand
where work has to be done in the
stakeholder management activities in the
next screen let us discuss the skills
required for stakeholder management
stakeholder management is both an art
and a science
since it involves dealing with people
and people are inherently non-linear and
unpredictable there is no one size that
fits all strategies or tools that will
work while managing them
however a project manager may use a few
traits and techniques while managing
stakeholders which are classified as
interpersonal skills and managerial
skills
a project manager must possess good
interpersonal skills that is must invest
the time and energy to build trust
this involves multiple things such as
establishing a personal rapport
following through on commitments being
punctual etc once the trust is
established it helps in smoothing many
difficult bends conflict management is
an important skill for a project manager
while communicating with stakeholders
the project manager must practice active
listening
they must not assume that they have all
the answers
instead they should spend some time to
understand the issues and the
stakeholders points of view this alone
can go a long way in smoothing ruffled
feathers and building constructive
relationships resistance to change is
natural a project manager must know how
to convert that into a positive energy
in its favor managerial skills that may
help in accomplishing the project
objectives a project manager must be
able to build consensus among the group
while absolute uniformity may not always
be possible or desirable the project
manager must use techniques to ensure
widespread discussions and arrive at a
path that the group can buy into
the project manager must be able to
influence people often without
necessarily being in the position of
authority
the project manager must be skillful to
negotiate agreements the project manager
must be able to understand and modify
organizational behavior in order to move
the project in a certain direction
network diagram is extensively used in
the project time management knowledge
area to plot the activity dependencies
this is a graphical representation of
the project activities in the form of a
network
there are two ways to draw a network
diagram
in precedence diagramming model pdm or
activity on node aon
boxes represent activities and the
arrows indicate the dependency
this type of network can have all four
types of relationships between the
activities
in arrow diagramming model adm or
activity on arrow aoa
the arrows represent activities
the relationships and sequences can be
inferred from the direction of the
arrows and linkages between the
activities
in such types of network only finish to
start relationships can be shown
such diagrams may need to make use of
dummy activities to indicate some
dependency between the activities
there may be questions in the pmp exam
based on the network diagram
so create and work with the diagram
this will make answering network diagram
based questions easy and fun
in the next screen let us look at a
network diagram
a sample network diagram is shown on the
screen
activities a and c can happen in
parallel
b and d require both a and c to complete
whereas e requires both b and d to
complete activity on aero network
diagram makes use of hammock activities
they are used to show a comprehensive
summary activity combining several other
activities underneath for control and
reporting purposes
in this lesson we will focus on project
scope management
there are 47 processes in project
management grouped into 10 knowledge
areas and mapped to five process groups
in this lesson we will look at the
second knowledge area that is project
scope management and its processes
let us begin with the first topic of
this lesson that is project scope
management
project scope management includes the
processes required to ensure that a
project comprises all and only the work
required to complete the project
successfully
the project scope management is
concerned about the scope what is not
there in the scope is also clearly
identified
in the next screen let us look at the
key activities performed under project
scope management
let us look at a few of the typical
activities that happen as part of the
project scope management
constant monitoring is essential to make
sure that all the project work is being
completed
the gradual uncontrolled increase in
scope of the project is referred as
scope creep
it is necessary to define the project
scope boundaries and not let people
randomly add to the project scope
gold plating is doing more than what is
required as part of the project scope
this has to be avoided in projects
as per the published statistics about
projects done globally less than forty
percent of projects can be considered
successful
therefore the focus should be on what is
required rather than squandering around
with what is not required
forty percent might be considered less
but a project is classified as
successful only if it meets all its
objectives and is done within time and
cost budgets
in the next screen let us understand the
differences between product scope and
project scope
project scope management deals with
managing both the product scope as well
as the project scope
product scope refers to the features and
functions that characterize a product
service or result
the word product may also include
creation of a service for example in the
banking industry each of their services
is called a product
likewise a savings account is one of
their products mutual fund is another on
the other hand project scope is the work
that needs to be accomplished to deliver
the output of the project which could be
a product service or result with the
specific features and functions
for instance to deliver a product you
may also need to produce a requirements
document or a design document
these are not part of the product scope
but it may very well be part of the
project scope
in the next screen let us discuss a few
key terms used in the project scope
management
wbs stands for work breakdown structure
it means breaking the project
deliverables into smaller and more
manageable components called work
packages
the last level of work in such
subdivision is called work packages and
the whole structure is called wbs
for example a typical software
development project would have various
activities like finalizing requirements
designing the new system coding testing
and going live with the new system
each of these translates into high level
deliverables which can be further
subdivided into smaller activities which
are more predictable
wbs dictionary like any dictionary
contains the explanation of the terms
used in wbs
a typical wbs dictionary has details
like the control account name of the
work package description of the work
package resource assigned if there are
any assumptions or dependencies to
complete the work package the due date
to finish the work package technical
dependencies and so on
wbs dictionary is useful for the person
or group working on the work packages as
it further elaborates the decomposed
work package
control account is a level within wbs at
which management wishes to exercise
control for example perform earned value
analysis track performance etc in this
lesson we will focus on project
integration management
there are 47 processes in project
management grouped into 10 knowledge
areas and mapped to five process groups
in this lesson we will look at the first
knowledge area that is project
integration management and its processes
in the next screen let us understand the
concept of project integration
management
project integration management involves
unification consolidation articulation
and integrative actions that are crucial
for successfully completing the project
the project integration management is
high level work that project manager
does and it involves managing
interdependencies among the other
knowledge areas the other nine knowledge
areas involve detailed work in a
specific direction for example project
cost management deals only with how to
manage cost in a project
the project management processes do not
happen independently for example a new
resource added to the project may
require changes in cost or schedule or
both
in dealing with such situations the
project manager integrates the processes
of project management the need for
integration drives much of the
communication and the work of the
project manager
let us discuss the key role of project
manager sponsor and team in the next
screen
project manager team members and project
sponsors have different roles to play in
a project
the project manager is supposed to play
multiple roles in the project the key
role is to perform integration
the project manager puts all the pieces
of the project together into a cohesive
whole
in doing so the project manager tries to
ensure that the project is done faster
cheaper and utilizes resources optimally
while meeting the project objectives
as the project progresses the team
members work on completing the project
activities
the role of the project sponsor is to
protect project from any unnecessary
changes and to ensure that it has the
required resources for completion the
project sponsor is the champion for the
project within the performing
organization that is the organization in
which the work is being performed
in the next screen we will cover the
project selection methods
an organization can undertake a project
under contract with an external
organization or take up a project driven
by internal business needs
there should be a formal process of
selecting project in all organizations
to ensure that it is making the best
possible use of limited corporate
resources
for example
if the organization has an option to
take up any one out of the two projects
both of which use the same corporate
resources the organization would
naturally select the one which is more
profitable
there are two broad ways to select a
project
one way is the benefit measurement
method where one project is compared
with other competing projects
another approach is based on
mathematical models wherein you examine
the most optimal selection of projects
by trying to optimize a goal for example
maximize operating profits
such methods may be called constrained
optimization methods
there are different methods under both
these categories and you should be
familiar with the names of these methods
broadly the benefit measurement methods
focus on ascertaining the costs and
benefits of undertaking the project
the methods under benefit measurement
method include murderboard where a panel
of experts shoots down a new project
idea peer review scoring models economic
models and benefit compared to cost
the constrained optimization methods
rely on mathematical modeling techniques
to determine the best selection of
projects to achieve certain business
objectives
the methods of constrained optimization
method include linear programming
in reality you might not have seen these
methods to be followed in project
selection
often personal relationship with the
sponsor may be more important than
anything else
this is quite normal and any
organization worldwide works this way
however as a certified project manager
it is important for you to be familiar
with more scientific methods of project
selection
a typical question on the pmp exam could
be
what type of project selection technique
is peer review
and the right answer is benefit
measurement method
you need to understand the
characteristics of various project
selection methods to answer scenario
based questions
in the next screen we will focus on the
project selection methods
there are five project management
processes which are part of project
integration management knowledge area
they are the develop project charter
done in the initiation process group
develop project management plan
undertaken in the planning process group
direct and manage work carried out in
the executing process group
monitor and control project and perform
integrated change control undertaken in
the monitoring and controlling process
group and close project or phase done in
the closing process group
develop project charter is an initiating
process
a project charter is essentially a
document that authorizes a project
once a project has received a charter it
means that the project manager can start
employing the organization's resources
for the project activities
let us look at the key inputs to be
considered in preparing the project
charter
the first input is the project statement
of work this is created by project
sponsor
or the customer describing their needs
project scope and how the project fits
into their strategic goal
if the project is taken up under a
contract the request for proposal that
is rfp can be considered as project
statement of work
the next input is the business case
this document establishes whether the
investment in a project is worth from a
business point of view
the business need for the project and
the cost benefit analysis
it provides important information to the
project manager about the goals of the
project and the boundaries in terms of
the desired results cost etc
if the project is being undertaken as
part of a contract or agreement the
agreement provides an important input
for the project manager that establishes
what must be done in the project
the next input to be considered for
project charter is enterprise
environmental factors
any project to be executed within the
organization
has to deal with the organization
culture and existing systems you can
consider this as an organization baggage
that comes with the project
this is the reason a project being
executed in two different organizations
may be done differently
another factor to be considered is
organizational process assets
this is a broad term and includes all
the organizational processes procedures
and policies corporate knowledge base
and historical project information
every organization develops a set of
processes procedures and policies that
are based on the best practices learned
by the organization over time
the historical information includes past
project management plans risks lessons
learned etc of similar projects executed
now let us look at the tools and
techniques used in this process
the first technique is expert judgment
expert judgment is an invaluable input
to the process of formally authorizing a
project because an expert can provide
insights into why a project makes
business sense or why it does not
from experience they may be able to shed
light about the validity of the business
drivers feasibility assumptions and
constraints that need to be considered
for the project
facilitation techniques is another
technique used
the chartering process is often a
collaborative activity involving many
influential stakeholders in an
organization
facilitation techniques help bring all
these stakeholders together and engage
in fruitful discussions in order to
arrive at an informed decision whether
to go ahead with a project or not
the only output of this project is the
project charter let us try to understand
what the project charter might contain
the project charter usually contains the
high level project requirement and it
should be created by the project sponsor
and handed over to the project manager
the project manager can do the
groundwork to prepare the project
charter but it must be signed by the
project sponsor or somebody in the
performing organization who is higher in
authority than the project manager it is
important to point out that a project
charter is not a project management plan
the detailed risk schedule cost analysis
etc is part of the project management
plan and should be done during the
project planning phase when there is
more detail on the availability of the
project to do so
the charter should be sufficiently high
level to accommodate the minor changes
that might arise in the project
in this lesson we will focus on project
management processes
project life cycle addresses the
question what to do to get the work done
it varies industry wise for example let
us look at a typical project life cycle
in a software industry
first you understand what is required
and analyze it as part of the
requirement analysis phase
then as part of the design phase you
figure out the implementation of it and
arrive with the approach
next you implement the functionality by
writing the code as part of the coding
phase
the code is then verified to ensure it
works right as part of the testing phase
the tested and verified software is then
installed at the customer locations as
part of the installation phase
after the installation the system then
moves into operations and support phase
the project management process addresses
the question
what to do to manage the project
the processes for managing the projects
are likely to be the same across
industries
for instance in the develop schedule
process one needs to develop the project
schedule irrespective of the industry or
domain you are working
in the next screen let us understand the
project management process groups
the project management processes are
divided into five process groups
they are initiating process group
planning process group executing process
group monitoring and controlling process
group
and closing process group
the initiating process happens at the
beginning of the project or phase
the planning executing ads monitoring
and controlling processes go together
therefore you plan execute and re-plan
based on the execution result
the project closing processes are
performed when the project work or a
phase within the project is completed
the typical project management process
in the closing phase releases resources
back to the resource pool so the team
members can be assigned to another
project
note the iteration of processes within
the phases is dependent on the scale of
the projects small projects may have
only one iteration whereas bigger
projects may have multiple iterations
before they enter a new phase
project management processes are
overlapping activities
let us look at the interaction between
these activities in the next screen
process groups have overlapping
activities that occur throughout the
project life cycle
the output of one process group is
generally the input to another or a
deliverable of the project
for example project management plan is
an output of planning process group and
an input to execution process group
note that production of the plan is not
a one-time activity
as the project progresses the project
management plan may get updated as a
result of the monitoring and controlling
processes
the updated project management plan once
again forms an input to the execution
process group
in the next screen we will discuss the
project management process group
knowledge area and project management
process mapping
given on the screen is the list of the
47 project management processes
10 knowledge areas and 5 process groups
the table shows how each of them is
interrelated
you can see that the project integration
management processes can be mapped back
to all five process groups while project
scope management processes are mapped
back to only planning and monitoring
process group study the table to
identify processes under project
management and the knowledge area they
belong to
all the 47 processes are described in
detail in this tutorial
each knowledge area is covered in detail
as a lesson it also covers how the
processes map to process groups to help
you understand the big picture
further the inputs and outputs of each
of these processes tools and techniques
that are used in these processes and
what exactly happens during these
processes are also discussed
earned value technique is an excellent
way to track the project progress
against the project plan
it is a method of measuring the project
performance objectively and comparing it
against the project baseline
results from an earned value analysis
indicate deviation of the project from
cost and schedule baselines
baseline is the initial approved value
along with approved changes
therefore schedule baseline is the first
approved project schedule along with
approved changes
there are various terms used in earned
value technique planned value is the
authorized budget assigned to the
scheduled work
earned value is the work performed in
terms of budget authorized for that work
actual cost is the cost incurred in work
performed
budget at completion is the budgeted
amount for the total work
estimate at completion is the expected
total cost for the project
estimate to complete is the expected
cost to finish all the remaining project
work
variance at completion is the projected
budget surplus or deficit at the end of
the project all the parameters displayed
on the screen are measured in terms of
cost
you may come across business scenario
based questions on earned value
management in the pmp exam so ensure
that you develop a clear understanding
of this topic
let us look at an example of a planned
value in the next screen
planned value is the estimated value of
the work planned
this value is measured in terms of
currency say dollar if the plan value is
three hundred forty dollars then the
work plan is worth three hundred forty
dollars
how do you calculate earned value the
solution is add the budget allocated to
each of the activities that have been
completed at the point of time
the resulting value is the earned value
in the next screen let us look at the
formula used to calculate earned value
in cost variance negative means the
project is over budget
positive means the project is under
budget
similarly in schedule variance negative
means the project is behind schedule
whereas positive means the project is
ahead of schedule
the value of the next two parameters
cost performance index cpi and schedule
performance index spi values vary
between 0 and 1.
for example a cpi of 0.8 implies that 80
cents of work is obtained for every
dollar spent in the project
similarly if spi is 0.9
it implies that project is progressing
at only 90 percent of the speed
originally planned
the next parameter is estimate at
completion or eac
there are different ways of calculating
the eac value the method used depends on
how the cost and schedule variances are
expected to play for the rest of the
project
bac by cpi is used if you expect that
the current cost performance will
continue until the end of the project
ac plus bac minus ev is used if you
expect that the rest of the project will
be managed at the budgeted rate
ac plus bac minus ev by the product of
cpi and sbi
is used if you want to factor in the
impact of the cost as well as schedule
variances
ac plus etc is used if you want to
re-evaluate the project based on a
forecast value for the estimated cost of
the remainder of the project
the next parameter is estimate to
complete or etc
which is the cost of project from this
point to the end
this is calculated by subtracting the
actual cost from the estimate at
completion
in addition variance at completion can
be calculated by subtracting the
estimate at completion from the budget
at completion
variance at completion is the cost
estimation whether it is over or under
budget
another parameter is the to complete
performance index or tcpi
this is the cost performance needed to
achieve a desired outcome
for example
if the project needs to be managed to
the original budget bac then tcpi that
is the cpi that must be maintained for
the rest of the project
is calculated as
bac minus ev by bac minus ac
similarly if it has to be managed within
a revised target say eac
then tcpi is calculated as
bac minus ev by eac minus ac
before the start of the pmp exam please
make a note of the formulas of earned
value technique
in the next screen let us look into a
business scenario to understand this
concept better after reading the problem
statement click the solution button to
look at a possible answer
let us take the example of a software
development project there are four
phases and each phase takes a month to
complete and is expected to cost ten
thousand dollars
the phases are planned to be completed
one after the other the status of the
project at the end of the month three is
summarized in the table
requirements definition is completed and
actual spending on this is ten thousand
dollars
architecture and design is done and
actual spending on this is twelve
thousand dollars
development and unit testing is only
fifty percent done though it was
supposed to be completed by third month
it has cost nine thousand dollars until
date
system testing and go live has not yet
started
note s indicates start time
f indicates finish time and pf indicates
that it is partly finished at the end of
the month
based on the above information calculate
the cv sv cpi and spi of the project
let us look at a solution in the next
screen
before we end this lesson let us also
look at a few definitions that might be
useful for your pmp examination
law of diminishing return this means the
more you put into something the less you
get out of it for example doubling the
number of resources working on a project
will not necessarily have the time
working capital the amount of money the
company has to invest on the project and
the day-to-day company operations
funding limit reconciliation the process
of comparing the planned expenditure in
a given period with the available
funding for that period
large assets purchased by the company
lose value over time
this is called depreciation
there are two forms of depreciation
straight line and
accelerated same amount of depreciation
is taken every year for instance a car
with a price tag of ten thousand dollars
and useful life of ten years is
depreciated one thousand dollars per
year
at the end of the tenth year the value
of the car is considered zero for all
accounting purposes accelerated
depreciation depreciates faster than the
straight-line depreciation for instance
a car with a price tag of ten thousand
dollars depreciates three thousand
dollars the first year one thousand five
hundred the next year one thousand the
third year and so on
critical path is defined as the longest
duration path through a network diagram
which determines the shortest time to
complete the project
float can be considered as a buffer time
available to complete an activity
float is calculated once the network
diagram is ready
it is also called as slack
there are three kinds of float
the first being the total float which is
the amount of time an activity can be
delayed without delaying the project end
date or an intermediary milestone
the second type of flute is free float
which is the amount of time an activity
can be delayed without delaying the
early start date of its successor or
successors activities
the last type is independent float which
is the amount of time an activity can be
delayed if all the predecessors finish
at their latest finish dates and you
want to start all the immediate
successors at their earliest start dates
the slack of the activities on the
critical path is zero
because there is no scope to delay
activities on the critical path
critical path actually represents the
project duration
delaying activities on the critical path
is as good as delaying the project
duration concept-based questions on
critical path can be expected in the
exam so it is essential to have a clear
understanding of the concept
in the next screen let us learn how to
calculate float
let us look at an example for critical
path
there are five activities in this
project and two paths in the network
diagram
start 1 2 4
5 and is one path
and start one three five end is the
second path
since the duration of the path start one
two four five end is 18 days which is
more than the duration of the path start
one three five end the critical path of
the project is start one two four five
end
let us take activity 3 as an example
first calculate the early start and
early finish dates
activity 3 can start only after activity
1.
since the early finish of activity 1 is
3 it becomes the early start of activity
three
activity three cannot start earlier than
three because activity one can be
completed only by then
therefore early start of activity three
is 3
since the duration of the activity is 4
days
the early finish of activity 3 is 3 plus
4 equals 7 days
now let us calculate the late start and
late finish of activity three
late start of activity five is fourteen
days the activity three happens just
before activity five
so the late finish of activity three is
fourteen days
to calculate the late start you can
subtract the duration from late finish
therefore the late start of activity 3
is 14 minus 4 equals 10.
in the next screen let us focus on
schedule compression hi welcome to
project management tools tutorial from
simply learn i am cmr chandra mr a
certified project management
professional as part of this tutorial we
are going to look at about project
management tools essential features of
project management tools top 10 project
management tools currently used in the
industry so what is project management
tools why should we use project
management tools while doing project
management so project management tools
help to keep a streamlining flow in
project management processes the tools
help the team or an individual to carry
out the steps of project management in
an effective and efficient manner so
project management tools features and
functionalities so basically a project
management tool should have minimum
fulfilling these features and
functionality they should be simple to
use customizable they should have api
for integration it should help in
collaboration it should help in risk
analysis and real time reporting when we
say simple to use the project management
tools need to be suitable for every
project we do one needs to find a tool
that will have a pleasant interface and
increase work productivity the project
management tool must be easy to
configure according to the organization
needs every project management approach
every project management templates every
artifacts needs tailoring and adaption
before adopting as part of the practice
there are business patterns that change
every day so having customizable tool is
an added advantage api or application
programming interface enables the
sharing of data and application between
devices the tools with api integration
allows seamless connectivity amongst the
team the project management tools must
allow for collaboration so that whole
team can work together collaboration not
only makes that task easier but also
increases the productivity of the
project risk analysis helps to identify
analyze and respond to the risk quickly
and efficiently it needs to capture all
the details of the risks their impacts
the probability of occurrence of the
risk and risk responses and tracking
them throughout the project lifecycle
the real-time reporting enables the
access of data at different locations of
the project management one can assess or
access data at any time about the
project's current status this will help
in having a real-time update about the
project status to the stakeholders of
the project the top 10 project
management tools what we have today in
the market are
monday.com rick jira software trello
asana teamwork meister task basecamp
oracle's primavera and microsoft project
management tool so let us look at these
one by one so monday.com was released
during the year 2012 and it is known for
providing features to enable flexible
planning and monitoring capabilities the
website where you can find monday.com
access the tool is www.monday.com
so this tool is used by more than 90 000
team across the globe monday.com
features and functionality includes it
is easy for collaboration highly
customizable excellent for analytics
integration with dropbox google drive
and pipedrive is possible surprising the
basic version is dollar 25 on monthly
basis so which will provide you 5gb
storage one boat per dashboard and it is
built annually the standard package
includes 5gb storage 3 boards per
dashboard and it is 39 per month which
is built annually professional includes
unlimited storage 10 boats per dashboard
and it costs dollar 59 per month and it
is built annually monday.com is used by
the following customers organizations of
monday.com that is scarcebug discovery
channel adidas storm phillips etc rick
is another project management tool which
was released in 2006 so this application
provides its user with robust features
and allows them to collaborate with each
other the website to access the tool is
www www.rec.com and this is used by over
18 000 organizations across the globe
the features of rick includes it has
collaborative editing flexible workflow
real-time reporting and efficient work
management the pricing includes 0 to 5
users it has basic integrations and
which is free whereas professional
includes dollar 9.8 per user per month
which is which has a slabs of 5 10 and
15 users and rick proof free trial
business
version has five to 200 users and rig
proof free trial whereas
24.80 dollars per user per month the
companies which uses the rig tools are
airbnb laurel teamviewer tiffany and co
etc now let us look at jira software
jira software was released during year
2002 it is a software development tool
used by agile teams famous for its bug
tracking system the website to access
this tool is www.atlacian.com
software
jira used by over 65 000 customers the
features of jira software includes agile
reporting rich toolkit for developers
bug tracking mobile applications so the
pricing of jira software is as follows
so for forever 2gb storage and community
support which cost dollar zero but a
standard is around dollar seven per user
per month which includes 250 gb storage
and nine to five standard support
premium is dollar 14 per user per month
unlimited storage and has 24 7 premium
support jira software is used by the
organizations that is hitachi visa
dropbox nestle dominos coca-cola samsung
etc now let us look at the tool trello
so this application was released in 2011
it is known for providing flexibility in
organizing and prioritizing the tasks
with the help of its boards lists and
cards website to access the tool is
www.trello.com
used by over 50 million people the
features of trello includes smooth
editing easy file uploads from dropbox
or google drive high security standards
and easy data searching techniques so
the pricing includes it is free for
10 mv per attachment and 10 team votes
business class includes 250 mb
attachment unlimited team boards and it
cost dollar 9.99 per user per month
annually enterprise version provides 250
mb for attachment unlimited team boats
and costs around 20.83 dollars per
hundred users per month the companies
who use trello are google adobe paypal
unicef the new york times etc now let us
look at asana the asana tool was
released during 2008 it is an high
quality task management software that
makes the tracking of tasks easy across
the project management the website to
access this tool is
www.asana.com used by over 140 000
companies the features includes
incredible task management gantt charts
privacy controls easy progress tracking
the pricing includes the basic model
asana is provides 0 to 15 people
beginners in the project management so
premium includes custom fields priority
support where the pricing is dollar
10.99 per user per month annually the
business version includes advanced
integration priority support and it
costs 24.99
per hundred users per month the
companies which uses asana are deloitte
vodafone red bull uber salesforce nasa
etc let us look at teamwork tool
teamwork was released during year 2007.
it is a cloud-based project management
solution that helps in managing group
activities and establishing flexible
communication the website to access this
tool is www.teamwork.com
used by our 370 000 organizations the
features of teamwork includes high
quality crm helpdesk software risk
register and easy time tracking the
pricing includes 0 to 5 users and 100 mb
file space is provided free of cost
whereas pro version includes 5 to 50
users 100 gb file spaces which cost 9
dollars per user per month premium
origin costs around dollar 15 per user
per month which includes 5-100 users and
250 gb file space the organizations who
use teamworks are forbes ebay microsoft
studios hp paypal disney's honda
now let us look at the tool meister task
so this tool was released during year
2015 and it is known for providing
automated and streamlined workflows to
make the overall processes more
productive the website to access this is
www.mastertask.com
used by our 2 million users the features
of this tool includes it is simple to
use seamless workflow gantt charts
flexible project boards the pricing it
is zero dollars per month up to three
projects and unlimited project members
the pro version includes unlimited
projects unlimited integrations which
costs around 8.25 dollars per user per
month whereas business costs 20.75
dollars per user per month which has
security restrictions priority email and
phone support the organization who use
the tool are virgin optics consulting
and data supports expert dot d etc base
camp the base camp tool was released
during the year 1999 it is a real-time
communication tool that allow users to
keep track of priorities and actionable
tasks the website to access this tool is
www.basecamp.com
used by over 3 million users the
features of basecamp includes easy to
use various third-party integrations
daily backups and comprehensive project
calendar the personal version is free
and 0-20 users and 1 gb store space is
provided in business version it is 99
per month for unlimited users having 500
gb storage space the companies who use
basecamp is thoughtport harvest wlb
groupon etc oracle primavera so this
tool was released during the year 1983
which is acquired by oracle corporation
in the year 2008. primavora helps
project manager to handle a vast number
of tasks with the help of its unlimited
resources and target plans website to
access this tool is
www.primavera.com which is used by over
7143 companies so features of primavera
includes creation of wbs the work
breakdown structure issues and risk
recording supports large number of
activities and easy collaboration with
project users the enterprise project
portfolio management version costs
around two seven five zero dollars per
user which improves planning and
execution professional project
management version is usd 2500 per user
handles large-scale highly sophisticated
projects so oracle primavera contract
management version module costs around
usd 2000 per user keeps construction
projects on schedule under budget so the
companies which use primavera are burns
mcdonald's pond
caddies etc microsoft project so
microsoft project management tool was
used during the year 1984. so this tool
allows users to develop a schedule
assign resources track progress and
manage budgets all through the project
the website to access this tool is
www.office.microsoft.com
project the features of microsoft
project includes simple to use effective
monitoring easy communication enhanced
decision making so this is a cloud-based
solution and the pricing is project plan
one costs around dollar ten per user per
month on an annual commitment managing
projects web web browser is the feature
project plan 3 which costs around dollar
30 per user per month with annual
commitment which is fully updated
project desktop application project plan
5 which costs around 55 dollars per user
per month with annual commitment
evaluating project ideas from anywhere
in the organization is possible through
this project standard 2019 version costs
around 620 dollars per pc per user for
those who don't need collaboration tools
and advanced features project
professional version 2019 costs around
thousand thirty dollars per pc per user
syncing with project online and project
server the organization which uses
microsoft projects are comptel airbus
intel volvo xerox etc hey guys welcome
to this trello tutorial by simply learn
so without further ado let's get started
with what exactly is trello
so trello is a simple and easy to use
collaboration tool that can enable you
to organize projects and everything
related to it into boards
with trello you can find all kinds of
information
like what's being worked on who's
working on what and what progress the
project is making now we'll learn about
that in a little bit while we're talking
about the trello demo
now let's talk about the advantages of
trello
now first off trello can be used
immediately after signing up
so trello offers you a free sign up
after which you get access to almost all
of trello's features now it does have a
premium service but most of trello's
important features are available in the
free account
secondly it follows the kanban system so
the kanban system is a popular
methodology that can be used to achieve
lean
so with trello you can also achieve lean
now trello also has a very popular
mobile application which also has the
same features as the interface that you
see on the desktop it's very user
friendly
now the fourth advantage is that all
project related items can be seen on one
page which means everything you need
about the project is available in one
place
next adding new members creating issues
and assigning them are very easy with
the help of trello
now that we had a look at all the
advantages that are provided by trello
let's have a look at a live demo
so first off let's go to trello.com
so here you can see two options to log
in or sign up so first of all if you've
never used the website before go to sign
up
so here you can enter your email or you
can go through google or hotmail or
outlook so it's very simple i already
have an account so i'll just log in
right so i'm just going to login
so if you're using shallow for the first
time this is what it would look like
so here you have personal boards
templates home and so on so let's go one
by one
firstly the most important thing that
you need to know about is boards which
is right here
so let's assume you're using this for a
deal which means that you need people to
share the board along with
so first of all let's create a team
so here i'm just going to name a company
called company go
say we do engineering id
let's write a brief team description
and continue so here say i have four
members
so have bob
i'm adding them here so
depending on what your team is like you
can add those team members so this is
important so that you can connect with
them while you're on the board so this
is company.com so we'll just add them
so the team members that you're going to
invite will get an invite email very
soon as soon as you're done by clicking
the invite to team button
we'll also add bill
who also works at my company
and there's technician one
and there's technician one who works at
company.com
we'll add anybody who's required later
so invite to team
and there you go there's some details
here about the team and all that let's
go back to home
and now let's create a new board under
company co so the difference here is
that
for personal boards is that
like the name says it's personal you can
also add the team if you want later on
but
here you have the option for creating a
team port so i'll show you how you can
create a team board from personal board
so you got create board
here you can
show as this is by default selected with
no team because it's under personal
change it to company
and you can write
business
but anything else like that
and then you create a board
and there you go the board has been set
up
so now
first things first it's that you can
make this team visible which is
either only board members can see it or
since it's a small team the entire team
can seek it
so it's up to you how you want it
there's the public option which everyone
can see which i don't think is necessary
but if you feel like it you can do that
too
first of all you can even
write description of the board which is
what you want to achieve with this board
for example this is business or sales or
something like that
you can change the background into
something more colorful or less colorful
like this
and then
there's search cards which we haven't
added anything so far so there's nothing
to search
just stickers
which again is i feel unnecessary at the
moment you can also see something called
butler so based on your usage or how
you're using trello butler can provide
you suggestions like what you can add
here like you can see here
the tips haven't been added so far
because we haven't used cello so far
so based on your usage it will give you
suggestions
now let's go back
so here you see power-ups so power-ups
are basically additional features that
you can add to your board
so there are features that are
connected to a number of different
fields this analytics automation
utilities tools and so on
so as a free user you get access to
one power up but still we don't have to
use it so far because
we don't have anything on our board but
based on your requirement you can go
through these power-ups and decide on
one of them
so now let's get back to business
or our board so first you can see add a
list
so this basically refers to the
different processes that you want to
follow in this board
so first of all we'll add a list title
i'm going to add
to do
that's the first list
then this in progress
on hold
completed
so here we have four lists which
represent
the processes in this business
so if you want you can even add another
list depending on your requirement
so in these lists there are things
called cards so which are like sub
topics so first of all let's add
a very simple
title for example
product
company
a second very simple deliver product
to company
b
like this so on and so forth if you want
it
so here this is a card so this card can
be moved from each stage to another as
it progresses
so this isn't the to-do stage since
we've not started with anything
so once you click on a card so this
pop-up shows up
so here you can add a description like
conversed with company a
ready to go
just some details that you want to add
you save
now one thing you can see add to cart so
there are a number of different things
you can add to this card
so members
now i have four team members i can add
bob
here i want bob in on this i want bob to
see the activities as it happens
i want bill to also see as things
proceed
right so the bob and bill are in on this
right now
next you have labels so depending on
what you want to use this for for
example i want to use this to represent
that it's important or immediate
put it as red
save
so
i can select this label to indicate that
this is now very important so depending
on your company's
you know style or depending on your
requirements
you can add the labels
then you have a checklist
so different steps can be focused on
with this checklist for example i'm just
going to write steps
so we're delivering a product for
example so let's just
use steps
gathering i'm just going to write the
software lifecycle steps analysis
design
implementation
testing
deployment
and maintenance
so yeah we have all the steps so one
thing is that once each of these steps
are done
you tick it
so a percentage increases so until
you're done with hundred percent you can
just keep ticking finally it'll show 100
and you're done
so another thing is a due date
so this is basically by when you want it
completed
so this is basically a reminder that we
need to complete it or before a
particular date is done so i'm not
adding a due date out of now but that's
up to you
next you have something called
attachment so say for example all your
requirements have been gathered into one
pdf so where all the requirements that
are required by the company are shown in
that pdf you can attach it here so that
everyone has access to it
then a cover can also be added to your
card which is just basically beautifying
it so we can find one so for example
this
and there you go there's a pretty good
looking code here
now
we have all the information so let's get
started
so to officially mark the beginning of
the project we'll just go and put this
to in progress so at the same time you
can do the same thing with this card as
well about company b so let's just focus
on company a now
so say the steps have already started
requirement gathering is done
designing is done
implementation is also done so
depending on the person you know the
technician
so the technician could respond that you
know
we've already started so before that we
need to add the technician he's already
on this but if you had to add him you
search for members
and you have board members who's already
in the board you can add the technician
now you can also you know
add activity details like technician one
now
how's it going
how's the process going
now he could respond here with
its
right
so each time one of us you know adds the
other or says something to the other
they get notifications so that you know
they get to respond as well they get to
know what's happening
now
now say for example
the technician is
not able to complete the project or
complete his work so it's put on hold so
here
i could say
so testing isn't done so you can say
tech
by the delay or what's going on
and he would given a property response
and once he's ready he can finish the
texting
and put it back to in progress
then eventually all of it is done
deployment and maintenance
so you here you have an option to hide
complete items that's up to you you can
also delete them if you feel like it you
can close this and then after everything
is done and you feel that everything of
the process is done you can put it on
completed so if this is a recurring
process you can you know
make a copy of this which you can find
by doing this copy
or you could just put this on archive
indicating that it's done you can even
get it back by just going
to
more archived items and then there you
have it you can send it back to board
that's up to you
and there you go that's most of
everything you need to know about trello
one another thing is that right now you
can only add 10 boards on this feed as
of now because you're using a free
membership
also depending on the intensity or the
difficulty of the board you can also
have different
boards for different projects i've just
used one for multiple projects but it's
entirely possible for you to have one
board per project you can also you know
favorite this indicating that this is a
very important one that you need to
focus on every day so this is where you
get all the notifications that x has
changed there you go
all kinds of responses everything that
you need is available on this home
screen which is basically like a home
feed
you can also find templates depending on
your requirement
so you can choose a template from a wide
variety of options so i'm just going to
show you the kanban template
so here you have details about the
template
you have an example of what the template
looks like and so on
and there you go that's everything you
need to know about trello
in this session we will be talking about
agile project management and several
other things related to it before we
begin let's have a look at all the
topics we will be covering today first
we will see the basics of agile project
management then we will check the
relevance and principles of agile
project management we will then see
necessary steps to implement agile
methodology along with that we shall
also see different frameworks involved
in the process and finally we shall see
some companies that use agile project
management so without any further ado
let's get started with what is agile
project management agile project
management as the name suggests is a
flexible approach to building a project
in agile project management the project
is broken down into several stages of
sprints agile does not work on the
principle of delivering the final
product at the end of the project it
works on delivering sections of a
project on many projects the process of
project management in the case of agile
is agile based so there won't be any
central control of project manager as it
was there in the traditional way of
working before we move forward let's
have a look at the agile development
cycle agile methodologies consist of
several small cycles or sprints at the
end of each stage we get a mini project
there's a product backlog that explains
new features changes in the existing
features and several other improvements
in the project then we have a sprint
backlog which has a list of tasks that
are to be completed during each sprint
the sprint consists of planning
designing execution testing and
deployment stages and at the end of each
sprint a mini project is delivered with
every sprint new features are added to
the product which plays a significant
role in the overall project growth after
all the sprints and early validation in
the development the final deliverable
has a fewer chances of failure let's now
have a look at some reasons why
industries have started moving towards
agile project management the first
reason is high product quality when we
talk about higher product quality we
refer to the build of the product as per
stakeholders demands testing is
performed at short intervals of time
wherever needed to ensure high quality
of the product then another reason is
customer satisfaction whatever is done
in the project is known by the customer
the deliveries don't take longer
durations as they used to take in the
case of traditional ways the changes may
be provided by the customer in the
execution phase of the project third
reason is reduced risk since the project
is divided into sprints so if the risk
affects one sprint it doesn't mean whole
of the project will be at risk the
process of risk analysis continues to
take place with all the other processes
another significant reason for agile
project management is better and faster
return on investment the project is now
developed in several sprints and each
sprint has its own version therefore the
project becomes market ready after a few
sprints only since the projects can now
be released with ease and in shorter
duration this helps the organization to
stay ahead in competition with respect
to other organizations which are still
not moved to agile methodology now we
shall check the principles of agile
project management there are 10
principles for successful agile project
management the first principle is the
satisfaction of the customer by
delivering the project fast and with
least number of errors the next
principle refers to decreasing the
amount of time between the phase of
planning and delivery the third
principle states that the team of
managers and developers work together
and increase the productivity of their
work the next principle states that the
changes requested by the stakeholders
can be taken into consideration and
worked upon during the development phase
as well the fifth principle pays
attention to the factor of coordination
among the team members then the sixth
principle refers to the process of
monitoring and tracking the progress of
the project at the end of each sprint
and making amendments wherever needed
moving on the next principle states that
there must be a feeling of trust and
support towards the team to complete the
project's objectives the next principle
emphasizes on face-to-face conversations
with the development team the
face-to-face conversation helps in both
solving problems and easy knowledge
sharing then the 9 principle emphasizes
on finding solutions and maximizing the
amount of work done with simplicity this
ensures timely completion of tasks by
all the team members the last principle
states that scrum tools like monday.com
or zoho sprints must be used to simplify
the complicated codes which further
helps in saving time
we shall now see the steps in agile
project management the goal of agile
methodology is to produce shorter
development life cycles and more
frequent product releases than
traditional waterfall project management
so we will now check 6 steps in agile
project methodology the first step in
the process is project planning project
planning includes feasibility study
development of scope breaking the
project into executable tasks or sprints
and then estimating the amount of time
needed to complete those sprints the
second step is the step of roadmap
creation a roadmap is a plan of action
that shows how a project shall evolve
over time a list of all the features
that the final product should have is
created and the steps to achieve those
features are taken the next important
step is release planning since we are
doing the project keeping in mind the
agile project methodology the project
will complete in sprints that means
there will be the release of features at
the end of each cycle and unlike the
traditional waterfall model the
development cycles will be smaller the
fourth step in agile project management
is sprint planning the sprints are made
keeping in mind what all is to be
accomplished in that particular step at
the beginning of each sprint the goal of
that sprint is decided and steps to
achieve that goal are taken the next
step in the process emphasizes on daily
meetings there are short meetings every
day to discuss if the team was able to
finish the task for each sprint and
check if there are any amendments that
are required each team member talks
about what they achieved in the last
print and what are they going to work on
in the next print the last step is the
step of sprint review and retrospective
there are two meetings after each sprint
first meeting is for the sprint review
this meeting is with the stakeholders to
show them the finished product this
helps both sides to build a relationship
and discuss if there are any issues in
the end product the second meeting is
for having a sprint retrospective this
meeting involves the stakeholders to
discuss what went well and what went
wrong during the sprint sprint
retrospective takes place after the
sprint review and before the next print
planning now when we know the steps
needed for agile project methodology we
must understand some agile project
management frameworks there are several
frameworks available today here we will
be discussing some of the most popular
frameworks the first framework we will
discuss is the kanban framework kanban
framework is a well-known framework for
implementing agile software development
in the case of kanban framework work
items are represented on the kanban
board which helps all the team members
to see the state of every piece of work
at any time kanban board not only helps
in visualizing the work but also
optimizing the workflow among the team
the next framework we will discuss today
is the scrum framework scrum framework
is a popular framework for managing
complex knowledge work like in the field
of research and advanced technologies
scrum is a simple framework that helps
team work together and learn through
their experiences gained while working
on a problem the third framework we will
see today is the hybrid framework the
hybrid framework is a combination of
agile methodology and non-agile
methodology
in the case of a hybrid framework
planning is done using the traditional
way of project management while the
execution and delivery is done using the
agile methodology since the hybrid is a
combination of the two it handles the
requirement changes and delivers the
product in different stages the fourth
and the last framework we will see is
the lean framework the lean framework
works on the principle of providing
maximum customer value and creating zero
waste it focuses on optimizing the flow
of products all through the value stream
this helps in eliminating waste all
through the process and create processes
that requires less human efforts this
also simplifies the process of
information management and makes it more
accurate finally let's have a look at
some companies that have opted for agile
project management today around 22
percent of the organizations worldwide
have all their teams working on the
principle of agile project methodology
let's have a look at some of the most
prominent companies in the world that
use agile project management in the list
we have ibm cisco atnt microsoft philips
and samsung welcome to simple learns pmp
sixth edition training tutorial i am cmr
chandra mr a certified project
management professional prince to
practitioner itl expert itl for managing
professional kobit 5 and devops
today we are going to look at
understanding what is the pmp
certification what is pmbok eligibility
criteria to appear in pmp examination
the project management framework
the project management process groups
knowledge areas and processes
so now imagining the world where you
have a project being done so you are the
project manager
and how best a project can be conducted
so to make a project successful it is
required to follow a best practice
so if you have a certification just
imagine having a certification that lets
the world know that you know what you
are doing in project management so pmp
certification gives you all
so what is pmp certification
so the pmp the project management
professional certification is a
certification of pmi the project
management institute
which is at usa so is an internationally
recognized credential for project
managers
see the certification indicates
that the certified professional has a
sufficient experience education skills
and competency reason being
before going for pmp certification it
asks for specific prerequisites which
involves experience in project
management as well as
formal education of project management
and demonstrated skills so that being a
prerequisites for project management
professional certifications it is very
essential that one need to understand
what it takes to become eligible for pmp
examination so that we will go through
the subsequent slides so the moment one
has the pmp certification
that itself indicates
the prerequisites to take up a pmp
certification is accomplished already
before going for certification
and then the individual will go for a
certification and become certified
professional so that way it concludes it
also indicates that person who holds the
pmp certification has sufficient
experience education skills and
competency moreover there are more than
10 hundred thousand pmp certification
holders across the globe so pmp
certified individuals earn 25 percent
more than non-certified individuals
so now
pmp certification also has the
advantages which are given here like
helps the project manager to practice
the project management better
create the results better demonstrate
the project management capability better
so this also helps project manager to
show the commitment towards the project
management profession
and having pmp certification provides
the recognition across the globe which
helps in getting better salary compared
with people the professionals who are
not certified and also helps in
increasing the network project
management network who actually
practices project management the fellow
practice project managers who are
practicing the project management so
there are certain vocabularies jargons
which are used specifically while doing
the project management pmp helps to
understand those
so now let us look at
what does the official guide which is
used
in pmp that can help to become a project
management professionals
so that is pmbok which is
referred as project management body of
knowledge or pmbok
which is the collection of processes
best practices terminologies and
guidelines accepted as standards within
the industry
so the latest edition of this is sixth
edition which was released in 2017.
the first edition of pmbok guide was
published in 1996 and the sixth edition
as i mentioned was released in 2017
and exam format was revised from 26th
march 2018. so pmbok guide will become
the basic reference to appear in the pmp
examination so one needs to go through
the training based on pmbok guidelines
so that will help them to pass the
examination easily so eligibility
criteria for appearing for pmp
certification examinations so you can
have two types of eligibilities which
pmi defines
so option one includes
someone who has secondary degree
should have 7500 hearts of leading and
directing project that is an experience
what it is asking as a prerequisite
before
the professional go for examination plus
35 hours of project management education
formally from a registered education
provider like simply learn option two
someone who has four year degree
project management experience leading
and directing project this experience
will be 400 arts whereas as we saw in
option 1
in option 2 35 hours of project
management education is required and
that is from registered education
provider like simply learn as i
mentioned earlier so this training which
is conducted by registered education
provider
will have their trainings aligned with
pmbok the latest edition so
simply learn enables people to learn
what are the topics in pmp framework
plus
make the professionals ready to appear
the examination and become successful
the project management framework
which is defined in pmbok
includes 5 process groups 10 knowledge
areas and 49 processes
so when we say 5 process groups this
indicates the way the project flows
how each of these process groups are
connected
while project happens in the project
life cycle
whereas 10 knowledge areas are the one
which needs to be looked up to
demonstrated up to considered while
doing the project management
and the 49 processes distributed across
5 process groups and 10 knowledge areas
has the activities the objectives
the inputs outputs tools and techniques
clearly defined so that those can be
applied while doing the project
management
so those are aligned the way it is shown
in the table
so five process group that is initiating
planning executing monitoring and
control and closing these are the
process groups whereas 10 knowledge
areas includes project integration
management project scope management
project schedule management project cost
management project quality management
project resource management project
communication management project risk
management project procurement
management and project stakeholder
management so each of these knowledge
areas and process groups are aligned in
such a way
where the processes
align with a specific process group and
knowledge area can be demonstrated
accordingly
if you look at a process which goes from
initiating to planning planning to
executing and then monitoring and
control while you do monitoring and
control if there is anything found as a
deviation it may come back to planning
or executing for necessary corrections
once the necessary corrections happens
again it moves to monitoring and control
to check whether it is completely done
as expected or not if it is confirmed
everything is done as per the
requirements defined then it moves to
closing this is how the project flows in
the project life cycle whereas
all the 10 knowledge areas happens in
parallel so now if you look at
initiating process group you can see two
processes that is
develop project charter and identify
stakeholders
so develop project charter and identify
stakeholders
basically defines project charter
required for the project as well as
initial identified stakeholders who are
required to move forward in the project
similarly if you look at planning
process group you have 24 processes
which are distributed across all the 10
knowledge areas so these processes
creates a plan for the project which
involves scope baseline schedule
baseline cost baseline quality
management approach then
resource management approach means the
plan i mean to say when i say approach
i'm speaking about the plan similarly
communication management plan
risk management plan procurement
management plan stakeholder management
plan and all of these will get
consolidated into project management
plan in the integration management
knowledge area
once this plan is done and
approved then it moves for execution all
that project manager do during execution
is directing and managing project work
and managing the project knowledge
at the same time project manager would
take responsibility of managing quality
acquiring resources developing team
managing team
then communications which are planned as
per the communication management plan
communication should happen during
execution so similarly implementation of
risk responses defined while doing the
planning and conducting the procurements
as planned and then managing stakeholder
engagement so actual execution of those
work packages execution of those
deliverables happens from the team now
as those deliverables happens the
delivered products are checked monitored
and controlled you can see validate
scope control scope likewise for each
knowledge areas there is a control
process which checks is that happened in
execution as it was planned in plan
planning process group so then
that is consolidated here for monitoring
and controlling the project work in
entirety integrated similarly performing
integrated change control any deviations
found in any of these checks which is
being done in the control
now that deviations needs to be
corrected so change will be raised so
request for change will be raised and
that will be approved and controlled and
necessary directions are given approvals
are given and that moves towards
execution for implementation once it is
implemented again validation happens
once control checks if everything is
okay then it moves to the closure
now activities enclosure a project or a
face involves just an activities of
closure the products or services or
results which are created from the
project
does not go to closure until those are
validated checked confirmed and signed
off only then it goes to closing project
or phase and necessary formalities which
are required to be completed before
conclusion will happen in closing
project office this is how the project
flows second point which should keep in
mind is a project manager is also called
as an integrator so
main focus
the umbrella view the word server
project manager should have from project
integration management
so this layer project integration
management where project manager should
have an umbrella view total view about
entire project what is happening so
bigger picture only when project manager
has a bigger picture project manager can
come to the lower levels and see is are
they progressing the way it is supposed
to so then go back look at the bird's
eye view again and see is it going in
the right direction which is very
essential
so further i guess we will look at each
of these process groups and what happens
in each of the process groups
similarly in knowledge areas so let us
move forward now project management
process groups
so these process groups details the
necessary requirement that need to be
satisfied to ensure that project
resources are used efficiently
and these represents the chronological
phases that all projects go through
during the project lifecycle so starting
from initiating stage it moves to
planning
once the plan is ready then it moves to
execution as the execution happens
validation checks happens in monitoring
and control and as you find
some deviation in monitoring and control
for correction of the deviation it comes
back to execution or if any necessary
changes needs to be done in planning
also while doing these corrections then
it may move to plan then execution and
then monitoring and control so this loop
continues until the confirmation yes it
is delivered as per the plan and then it
moves to closure so that's how the
project flows and the project life cycle
would be like that so initiating process
group so initiating process group
involves the processes activities and
skills needed to define the beginning of
the project as i mentioned earlier in
initiating process group the creation of
project charter happens and
identification of the basic stakeholders
main stakeholders who are required to
understand the further requirements in
detail who needs to be engaged so those
are identified so setting up permits
authorization and initial work orders
which should be in place and are
important for effective and logical
progress of the project and success
across all project phases so this
clearly sets up the phases for the work
to be completed initializing teams and
having a
well thought out budget which is very
important so this gives that view in
totality but it will not give you the
full granular details but it sets the
directions provides that insight and
also one important thing we should keep
in mind is in initiation stage
appointment of project manager happens
the formal declaration of appointment of
project manager happens and project
charter will be formally handed over to
project manager and that formal
declaration of assignment of project
manager happens from then project
manager takes over and first activity
project manager does is identification
of stakeholders so next process group is
planning process group
where
we have around 24 processes
to define the project scope
cost schedule
quality resource
risk then procurement stakeholder
engagement so comprehensive plan if it
is
waterfall approach or basic skeleton
plan which is required if it is agile
approach so it also clarifies the goals
and expectations while putting in place
infrastructure to achieve the goals
keeping in timeline and budgetary
constraints the end-to-end view of the
project is provided in planning so this
acts as a basic reference while the
execution and monitoring and control
happens so based on the planning the way
it is done execution will happen
now next process group is executing
process group where
the role of project manager is to direct
and manage project work and manage the
project knowledge main activities being
an integrator of a project secondly
acquiring resources it may be human
resource or technology resource or any
other resource required for the project
then if it is human resource there needs
to be necessary training
development of the team and then
managing them so lot of team dynamics
are involved that needs to be handled so
this involves managing teams while
handling time expectations and achieving
benchmark goals team members
delivers those results team members does
all the activities
and then creates that results so team
concerns needs to be addressed because
as you see the people together the team
members together it is quite obvious
conflict maker so conflict resolution
should happen the engagement with the
team member should happen
so demonstration of
work which is done by the project team
that needs to be monitored and
controlled parallely which happens
during the execution monitoring and
control is also happening so project
manager should look at both so concerns
needs to be addressed execution is that
happening as per the plan has to be
checked as part of monitoring and
control while execution is happening so
bird's a view in entirety which says how
the execution should happen that needs
to be directed and monitored whereas
coming on ground seeing is that
happening the way it is required that is
also very essential so next is
monitoring and control process group now
as part of these process group as i
mentioned while execution happens it is
very essential to check
validate and control so this process
group involves processing change orders
any deviations being found
change requests are raised and if that
change request needs some modification
or changes in planning then it goes to
planning if no such planning
requirements simple change that straight
go to execution chain get executed and
then again validation happens so
integrated change management which is
there in this particular process group
so this also focuses on addressing
ongoing
budget considerations handling
unexpected circumstances that could
hamper the team's ability to meet the
initial project expectations so it goes
on throughout the project life cycle so
two process groups if you closely
observe planning process groups and
monitoring and control process groups
are the process groups where you see
processes in all the knowledge areas
otherwise if you see an initiating
process group it is only two process one
is an integration management other one
is stakeholder management if you look at
uh execution you don't see in
scope time cost and risk management
similarly if you see closing process
group only one process which is in
initiating process group so
these are the only two process groups
planning process groups and monitoring
and control process group where you see
the most of the processes so next
process group is closing process group
so closing process group closing project
or phase is a process what we have in
this process group which basically
focuses on addressing the culmination of
project management skills shown through
the other interconnected processes that
guided the projects so all the aspects
of process
are closed and all the necessary
paperwork is submitted so it can lead to
great reviews and word of mouth
referrals in the future so all the
activities which need to be done for
formal closure and conclusion which is
done in the closing process group so
this is about all the five process group
defined in the pmp framework so now let
us move towards understanding each of
the knowledge areas and the different
processes within it so how many
processes in each of the knowledge areas
aligning with with the process group we
just saw in the table but when we look
at it understand what are those exactly
so now knowledge areas are necessary for
effective project management which can
take place during any of the explained
process groups so there are 10
so those are project integration
management project scope management
project schedule management project cost
management project quality management
project resource management project
communication management then project
risk management project procurement
management project stakeholder
management so many people ask me when i
train the people they ask me how do we
remember all of this so remembering
process group will be easy because it's
the flow which if you can remember then
remembering the process group will be
easier but to remember the knowledge
areas
so one thing you should keep in mind is
initially when pm okay were defined
mostly in
until third edition or fourth edition we
used to focus on triple constraints so
when we say triple constraints we used
to tell scope cost and time
now later when
as the best practices evolved as the
pmbok evolved
so it did not limit on triple
constraints it actually said six
constraints what are the six constraints
scope
cost time quality resources
and risk so if you can able to remember
the six constraints so each of
associated with each of these
constraints there is a knowledge area
like you have project scope management
which is one of the area of constraints
similarly schedule management link to
time cost management quality management
resource management and risk management
so out of 10 easily you can able to
remember six
further there are four
now integration management by default
integrates all the nine knowledge areas
so remembering that may not be difficult
so to consolidate this
to conduct the project properly you need
stakeholders you need to procure
something and you need to communicate so
other three knowledge areas remembering
should happen by linking to this so
firstly remember
six constraints that is scope time cost
quality resource and risk then you have
communication which needs to happen to
communicate there should be stakeholder
and also there should be supply which
needs to happen to the project so if you
can link like this
nine knowledge areas you can remember so
on all these nine knowledge areas you
will integrate and manage in integration
management so in fact all the plans
which are defined in rest of the nine
knowledge areas except integration
management so all those plans are called
as subsidiary plans so all these nine
subsidiary plans that is scope
management plan schedule management plan
cost management plan quality management
plan resource management plan
communication management plan risk
management plan procurement management
plan and stakeholder management plan so
all these nine subsidiary plans are
integrated together and consolidated in
project management plan so that happens
in project integration management so
this we should keep in mind so project
integration management what does it do
so project integration management
basically includes plans to develop
project charter a document that sets up
the project and assigns the project
manager created during the initiation
phase so a project management plan is
also created which is a roadmap for the
entire project to become a success so
the project plan once approved by
stakeholders and sponsor is monitored
and tracked through the change log it
also directs and manages the project
work
this process is monitored analyzed and
reported to identify and control any
changes or problems that could be
encountered so one thing we should keep
in mind when we say project integration
management
this is the only knowledge area
where we see processes in all the
process group so we have process in
initiating process group we have
processes in planning we have process in
execution process group we have
processes in monitoring and control
process group and also in closing
process group so project integration
management is only knowledge area where
it has a processes in all the process
groups which we don't see in any other
knowledge area now next we look at the
list of processes like develop project
charter is in initiation process group
develop project management plan which
consolidates all the nine knowledge
areas is in planning process group
direct and manage project work manage
project knowledge these two processes
are in
executing process group monitor and
control project work
perform integrated change control
these two processes are in monitoring
and control process group so close
project or face is in the closing
process group so now we will move to
project scope management so when we use
the term scope
the term scope refers to the boundary
within which we need to
do something so first thing we should
keep in mind when we say project scope
two things one is the scope of that
product service or results which we are
creating which comes out as a product or
a service or result out of a project
which comes out
what is getting created so scoping that
part of it
so other scope part of it the processes
the tools the resources what is being
used
during the project so that deliverables
happen so two part of the scope we
should look at so project scope
management involves
those areas deals with the work of the
project and involves plan scope
management an important part of project
management plan the collection of
requirements of the product or service
also takes place in this process group
and also
project scope management knowledge area
deals with work of the project which
involves plan scope management an
important part of the project management
plan so the collection of requirements
of the product or service also takes
place in the stage the scope of project
is also defined in the scope statement
this is expected to undergo change over
the course of project the scope is
validated during the project
ensuring that the deliverables are
approved by sponsors or stakeholders so
as i mentioned earlier it involves the
scope of the results what is being
created and also scope of those
processes resources tools which are used
during the project so processes in
project scope management knowledge area
so plan scope management which is in
planning process group collect
requirements define scope create wbs
even these
three processes are in planning process
group in total four processes in
planning process group
whereas validate scope and control scope
these two processes are in monitoring
and control process group
so when you say plan scope management
it's about defining how to collect
the requirements how to manage those
entire scope management planning and
requirements management plan also has to
be defined then requirements are
collected from the stakeholders who are
being identified and then scope will be
defined now very important thing here is
about work breakdown structure so we
have a product or a service or a result
which we are working on to create as a
result of the project
so how will you understand all the parts
of it that needs breaking down that
particular product or services or
results which we are going to create
into multiple pieces in a structure
which would look like a tree so that you
will get a necessary insight towards
what is being delivered
so firstly product breakdown structure
is made and for each of the layers of
this product breakdown structure you
will be assigning an activities
assigning resources effort estimation
cost estimation sequencing those all
this will will be done later
basic thing needed is work breakdown
structure for that so to create wbs the
technical decomposition is used and this
approach is top down approach next
validate scope and control scope as
wbs provides that structure of various
things which needs to be delivered
referring to that as the execution
happens validation should happen whether
it is delivered accordingly or not and
is that scope management is being done
according to the plan control scope will
be checking that
so next is the project schedule
management when we say schedule it's
quite obvious for us to understand
when what needs to be done
so what needs to be done is already told
in scope and when are we going to do
that for that you need to have a
specific schedule the timeline so
the project will have various different
activities tasks
which is assigned to the particular wbs
element
so
these activities will have a specific
start date end date
and this will have a specific output
which is coming out as part of those
actions which happens so the project is
divided into tasks each with their own
start dates and deadlines and budgets so
these are revised as the project moves
forward depending on how the project is
progressing a schedule for the project
and determining who is responsible for
that so
helps us to understand which resource is
required at what point in time similarly
the cash flow requirement can also be
understood by having a defined schedule
so the tasks are placed in a sensible
order and the dependencies between each
of them are noted once sequenced the
resources required for the tasks are
estimated and assigned the time required
for each of these tasks are also
determined now when we say this we will
require to understand and visualize
while doing a project the wba structure
is defined and in what sequence each of
these elements are delivered and
what timeline start time end time and
how each of these are connected to other
wbs element in what sequence what
activity is required what resource
required what effort required what
competency skill required so all these
are put in so since we schedule and
sequence it we know when is that
required
so this requires working with other
knowledge area very closely when i say
wbs element it's quite obvious it comes
from scope management when i say
allocation of resources obviously it has
to work with resource management to
create resource calendars if it's a cost
management to understand the flow money
flow cash flow so budget should be there
for the project so cash flow when what
amount is required to understand that it
cost is linked to schedule
so all these knowledge areas should work
very closely with coordinating with each
other interfacing with each other so
project schedule management also uses a
very important technique called network
analysis technique where we speak about
critical path
then forward pass backward pass
then identification of floats
so when is a critical path critical path
refers to the longest path in the
established network diagram of a project
and that will be the minimum time
required for project to complete so this
critical path needs to be closely
monitored as the execution of the
project happens because any delay in
this critical path will delay the
project itself
so that's about some summary about
schedule management now let us look at
the processes which are involved in
schedule management so plan schedule
management define activities sequence
activities estimate activity durations
develop schedule
so all these five processes are in
planning process group so schedule
management how it has to be done needs
to be clearly planned as part of plan
schedule management then when to define
activities it is quite obvious we need
to know what needs to be delivered so
wbs element helps us when the scope
baseline is provided as an input here
so taking that activities are defined
then the sequencing happens then when we
say estimate activity durations
so we speak about two terms like effort
and duration if i want to deliver
something let me assume uh to deliver x
for a person it requires one day
or for a person it requires 10 days if
we say so to create that working piece
of a product it takes 10 man days we
will say that is an effort
now if i have 100 pieces of such news to
be created
how many mandates i need so 10 into 100
piece
10 days into 100 piece so 1000 mandates
now how many resources i have i may have
around 25 resources now thousand divided
by 25 it will be around i guess 400 400
band is no i think 2 thousand divided by
uh it's about 4
40
so
40 mandates of effort means that is
duration whereas effort is
1000 mandates 40 days will become
duration
so likewise looking at how many
resources we have how many uh what is
that effort is actually required is
involved and then what is the duration
within which we need to complete it
either you look at how many resource i
have based on that i will look at the
duration or i will look at the target
date mainly target date is given by
customers as you discuss when the
project needs to be completed
accordingly you are required to acquire
the resources so this itself is showing
us these knowledge areas now work very
closely now without scope you cannot
define activities
now without understanding the activities
you don't know what is the effort
so now once you understood the effort
you know what resource what competency
when so you need to work with resource
management so to have those resources
on boarded or acquired you need to have
money cost so what cost it takes so
likewise it goes one by one hello
operating that's where you see 24
processes in the
planning process group distributed
across all the ten knowledge areas so
this is about schedule management now i
look at
the cost management project cost
management so when we say cost it is
quite obvious it's all about money what
money the expenditure the outgoing money
so project incurs cost
if any individuals i keep getting these
questions in lot of trainings
so
is checking the revenues the invoice
rising and collection of payment is that
a job of a project manager now when we
say the project management and look at
date as a project management activities
now it's all about delivering the
results of the project so when we say i
need to collect invoices and to submit
invoices collect payments when you say
that so that doesn't mean
it is part of a project management role
no
now if in your organization if you have
a designation of project manager or some
manager or something
and
invoice submission and collection of
payment is also part of your job
description you have to do you don't
have any choice so designation is
totally different when compared with the
meaning of the role called project
manager so any other things which are
associated with your designation in the
organization it may be project manager
also designation possible depending on
what job description what job activities
are associated with it accordingly to do
but when you do a project management
activity in specific when you involve in
the project so all these aspects what
we're defining that needs to be taken
300 percent along with it raising an
invoice collection of payment or
coordinating with some other
department to find out new opportunities
in the existing customer those are all
additional things which are given to you
as an individual with that designation
to justify many things so as a
professionals i have a position in
organization with some designations and
there is a ctc salary which is given and
that needs to be justified to justify
that various different roles are
attached to you for your designation so
that you need to look up to accordingly
and to deal with
now let us come back to project cost
management so it's about expanding money
what we're speaking about
which basically focuses on estimating
and allocation of budget to the project
that is first thing one needs to
estimate approximate what cost it takes
for a project now what are those cost
components so where is that cost
incurred so cost is incurred
to the resources acquired cost is
incurred to the tools cost is incurred
in all that
activity what we do right so everywhere
the one we create result for raw
material what you acquire the people the
technology resource what you occur the
facility what you have so all this
involves money the cost expenditure so
approximation of the cost needs to be
done what it takes to complete this
project
and confirm budget it so this involves
project budgeting so good estimation
tools need to make sure that the funds
are within the need of the project and
stakeholder sponsors are kept informed
so
estimation and budgeting cannot happen
in isolation project manager cannot do a
loan that requires to involve the
experts the divine experts who can
determine how the budget can be
established
how it can change how it can be
controlled what are the regulators needs
to be kept in mind so it considers all
those processes required to do that
all the tasks which are involved like
cost and combining them would determine
project budget so firstly approximation
would happen based on that approximation
then the approximation of that will be
submitted
then the budget is confirmed after
allocation so this needs to be monitored
and controlled throughout the project
life cycle so initially i also mentioned
earlier about triple constraints scope
time and cost so it is very important to
monitor these three critically so for
that there is a technique which is used
which is very popular earned value
management
which speaks about or provides you the
insight towards how the project is
progressing in terms of scope time and
cost
which are basically very important ones
then comes rest of the things quality
resource risk which complements to this
right so project cost management
involves
four processes that is plan cost
management estimate cost determine
budget which are part of planning
process group
and control cost is part of monitoring
and control process group now next uh
knowledge area is
project quality management so when we
say quality it's all about ensuring that
grades are set requirements are clearly
defined and how are you going to ensure
that hindering characteristics what are
defined are accomplished so you need to
have a quality management approach
quality management plan in place now
what quality management i should follow
there are a lot of standards lot of
best practices
so that
is based on the project environment in
which organization are you doing in any
given organization there will be quality
management practices which are followed
an approach that may require to get
reflected in the projects which is being
done in that environment or if project
has a specific requirement that specific
quality management standard or practice
needs to be followed then that needs to
be defined accordingly the quality
management should happen so quality
management is a part of entire project
management plan which speaks about
quality specifications products or
service the artifacts which are used as
part of the project so
when we say quality management approach
we speak about many terms like
acceptance criteria quality criteria
customer quality expectations
then quality assurance quality control
so all these needs to be
kept in mind and brought in place
and this
in execution if you look at there is a
process called manage quality when we
looked at scope schedule and cost there
was no processes defined in execution
but since the accountability of ensuring
quality is with project manager there is
a process now remember all these 49
processes defined in pmp or project
management processes these are not the
processes which are for execution so
these are all project management
processes if any team member is
configuring something creating something
delivering something
none of those activities are defined as
part of these processes
as plan when you make a clear plan like
when i said create wbs where you have
the elements which needs to be delivered
or defined when you putting an
activities into it adding activities
into it that anyway you have a domain
expert to do it accordingly execution
happens by team members but as a project
manager you are not involved in that in
entirety in execution i'm saying so
project quality management will have the
processes like plan quality management
manage quality and control quality so
plan quality management is part of
planning process group manage quality is
part of executing process group whereas
control quality is part of monitoring
and controlling process group so the
next knowledge area to look at is
project resource management so when we
say resource
by default we think about human
resources
so that's how the knowledge area was in
the fifth edition
so it was called as project human
resource management but as the
discussions happened has the realization
happened it is not about just
human resource
many resources involves technology
resources facility resources
so the renaming of that knowledge area
happened in sixth edition as project
resource management so project resource
management focuses on
ensuring identification of those roles
identification of those resources
having a plan in place so that resources
can be managed better so predominantly
when we say resource it's quite obvious
we think about human resources so which
is very very unpredictable kind of
resource whereas when it comes to
technology resource
it is predictable the nature the
behavior the configuration everything is
predictable but only those human
resources are the one which requires a
special treatment
a special approach to engage with them
so this knowledge area helps to identify
roles within the project team as per the
project management team structure
defined so there should be project
management team structure defined and
what needs to be delivered from which
are the roles which also include how
they fit into overall structure of the
project so these team members or
resources need to be acquired if it is
human resources
those needs to be educated an induction
needs to be done about the project and
they need to become fit into the project
so when i say people it's quite obvious
conflict occurs various different
preferences they come across with they
have their own
experience backgrounds and dynamics
associated with them so close monitoring
is required mentoring is required
demonstration of leadership skills are
required
so generally we speak about three main
ways of demonstrating leadership which
involves
authoritarian leadership then lazy fair
leadership
and participative leadership so
authoritarian is also called as
autocratic which means the project
manager will become
hold that authority power with that
power
the project manager demonstrated this is
how it should be makes the decision so
such power demonstration may be required
when something needs to be influenced
strongly and direction is to be set and
decision needs to be made but when it
comes to
participative leadership when some
problems needs to be resolved when
people's involvement is required that
needs to be encouraged that is very
essential reviewing or creating
solutions that approach leadership style
is required but when it comes to lazy
fair delegative approach so
where there are specific domain experts
who will do it so assigned to them and
then monitor review with them that is
delegative approach so these three
leadership styles has to be demonstrated
effectively while doing doing project
resource management
so team will have their own dynamics so
that needs to be understood and
accordingly dealt with
so this knowledge area has
around six processes that is plan
resource management estimate activity
resources acquire resources develop team
manage team and control resources so
plan resource management and estimate
activity resources are part of planning
process group acquire resources develop
team and manage team are part of
executing process group whereas control
resource is part of monitoring and
control process group so next knowledge
area we are going to look at is project
communication management
so when we say project communication
firstly we need to understand what is
this communication is all about
so communication is used to convey
something to someone
so there should be two parties the
communicator and the one who receives it
means sender and receiver so very
important here is when sender sends
certain message
at the receiver's end how it is received
is the meaning what is actually
perceived
by a receiver is same as what is meant
by the communicator means sender so this
will become a big gap if what i told
versus what someone understood if there
is a gap
then the communication is not effective
so it is very essential to understand
this dynamics communication should be
very effective and based on that
communication there is always a
resultant action
so always communication will have two
parties minimum one is sender and
receiver and in the receiver's
perspective one is to understand who
would be the receiver generally when i
say project manager project manager
communicates with sponsor project
manager communicates with team members
project manager communicates with
customers
project manager communicates with other
functions within organization
suppliers or external to the
organization now each of these
communications will have a specific
objective and intention so project
manager should understand that and what
sorts of vocabularies jargons which
needs to be used while communicating the
words
the communication methods which needs to
be used the communication channel
the language the syntax understanding
all of these will become very important
while doing the communication in the
project so project communication
management is the area that informs the
team and stakeholders about the project
so the communication management system
is determined along with how it is done
and how often it is done how frequently
the communication has to be made
so managing communication should also
involve reviewing how effective the
communication is
and how the regularly the modifications
are being done to ensure the
communication is actually fulfilling the
requirements of communication needs
that needs to be discussed regularly and
looked at is that helping so it is very
essential as the stakeholders are
identified their communication
requirement should also identified
and
what communication why is that
communication how often how frequently
the communication has to be made what
channel what template which has to be
used and what language
so all these needs to be understood
signed off
so when you go and inform or sends a
message to the sponsor it will have
specific objective of that communication
similarly when you send it to team
member specific objective here in this
two aspect the frequency will change
the language will change the
stakeholders to whom the communication
is made by changes
and impact it has to create in that
communication will also change
so that needs to be understood the
project manager should be very sensitive
about it so communication management
plays very important role whereas 90
percent of the time project manager will
be spending
his effort and time in communicating if
that is not effective
it is difficult to become successful in
project management
now let us look at the processes in
project communication management
so there are three processes that is
plan communication management
manage communications and monitor
communications
so plan communication management is part
of planning process group
managed communication is part of
executing process group
monitor communication is part of
monitoring and control process groups
the next knowledge area is project risk
management
so when we use the term risk it's all
about an uncertainty what we're speaking
about so every assignment we take up
every initiative we do everything
involves risk
similarly project also involves risk so
risk which is termed as an uncertainty
of certain occurrence
are both positive as well as negative
the positive risk we call it as
opportunities whereas negative risk we
call it as threats so each of this risk
has to be treated certain way so before
you treat or decide on certain treatment
of the risks identified risks needs to
be analyzed so qualitative analysis
quantitative analysis has to be done and
risk responses has to be planned so the
project risk management is the knowledge
area which will identify how the risks
are itemized categorized and prioritized
in the risk register similarly risks are
prioritized and qualitatively and
quantitatively analyzed
so based on their impact on the project
the necessary response plan will be
defined
so risk has to be controlled by
reviewing the risk register regularly
and removing the risk that no longer
impact the project now the risk once
identified mainly risks are identified
some set of risks are already identified
captured in project charter whereas in
detail risks are identified during the
planning
associated with many different aspects
of the project
the risk related to scope schedule time
cost quality
resources maybe procurement stakeholders
so risks are categorized accordingly and
identified now this is not the list
which is made it is not an exhaustive
list which is made in one go
so this acts acts as a basic list as the
project progresses all these identified
risks needs to be evaluated on continual
basis and also new risks needs to be
identified regularly so that what are
the kinds of risks which comes up are
understood and then response plans are
accordingly taken so this helps in
managing the risks effectively and
efficiently
the processes involved in risk
management knowledge area are
plan risk management identify risk
perform qualitative risk analysis
perform quantitative risk analysis and
plan risk response which are part of
planning process group
whereas implement risk response will be
part of executing process group and
monitor risks this will be part of
monitoring and controlled process group
so when we say identify risk this is
when you identify the risk here and
captured in the risk register
and as i mentioned earlier this is not a
list which is exhaustive so at the
moment whatever the risks are being
identified
so these risks are analyzed now as part
of this planning qualitatively as well
as quantitatively
but the analysis of the risk assessing
those risks should continue throughout
the project life cycle
because the impact level of the risk
would vary as it progresses throughout
the project life cycle now
as we have a risk response plans defined
and for some it is already implemented
some you cannot implement you need to
make yourself ready to tackle the
scenario of issues when it occurs when
risk occurs you need to handle those so
have that capability built or having
some contingency plans any of such
actions are taken
and project should be ready means when
risk occurs the impact occurred and i'm
just okay with it that will not work so
project will get impacted it may
escalate the cost it may delay the
project closure many things it will
happen
so proper analysis and then
actions in time
right risk response plans can be
implemented so for
positive risk for opportunities
generally acceptance
or exploit or taking advantage of that
would be the kind of response we will
see
for the negative risk the threats the
kind of responses what we would see is
like avoid
or have a contingency plan or mitigate
the risk in terms of having some
measures implemented
transfer risk is another thought which
is certain so if someone says avoid risk
that behavior is called as risk average
behavior someone who don't even take
risk so
if i take up this i have the risk of so
much so i will not even take up that
such behaviors so those are the kinds of
risk responses may come across which
needs to be implemented as part of
executing process group
then whatever the plan whatever the
implementation which has happened that
needs to be monitored as part of
monitoring and control so next knowledge
area for us is project procurement
management
so when we say procurement so every
project involves procuring something
so a main decision which happens here is
make or buy decision so should i make it
myself should i create
myself within within the organization or
should i
do something or purchase something so
make or buy decision so when i decide i
am going to buy certain things from
outside because we cannot make
everything as part of our organization
because the direction of the business is
totally different
if i am a bank and i am doing an i.t
project i need not go and sit and start
configuring a server
so i need not hire people who configure
and then they come and
sit here and i start managing them so my
entire focus of banking services which i
need to focus on
will go for toss i should not do that so
ensure instead i'll give to an experts
so procurement of an i.t services from
iit service provider i will do so to
giving it to the experts rather than
doing myself which helps me to have that
expertise coming to me so procurement
management involves in identifying those
resources the products or services which
needs to be procured
to use in my project
so that i need not spend time on that so
this involves identification of the
suppliers having those subcontractors
right so they will have an engagement
through a contract and monitoring and
managing them and establishing a
relationship with them and engaging with
them in appropriate way that is required
it is very essential to be done in every
project so that way project procurement
management would guide in terms of
handling all the procurements what we do
from outside external to the
organization so this knowledge area
handles outside procurements like hiring
subcontractors
outside needs of projects are identified
and how much they are determined this
involves a statement of work terms of
reference request for proposal and
choosing a vendor so to do this bidder
conference happens floating request for
proposals can happen request for
quotation can happen
so many such actions are taken and the
processes involved here are three mainly
so plan procurement management which is
part of planning process group
conduct procurement which is part of
executing process group and control
procurement which is part of
monitoring and control process group so
the next knowledge area is project
stakeholder management so when we say
stakeholder who is the stakeholder
stakeholders are internal stakeholders
are external stakeholders are the one
who influence stakeholders impact they
will get impacted they are influenced so
likewise
for every project every initiative
organization takes there are
stakeholders for me for my project i
need to identify all the stakeholders
so now identification of stakeholder
engaging with stakeholder managing the
stakeholders will become very essential
so as part of this knowledge area
after identification of stakeholders the
need of stakeholders needs to be
understood so not every stakeholders are
identified will have very close
to the project they are not in very
close proximity to the project the
distance of the stakeholder from the
project may be far
still they may have an impacted because
of this we need to understand that if i
am building a
flyover construction of flyover is
happening obviously people living in the
region will get impacted but they have
no direct involvement in the project
however their cooperation is required so
likewise as as we identify the
stakeholders we need to understand
what kind of impact or influence that
stakeholder will have
on them or on the project from them this
needs to be analyzed so stakeholders
needs to be identified their concerns
need to be identified and must be
managed some stakeholders would come up
with certain powers authorities so we
need to understand that as well
so each of the stakeholders needs to be
listed out their concerns prioritize
based on their impact on the project
then the stakeholders need to be engaged
and determine if their needs are being
addressed if not what can be done to
rectify those if at all any issues exist
so various stakeholder state also can
exist there is a stakeholder who should
be very supportive in the project
actively involved in the project but the
stakeholder may be in an aware state so
we may require to engage with a
stakeholder
bring that
clarity explain and then
ensure that stakeholder is supportive to
the project some stakeholders may be
resistive some stakeholder may be
neutral some stakeholder would be very
supportive
unaware so various different state of
stakeholders would exist but one needs
to analyze what kind of state that
stakeholder should be
in this project that needs to be
discussed understood and then decide
so accordingly engagement should happen
so stakeholder engagement plan needs to
be defined very clearly so now here we
have four processes so one process in
initiating process group that is
identify stakeholder
then plan stakeholder engagement which
happens in planning
manage stakeholder engagement which is
executing process group and monitor
stakeholder engagement is
monitoring and control process group as
i mentioned in risk management in
stakeholder management also
identification of stakeholder analyzing
the way stakeholder engagement should
happen and deciding that engagement this
is very dynamic which has to happen
throughout the project life cycle and
this is not one time register what we
create like stakeholder register if you
create it is not one time register it is
dynamic which gets updated throughout
the lifecycle of the project and today
we will learn about pmp certification
before we begin let's have a look at an
incident where two project managers jon
and ted are talking to each other jon is
a senior project manager while ted is a
part of his team jon finds ted to be
upset so he asks him is there anything
he can help him with to which ted
replies that his project failed jon
further asks him what could be the
possible reason for the project failure
ted tells him that it's because he was
not able to manage the time and budget
now jon asks him if he is pmp certified
to which ted says he isn't then jon
suggested that he must take the pmp
certification which will not only give
his project better performance but also
help him upskill in his career so today
we will discuss about pmp certification
in detail let's first have a look at all
the topics we will cover we will begin
with what is pmp then we will check top
10 reasons to get pmp certified followed
by the basics of pmp then after we know
the pmp basic concepts we will check who
can get the certification and pattern
for the pmp exam then we will learn
about the pmbok guide which is an
integral part to prepare for the pmp
exam finally we will see the cost and
the validity of the certification so
without any further ado let's begin with
what is pmp pmp or project management
professional is the world's most
renowned project management
certification for project managers this
certification is provided by the project
management institute now when we know
what is project management professional
or pmp certification let's have a look
at some reasons why you should get pmp
certified today i will give you top 10
reasons to take pmp certification pmp
certification helps you become a better
project manager the process that helps
us acquire the certification goes to
several phases like gaining project
management experience and passing the
pmp exam which helps you in bringing
sanity to the project manager the
process helps project managers to learn
different industry trends have practical
knowledge and several other project
management constraints the second reason
that we have is project management
certification makes our resume more
valuable as we have discussed earlier
that pmp certification is the most
renowned project management
certification so having it on the resume
will definitely help the interviewer
recognize our skills there are companies
that only accept project managers who
are pmp certified pmp certification not
only helps in switching the job or
finding a new one it helps in
progressing in the current company as
well the third reason that we have is it
provides more job opportunities when one
acquires the pmp certification it proves
that one has expertise in completing the
project effectively and efficiently so
the certification increases the trust
factor of the interviewer in you and
increases your probability of getting
that job the fourth reason that we have
is salary hikes pmp certified project
manager is one of the highest paid jobs
around the globe and this trend will
continue to grow the global survey by
the project management institute shows
that pmp certified project managers tend
to get 20 percent more salary than the
non-certified project managers the next
reason that we have is pmp certification
validates your dedication to the job the
certification requires several months of
training it requires several hours of
project management experience and
exposure this experience and exposure
explains the seriousness of a project
manager towards its career path then
sixth we have is pmp certification is
globally acknowledged pmp certification
is the most renowned certification all
over the world it helps project managers
to be a part of different types of
industries all over the globe pmp
certification is the most renowned
certification all over the world project
managers who are pmp certified may get
jobs in different types of industries
all over the world pmp certification not
only provides theoretical knowledge but
also helps in gaining practical
knowledge which further helps in
increasing the confidence of a project
manager the next reason that we have is
better project performance pmp certified
project managers tend to deliver better
projects than the non-pmp certified
project managers this is because pmp
certified project managers are well
aware of 5 process groups 10 knowledge
areas and 49 processors which helps them
have a clear picture of different
aspects involved in a project the eighth
reason that we have is it increases your
networking opportunities there are
several communities that one becomes a
part of when they sign up as a pmi
member these communities have meetings
regarding new job opportunities and this
helps in having a professional network
the ninth reason that we have is job
security job security is a major reason
that a professional thinks off before
opting for a particular profession today
in the world of recession where
companies are drowning the demand for
pmp certified project managers goes on
increasing the last and the 10th reason
we have is expertise in practical
application when one appears for a pmp
exam they need extensive preparation
they need to have thorough knowledge of
process groups and knowledge areas which
help them develop several essential
skills and move ahead in their career
now as we move further we will look into
the pmp basic concepts the pmp basic
concepts are the five project management
steps these project management steps
start from the day we begin our project
to the day we end our project they begin
from initiation to closure the first
step that we have is initiation planning
execution monitoring and controlling and
closure now let's have a look at each of
them in detail the first step we have is
initiation initiation involves defining
the project scope this is the step where
we explain what our project will have
for whom we are making that project it
helps us to identify our stakeholders
who all will be the part of that project
and determine the project feasibility
after this step of initiation when we
have decided the scope of our project
the second step that comes is planning
in the planning phase we define a flow
to all the activities of a project we
define this flow keeping in mind all the
constraints of a project like time
resources and risk after we have defined
the flow of these processes it is time
for us to look at the execution in the
execution phase we evaluate the plan and
the sequence of the tasks we have made
we finally put the plan in action and
the project tends to start after the
project building has started and the
process of execution has started it is
time for the monitoring and the
controlling phase in monitoring and
controlling phase the progress of the
project is tracked and important steps
for quality assurance are taken in
monitoring and controlling phase the
work being done is compared with the
work as defined in the project plan in
this phase the progress of the project
is tracked and important steps for
quality assurance are taken finally we
have the closure step in this step the
deliverables are delivered to the client
the documentation of all that took place
during the project lifecycle is done and
project is fully evaluated now when we
have seen reasons for getting pmp
certified and we know the basic concepts
of pmp it is time for us to know who can
get pmp certified for getting pmp
certified there can be two cases the
first case says you must have a
secondary degree a secondary degree
means high school diploma or an
associate degree or a degree that is
globally equivalent to all of these then
you need to have 7 500 hours of leading
and directing projects and 3 500 hours
of project management education there
can be two cases first case can be you
must have a secondary degree that means
a high school diploma associates degree
or the global equivalent degree then you
must have 7 500 hours of project
management experience and 35 hours of
education in project management the
second case can be you must have a
four-year degree along with 4 500 hours
of project management experience and 35
hours of education in project management
now when we know who can get pmp
certified we will see the pmp exam
pattern the exam comprises of 200
questions out of which 175 questions are
used for evaluation one can answer these
questions if they have thorough
knowledge of five process groups and ten
knowledge areas the time provided to
complete the exam is four hours the
questions that are asked are of
different types the most common type
being formula based situation based and
knowledge based now when we have
discussed about the exam pattern
discussing about the pmbok guide becomes
very important so the next topic that we
have is pmbok guide pmbok guide or
project management body of knowledge is
a book that comprises of several
processes and different terminologies
needed to crack the pmp exam the whole
syllabus of pmp exam is covered in the
pmbok guide by the project management
and 10 knowledge areas apart from this
there are 49 processes that are divided
amongst 5 process groups 10 knowledge
areas finally let's have a look at the
cost and validity of the pmp
certification when we talk about the
cost of the certification there can be
two cases the first case can be if we
are not a member of project management
institute the exam fees is 555 us
dollars the second case can be if we are
a member of project management institute
the exam fees is 405 us dollars if we
talk about the validity of the
certification a certificate is valid for
a period of three years after every
three years the certificate needs to be
renewed to renew the certificate one
needs to furnish a proof of 60 pdus or
professional development units after so
much information that thanks john for
his time and promises to take the pmp
certification at the shortest notice now
let's have a look at the salary trends
of a pmp certified project manager and a
sample resume if we consider the salary
of a non-pmp certified project manager
it is approximately ninety one thousand
dollars while if we consider the salary
of a pmp certified project manager it is
approximately one hundred eleven
thousand dollars which is approximately
twenty percent higher than the
non-certified project managers salary
now let's have a look at the resume of a
pmp certified project manager if you are
somebody with pmp certification and
looking for a project manager or a
senior project manager role your resume
should look something like this the
summary in the beginning would include
how much experience you have and
anything that supports your claim of
being a project manager like here james
brown has written he has more than 10
years of experience with generating and
building projects then when you talk
about your experience you should put
something that emphasizes on the
responsibilities that you had your area
of expertise put something that shows
your skill set for the desired post and
also something that you learn from your
former job role this shows that you have
command over your work and also the
determination to skill and upskill
yourself like here james brown has three
years of experience as an assistant
manager training new associates and then
more than three years of experience as a
project manager where he not only led
projects but also learned new project
management tools like trello and
primavera after this add relevant
information regarding your education
your resume must include skills that you
have or you have gained in your years of
experience like here james brown has
divided his skills into two parts where
he has written his technical skills and
non-technical skills he has included a
skill of agile and quality assurance
software as well as he has his knowledge
of different project management tools
then putting your certifications play a
major role this proves that you are up
to date and updated with current market
trends james brown has his
certifications in c and java and more
importantly he has his project
management certification project
management professional in this session
we will discuss about project manager
roles and responsibilities let's first
have a look at all the topics we will be
covering today first we will see who is
a project manager then we will check the
roles and responsibilities of a project
manager moving forward we will analyze
the salary of a project manager and the
steps that will help us become a project
manager finally we will see a project
manager's resume so without any further
ado let's get started with who is a
project manager project manager in
simple words is a professional who
manages the project project manager
plays an integral role from the first
phase of the project life cycle to the
last phase of project life cycle this
individual is a part of all the
activities that produce the final
deliverables and strive towards the
success of the project now let's
consider some must have skills of a
project manager first we have is strong
communication skills the communication
skills help the project manager to
communicate the organization's mission
and vision to the team members in a
clear concise manner these communication
skills help project manager to explain
their thoughts and requirements to
customers and stakeholders the next we
have is effective leadership skills that
helps in forming a team of skilled
professionals and lead them in the best
possible manner the next skill that a
project manager must have is a team
management skill as a project manager it
is very important to know how to manage
your team to achieve a common goal with
complete harmony a project manager must
have strong negotiation skills as
project managers have to negotiate at
each and every step this negotiation
might be with the customers stakeholders
or team members these negotiation skills
become of utmost importance when project
members get into a fight or an argument
then we have critical thinking this is
what makes a project manager more
effective and efficient in project
management this thinking capability is
needed to take difficult steps talk to
stakeholders and resolve several issues
throughout the course of the project the
last skill that a project manager must
have is risk management skill handling a
project is an important step but what is
equally important is risk management
this is the process required to identify
analyze and respond to the risk factors
throughout the project life cycle now
when we know who a project manager is we
must have a look at the roles and
responsibilities of a project manager
the first and foremost role of a project
manager is to set up a project scope
check its feasibility and determine the
resources that are needed to satisfy the
project scope second role that a project
manager has is the development of a
project plan according to the project
scope the plan is needed to encourage
the team to hard work with all their
dedication next a project manager is
supposed to set deadlines for the
project deliverables he or she is
supposed to manage time as a priority
and communicate with the team at regular
intervals next important role is to
analyze track and control the budget of
the project project manager has to make
sure that the project does not run out
of budget and is optimized as possible
moving forth effective communication is
one of the most important skill of a
project manager he she is supposed to
maintain communication with all the
stakeholders throughout the project then
we have is the identification and
evaluation of risk in a project project
manager must take steps to minimize the
effect of risk in a project the next
role of a project manager is to track
and control the performance of the team
this helps in yielding the best outputs
with the least number of resources last
role a project manager must have is to
provide reports and documentation of all
the steps involved in project management
this helps in future projects and makes
sure that the mistakes that happened in
the project will not happen again in
ongoing projects now it's time for us to
check the salary of a project manager
the data shows that an average salary of
a project manager in india is
approximately 14 lakh rupees per annum
while the average salary of a project
manager in united states is 83
215 dollars per year the next important
thing we must learn is how can we get a
project manager's job there are four
important steps that one must fulfill to
become a project manager the first step
is to have a bachelor's degree it is
important for a person to be a graduate
one can hold a bachelor's degree in any
area of interest like marketing computer
science or even engineering this
entirely depends on the type of project
manager one wants to be the second
important step is gaining project
management experience this means that a
person must have experience in leading
and directing projects project
management experience helps in taking
different project management
certifications which further help in
having a good paying job the third
essential step is to learn project
management tools there are different
project management tools for different
area of interest these tools help in
quick and efficient management of work
project management tools are used widely
by organizations now learning these
tools will increase the chances of
getting selected in one of those
organizations the fourth and the last
step is getting project management
certified project management
certifications help an individual to
increase the value of their
certification and validates their
dedication to the job nowadays several
organizations have made it compulsory
for a project manager to be project
management certified there may be
several project management
certifications out of which project
management professional certification or
pmp certification is one of the most
common and widely accepted
certifications the project management
institute or the pmi predicts that there
will be 22 million new project
management jobs by the year 2027 now
it's time for us to know how a resume of
an aspiring project manager looks like
if you are somebody looking for a
project manager role or a senior project
manager role then your resume should
look something like this the summary in
the beginning would include how much
experience you have and anything that
supports your claim of being a project
manager like here james brown has
written he has more than 10 years of
experience with generating and building
projects then when you talk about your
experience you should put something that
emphasizes on the responsibilities that
you had in your area of expertise put
something that shows your skill set for
the desired post and also something that
you learn from your former job role this
shows that you have command over your
work and also the determination to
upskill yourself like here james brown
has three years of experience as an
assistant manager where he trained new
associates and then three years of
experience as a project manager where he
not only led projects but also learned
new project management tools like trello
and primavera after this add relevant
information regarding your education
your resume must include skills that you
have or you have gained in your years of
experience like here james brown has
divided his skills in two parts where he
has written his technical skills and
non-technical skills he has included his
skill of agile and quality assurance
software as well as he has his knowledge
of different project management tools
like trello and primavera then putting
your certifications play a major role
this proves that you are up to date and
updated with current market trends james
brown has a certifications in c and java
and more importantly he has his project
management certification in project
management professional or pmb here as
part of this video we are going to look
at few possible questions which one
would face while going through an
interview this will help them to prepare
for interview and also help to
understand what kind of questions would
come across when they face the interview
in addition to that
these questions also has an insight
towards the role of project management
itself
so let us look at one by one
question number one how do you define a
project
so as per the pmis pmbok sixth edition a
project is a temporary endower
undertaken to create a unique product
service or results
the temporary nature of projects
indicates that a project has a definite
beginning and end so when we say this
temporary end over undertaken to create
a unique product service or results each
project will have a definite start date
and end date
once the project team is formed once the
project objectives are achieved so the
team which is formed the human resources
which are onboarded to a project so
those are disseminated sent back to
their respective functions or
departments and project will be
concluded as complete
so project can be simple or complex and
may be managed by a single person or a
group of them so every project will have
a life cycle so from beginning to end
it starts and end where it acquires lot
of resources where it will divide the
project life cycle into multiple stages
or phases where project is being done
and deliverables will happen through the
milestones during that life cycle
so projects are often broken into small
tasks to utilize teams trends and
increase productivity
question number two
what is a project charter
so project charter is a short document
that explains the entire project so this
will become a basic document which will
be given to a project manager so that a
project manager can understand what is a
project management is all about
so this document would include the
objectives of the project
how will they be carried out who are the
stakeholders
identification of risks advantages of
the project and the budget so project
charter plays an integral while planning
the project as a plan is something that
is used in all the phases of project
life cycle
it is very essential because it provides
all the necessary insights a project
manager is needed while taking up the
project
after getting the project charter the
first job a project manager supposed to
do is to identify the stakeholders even
though project charter will have a basic
list of stakeholders so project manager
has to contact those stakeholders
establish the list of stakeholders for
the project understand the requirements
in detail and further move towards
planning
what is meant by scope of the project
so project scope is most essential part
of project planning that helps in
determining the list of specific project
goals or deliverables so when we say
this
project will have a definite unique
deliverable which has to be created so
this will have a specific description of
the specification as well as the
features functionalities of the
deliverable
so to accomplish that features
functionality of that output what we are
going to create as a result of a project
within a project lot of activities are
done the processes the tools the
resources which are utilized for the
project all falls under this scope
so when we say the term scope it is very
important for us to understand the scope
of a project versus scope of the product
the scope of the project involves all
those processes resources and activities
what we do to accomplish the result
whereas product scope is the one which
we speak about the result itself the
features functionalities of that result
itself so one needs to understand the
difference between this project scope
and product scope and define accordingly
so this will help in identification of
the project's output
and why that output is created and how
these particular product or services or
results will help organization or
business to accomplish their objectives
this should be the basic understanding a
project manager should have
so it includes everything that is to be
achieved by the project which means all
those results what needs to be achieved
all those value which has to be created
by the results so we need to keep in
mind the result itself is not the
ultimate objective of an organization it
is not instead the result will help
organization to accomplish their
objectives for example if you take in hr
department if they introduce an intranet
portal for claim processing
so the application what is created as
part of the exercise of initiative where
my employees should submit their claims
through a specific portal now that is to
reduce the time the processing
duration as well as the efficiency and
effectiveness of the processed claim
what is submitted
so this is an outcome
so keeping that outcome the objective
this portal is created that portal
itself has the features and
functionalities which project will focus
and create that results so through that
result organization would accomplish
their objectives that should be kept in
mind
so
understanding the scope is essential so
while understanding the scope also need
to understand how this particular output
the product results is going to add
value to the business what is the
outcome of that that is also very
important to understand one is
understanding the scope ensuring the
project is delivered within that scope
and all that required to be done to
accomplish that scope has to be done and
only that
not anything more than that not anything
lesser than that
what is project life cycle
as i was mentioning during the question
three there is a project scope
so project itself has a life cycle
so this project scope falls under this
project life cycle so project life cycle
refers to
the beginning and end of the project so
there is a life so you initiate a
project trigger a project project is
actually started and as it starts it
progresses creating the results and then
it ends
project can end in various different
scenarios one is by accomplishing the
objective of the project the ultimate
results the deliverable it creates and
then ends our project may also get
closed prematurely so we are not going
to look at the why the project is going
to close prematurely at the moment
our idea is to understand what is
project life cycle and to visualize that
so this entire span of time the project
spends from the beginning to end it
involves various different stages or
phases whatever the term you want to
call it and in each of these
stages or phases there is a milestone
deliverables which are measured and that
will be part of the ultimate deliverable
what is going to be delivered as a
result of a project
so it involves
all the activities all the processes all
the resources which needs to be acquired
managed and then the results needs to be
accomplished ultimately
so
here in the project life cycle
it involves five process groups which
mainly focuses on different different
activities and dynamics of the project
which we call it as an initiation
process group
planning process group execution process
group
monitoring and controlling process group
and closure process group
so during initiation process group the
creation of a project charter
appointment of the project manager and
identification of this key stakeholder
will be done
this can be initiation of the project as
a whole or as a part of a specific stage
or a phase
now all this process group what i
mentioned initiation planning execution
monitoring closure all of these process
groups can be looked at their
involvement in the entire project life
cycle at the same time it can also be
seen as part of a single phase
so each of the process groups are
applicable like initiation of a project
if i say similarly initiation of a stage
or a phase
so the planning process group involves
the process of creating the plan for
achieving the project's objectives so
this would create the detailed plan for
entire project or a skeleton plan for a
project if it is a agile or rolling wave
project if that approach is taken like
rolling wave or progressive elaboration
or agile approaches then the skeleton of
the project plan is created if waterfall
approach is taken it's quite obvious the
comprehensive the detail project plan
will be created project management plan
is also involved in this
now in addition to this as you progress
in the project for each stage or a phase
there needs to be a plan which is
detailed further compared to the project
plan itself which will become ultimately
part of big plan of a project
the execution process groups involves
the project management processes for
identification allocation and management
of resources
required for executing the project
deliverables
so here the actual execution happens
being a project manager the focus should
be on managing the project so many a
time i have seen project manager is
going and doing tasks looking at the
task level transaction level
which was not project management thought
so one needs to ensure
the project management is not about
deliverables in terms of doing the tasks
it's about getting the deliverables from
the team
so active involvement in terms of
acquiring the resources checking whether
the accomplishment of results has
happened needs to be done throughout the
project life cycle so it's all about
directing and managed project works and
at the same time managing the knowledge
which is acquired during the project
life cycle
the monitoring and controlling process
groups involves the process for project
manager to monitoring and controlling
the project
now this involves reviewing this
involves creation of reports this
involves concluding yes project has
delivered or not delivered
identification of the deviations and
initiating with the change request for
necessary corrections so monitoring and
control will be done throughout the
project life cycle and only with an
effective monitoring and control we can
see the success in a project
so the closure process group involves
the process which is required for
formally closing the project where
everything including what went wrong and
what went right all through the project
is summed up
so here especially in the closing
process group
we will not focus on acceptance of the
deliverable instead we'll focus on sign
off capturing lessons learned all the
formalities which needs to be completed
as part of a closure
then where are we going to accept the
deliverables this happens in monitoring
and controlling so while doing the
monitoring and controlling we will
validate validate against what is
planned comparing with what is being
delivered so when you compare both one
would understand what is delivered
versus what actually was planned
so their acceptance happens once the
acceptance happens there only then the
project moves towards closure project or
phase either of that so when we say
closure process group it involves the
process for a closure of that face
whether accomplishment of all the
objectives all the deliverables of the
phase is done or not is checked if it is
a phase
if it is a project in the project
perspective if everything is complete is
checked and then it moves to closing
process group
where the lessons learnt the formal sign
off everything will run as part of this
closing process group
what is the importance of process groups
so process groups are set of processes
that are applicable to various stages of
the project as i mentioned earlier each
of the processes has a defined set of
inputs
and produced defined outputs by applying
a set of tools and techniques on the
input
the initiation process groups involves
the processes needed to initiate the
project that is develop project charter
and identify stakeholders the two
processes the project charter will be
handed over to the project manager and
formal declaration of appointment of the
project manager will be done further
project manager has to identify the key
stakeholders and take forward the
project as per the direction set in the
project charter so
in this group in this process group
initiation process group it is a formal
declaration of appointment of project
manager to the project but one needs to
remember should not get confused in real
time we see an individual who is about
to become a project manager for a
project sits and create a project
charter we have seen that in reality
so does it mean that what is told here
is wrong compared to what is practiced
that is not the idea many organization
thinks if we involve the project manager
to be project manager of a project while
creating the project charter itself the
level of information the detail that
person will have about a project will be
more compared to a person we will become
a project manager after ending over the
project charter so there is a difference
the person takes the project charter and
become aware of the project that is one
scenario the person actively involved in
creating a project charter and then
become a project manager that is better
scenario where the person will be more
informed but ultimately the
accountability of a project charter lies
with the sponsor
formal declaration of appointment of
project manager confirmation of that
happens only when project charter is
approved and handed over to the person
who is to be project manager so that's
where actual initiation of project
happens
then project manager can move out and
start identifying the stakeholders and
start collecting the details of the
stakeholders the requirements and
stakeholders cannot give all the
requirements comes coming to their mind
they need to restrict to those project
detailing what needs to be provided the
planning process group defines the
detail plan of the project which
involves the planning for scope time
cost quality resource risk procurement
stakeholders communication
and integration of all these subsidiary
plans each of this plan like scope
management plan schedule management plan
cost management plan quality management
plan resource management plan risk
management plan procurement management
plan stakeholder engagement plan
communication management plan so all
these plans are called as subsidiary
plans so all these plans are integrated
and detailed project management plan
will be created so this involves various
tools and techniques like expert
judgment meetings analogous estimation
parametric estimation decomposition part
critical path method
depending on the specific area which has
been focused on while planning for
example expert judgment is a common
technique used across all the areas like
scope time cost quality all of these
nine areas knowledge areas which i was
mentioning expert judgment meetings are
mostly seen as a technique used during
each of these planning whereas when it
comes to critical path method
so critical path method is about
scheduling so we will see the technique
only in mostly schedule management
similarly if i speak about decomposition
we see that in scope management so
likewise there are specific techniques
which are specific to a specific
knowledge areas which we need to
identify as we go through the entire
framework itself
similarly there are common techniques
used across the knowledge areas which if
you can identify that common techniques
which are used across knowledge areas it
is easy for us to remember and recall
those similarly specific techniques for
a specific knowledge area
the execution process group involves the
processes to direct and manage the
project works the active involvement of
the members of the team is seen
performing their tasks to execute the
project works although the project plan
is finalized there may be changes in
requirements that come from the
stakeholders which are considered for
further modifications so actual
involvement of team delivering something
acquiring the team
onboarding the team
onboarding the supplier
identification of them doing the bidder
conference
engaging with stakeholders
all this action should happen so because
the main focus of execution process
group in project management perspective
is directing and managing project work
and managing the project knowledge which
is very very important
the monitoring and controlling process
group refers to tracking and reviewing
the progress and performance of the
project the process of monitoring and
controlling is continually performed
throughout the project lifecycle
so here i think as i mentioned earlier
as well so it is very essential for us
to understand whether project has
delivered all those required
deliverables or not
are the deliverables are fulfilling all
the features and functionality which are
defined during the planning that
validation should happen any deviations
are found change requests arised and
these change requests are approved once
it is approved then it comes to
integrated change control process
through which changes are executed then
the closing process group involves
assembling a report of all procedures
throughout the project life cycle the
closing process group marks the formal
closure of the project and completion of
its deliverables
now let us move to the next question
so question number six name 10 knowledge
areas as mentioned in the pmbok
so the 10 knowledge areas are project
integration management project scope
management project schedule management
project cost management project quality
management project resource management
project communications management
project risk management project
procurement management and project
stakeholder management the project
integration management basically focuses
on unification and integration of all
the project to manage it in an
integrated way a project manager is also
called as an integrator which means a
project manager should have a end-to-end
visibility of the project so all the
rest of the nine knowledge areas the
plan which is created as part of all the
next nine knowledge areas
those are consolidated and a
comprehensive project management plan
will be created in project integration
management so this is the only knowledge
area where we see the processes in all
the process groups whereas in the rest
of the knowledge areas if you see we
don't see any processes in initiating
process group except stakeholder
management
so integration management has one
process similarly stakeholder management
has one process in initiation process
group similarly in closing process group
only integration management has a
process no other knowledge areas has any
processes
so this is the only knowledge area where
we find processes in all the process
groups which means it is very important
to look at a project in an end-to-end
view perspective a full view of a
project should be known to the project
management only the project manager can
become successful in doing the project
management the next knowledge area
project scope management which focuses
on ensuring collecting requirements
defining scope creating work breakdown
structures
and scope baseline so scope management
focuses on ensuring the necessary scope
is defined and provided so that during
execution projects are delivered
accordingly and monitoring controlling
of the scope the validation of the scope
will be based on what is defined in the
planning what is planned as part of
scope management
similar to scope management in schedule
management once that work breakdown
structure is created it is very
essential to understand what it takes in
terms of efforts what it takes in terms
of duration and in what sequence project
deliverables are completed
in what sequence activities are done so
schedule management focuses on that the
critical the important technique what we
use when it comes to schedule management
is critical path method so in a given
project when we establish a network
diagram so we may see multiple paths
from beginning to end of the project so
some paths will be the longest path
which is called as critical path and
that will be the minimum time which is
required to complete the project so
schedule management plan provides us a
detailed schedule of a project along
with sequencing and duration and at the
same time that is considered as a
scheduled baseline
then the cost management so when we say
cost it is very essential for us to
understand it is an outgoing money
outgoing monetary value so projects
incurs cost when i say project incurs
cost there needs an investment from the
organization who is actually doing this
project
so the cost needs to be assessed means
an approximation of the cost needs to be
done a budget has to be allocated to the
project and within that budget the
project needs to be completed it cannot
go beyond that so budget is established
allocation of budget and confirmation of
budget happens and cost perspective
monitoring of the project happens based
on what is that specific budget it has
within that project has to done that
will become a baseline cost based line
so to measure the cost and schedule a
technique called earned value management
is used well the terminology like cost
performance index scheduled performance
index actual cost earned value planned
value budgeted completion estimate to
complete
so these are the terminologies which are
used as part of earned value management
now let us move to quality management
project quality management
so it is very essential for us to ensure
all the processes all the activities all
the templates defined for the project
are complied with that is first thing
while doing the project during the
project life cycle similarly the
deliverables which comes out of a
project at the end of the project or at
the end of the specific phase or
specific stage or specific milestone so
those deliverables should be according
to the specifications defined and agreed
upon so quality management focuses on
establishing that quality management
approach so that project compliance is
maintained at the same time the results
what is delivered is as per the
specification what is agreed the
resource management focuses on ensuring
all the resources which are required for
the project are acquired configured
installed if it is a technology
resources if it is a human resources the
necessary induction of the project the
brainstorming required for team to
understand what is the project is all
about is given and the necessary skills
and capabilities are there with those
human resources and these team members
execute the task of the project so
project resource management plays very
important role
and now here when we say scope when we
say schedule when we say cost when we
quality in each of this in other
knowledge areas as well
the involvement of each of these
resources are essential so what
resources gets into scope management
what resources gets into schedule
management what into cost likewise for
each of the knowledge areas we see
various different resources used when i
say in schedule management effort has to
be established while we establish an
effort it is also required to understand
what is the skills and capabilities
required so schedule management
definitely work very close with resource
management similarly this each of this
resource comes with cost so obviously
cost management is involved then quality
yes so who is going to do the quality
management so roles and responsibilities
needs to be clearly articulated defined
if it is a human resource in resource
management coming to communication
management so communication i think
plays very important role as we know
90 percent of the time project manager
spends on communications
many times we see project managers like
look only communicating many team
members have told me mentioning that
project manager only does communication
project manager only ask questions
now this impression to the team gets
created because they only see what
project manager is doing is
communication because team comes in when
everything is done everything is set
right so that they see project manager
during the monitoring and control mainly
not during initiation not during
planning not during closure so many team
member comes and goes during the project
they only see project managers reviewing
and asking the questions so because of
this they assume project manager only
communicates project manager only ask
questions but it is very important to
ask questions but there is a perspective
and objective behind it which already
project manager is involved and created
like a plan like signing off
coordinating with stakeholders
understanding requirements many things
has done in all these areas
communication is involved so it plays
very vital role so then project risk
management every initiatives
organizations takes every investment
organization does there is a risk
so already the identified risks are
evaluated and project is taken up by the
organization which means the business
has already understood what is the risk
associated with this particular project
considering that they have taken up a
project but while doing this project
while doing the project management lot
of risk comes across project manager
should keep identifying the risk
assessing the risk analyzing the risks
qualitatively and quantitatively
depending on the level of impact of the
risk so risk means we already know it is
uncertainty of certain occurrence an
outcome it may be positive or negative
positive you can take advantage of that
you exploit it you enhance it whereas
negative risk you mitigate you respond
you will have response plans like
accepting those
or transferring it sharing it
transferring means you outsource or you
take an insurance so that is negative
risk responses next the project
procurement management the projects
would involve certain procurement so we
need to ensure for this project what is
that i am creating myself and using it
what is that i am going to procure from
external suppliers so whichever we
decided in make or buy decisions
whichever we have decided that we need
to procure from elsewhere
so procurement management plays a very
important role here so identification of
what needs to be procured what quantity
we need to procure who would be the best
supplier what are the criterias while
selecting the suppliers you may float an
rfp a proposal request will be respond
which will come in you may float a bit
when you evaluate the best vendor or
supplier you on board them then you
start issuing a po formally for them to
supply and then procurement happens so
end to end management of the supplier
right from overloading the suppliers
doing the bidder conference establishing
an agreement and then engaging with them
for reviewing their performance all
these are involved as part of
procurement management the 10th
knowledge area the project stakeholder
management so stakeholder means any
entity or individual who involves in the
project directly or indirectly they are
impacted they influence the project and
they get influenced so very importantly
if you think about the stakeholders we
can think about customers we can think
about sponsor we can think about team
members suppliers who plays very vital
role in the success of the project so
engaging with the stakeholders managing
the stakeholders plays very important
roles and if every nine knowledge areas
there is something which are done right
but something wrong done with the
stakeholder management entire project
may go for toss so one needs to be very
careful understanding the dynamics
associated with each of these 10
knowledge areas and then dealt with them
accordingly and integration management
would integrate all of this as i
mentioned earlier so that end-to-end
visibility of the project can be seen so
that is about 10 knowledge areas
mentioned in pmbok
the next question question number seven
why is the project planning considered
as the most significant step in project
lifecycle the project planning is more
significant this will provide all the
baseline plans like as we saw in the
previous question
scope baseline cost baseline schedule
baseline so all the baselines required
which will be referred right each of the
baselines are considered based on these
baselines project needs to be executed
now many deviations to this baseline
plans need to have a formal approval for
necessary corrections so already we know
there are nine types of subsidiary plans
for all the nine knowledge areas scope
schedule cost quality resource risk
procurement communication and
stakeholder these are the nine knowledge
areas which will have a subsidiary plans
which will get integrated in integration
management so without having a clear
plan clear directions so execution will
not have any specific direction to take
so you cannot measure the deliverables
so what to do when to do
who will do all these are defined as
part of the planning and that plays a
very important thing so if you look at
the entire framework of pmp most of the
processes out of 49 processes we can see
in planning process group almost like 24
processes out of 49 50 percent of the
processes almost can be seen in planning
process group which itself indicates how
important the planning process group and
planning activity for a project
so why the project plan is considered
most significant let us look at few more
points so one is it provides visibility
in terms of what project is all about
what is that we are going to deliver and
what kind of results are we going to
create what is that we are aiming for we
get a better visibility so next
increases employee satisfaction because
there is no confusion each team member
understand what needs to be delivered
and what is that performance of the team
members how it is measured is also
visible and that is happening in reality
because you cannot deviate on what is
being planned so that should happen in
actual execution as well so obviously
employees are not confused now the team
members are not confused they are
delivering it according to what is
planned and it is easy for them also
because it is a better visibility
and they have a clarity about it
next is quality assurance and control
so as we know quality management is one
of the knowledge areas so doing timely
audits testing all the deliverables
compliance checks so all these ensures
the approach what we are selected
covering all of this ensures the project
is delivered as we planned then reduces
project risk because all the risks are
identified we have understood what are
the risks are and we keep identifying
the risk and analyzing those and when we
see risk there is one unique nature of
risk where exactly the risk occurs
accordingly the impact to the projects
will be there for example when i start a
project if there is a risk associated
with human resources which i am not even
on board non-availability of a specific
resource very less impact but when i am
on board a resource and then project
execution is happening and execution is
at peak
now what happens
it is quite obvious
risk impact will be higher compared to
the risk which would have occurred in
the beginning of the project so meaning
as we progress in the life cycle of a
project the identified risk will have an
impact differently at the different
parts of the life cycle depending on the
nature of the risk and state of the
project so since it is visible to us we
have a risk management knowledge area
which emphasizes on doing all of this so
since we are doing it it will become
visible for us to have effective risk
management so next question
when is stakeholder analysis performed
already we know stakeholder means an
entity or individuals who involve
directly or indirectly who get
influenced will get impacted are all
called as stakeholders understanding who
are those stakeholders who are basically
straight in terms of having impact or
impacted so we need to identify them and
manage them we may have a stakeholder
like competition to our organization but
do we really manage them not required we
might require to be sensitive what
competition is doing is this project is
unique so that the details of this
project the
information on about this project is not
leak to the competition is not shared
with competition in that sensitivity you
need to ensure monitoring it you need
not manage the competition here but you
need to monitor what is happening
relating to competition similarly
stakeholder like team member so you are
required to manage them you cannot just
keep monitoring you need to manage them
so that they can be the results which is
required to be created has created
now next is customer if you say you need
to engage with them you need to discuss
with them you need to review with them
that customer is getting what customers
ask for
right so stakeholder may be anyone who
is affected because of project
stakeholder analysis plays an important
role to identify and analyze their needs
right so the analysis is generally
performed whenever there is a need of
any clarifications over quantitative and
qualitative data the clarification helps
in understanding the interest of the
stakeholders which plays a vital role in
the success of the project as i
mentioned earlier
so next question for us what is the role
of stakeholder in project management
so stakeholder as we know refers to any
organization or entity that can have any
positive or negative effect due to
project
because their interests are most
important their positive impact need to
be kept in mind while any negative
impact need to minimize while planning
for executing any activity during the
project
so it is very important to understand
the stakeholder perspective view
next question what are some essential
features to be kept in mind while
choosing a project management tool
so project management tools basically
assist the project manager and the
project team in doing the project
effectively
and i think efficient way of doing
project is also ensured
because many processes are automated
and
the transaction will become easier the
collaboration become easier
creation of dashboards and reports which
will provide the visibility of the
performance of the project
so let us look at some of the essential
features required by project management
tools so risk management just now we
discussed about risk management and its
importance if a project management tool
assist while identifying and managing
risk because when we identify risk we
update those in a risk register so if
tool has established risk register where
we can keep inputting this particular
risks and keep alerting the specific
details about we have a frequency of
analyzing the risk repeatedly the
identified risk so informing us
reminding us telling that this
calendar is like this you may require to
analyze those that will help in making
it better right risk assessment as well
as updates in terms of managing the risk
also lessons learned earlier some risks
which of similar kind which are
identified are managed like this so
let's start recalling those
coming to resource management so tool
can able to help us in terms of
calculating the expenditures and
distribute them among the tasks
so that it is helpful in terms of better
management of resources as well as the
cost associated with that then
dependencies milestones and critical
path
so most of the project management tools
what we have come across minimum they
will have this capability establishing a
gantt chart helping in terms of
establishing a network diagram which
will provide us a visibility in terms of
what is that the project flow would be
how the project flow would go on and how
the project is going to complete what
are the activities dependent on each
other so what are the relationship
between each of the tasks what are the
milestone deliverables duration of the
project what are those activities
happening in parallel so visually
graphical representation it would give
so it should also
minimize simplify the tool should have
that capability it should also have a
minimal interfaces or ease of doing
things like drag and drop interfaces so
ease functionalities maintaining smooth
maintenance and support which it can
help us in terms of doing a project
management better
so basically tools helps us in terms of
assisting to have efficient and
effective project management
so all the information should be handy
so that it is there with us always so
third party integration like a tool must
be able to help us in terms of
collaborating with other tools which
would help us in sharing information it
would help us in terms of for providing
better visibility
any other tools which are there in the
organization if i'm speaking about
documentation records sharing or any of
the reports or creation of the
dashboards these are the capabilities
which what tool can have and at the same
time this can have an interface with
other tools like dropbox google drive
which will help in have a better
visibility and better collaboration so
agile workflow system when we say the
functions features functionality of this
particular tool should help us becoming
agile so moving faster means quick
inputs and feedbacks given because when
we say agile we are moving faster when
we are moving faster there should be
quick feedbacks which should be coming
back so that necessary corrections can
be made quickly
so to do this if tool can assist us in
providing those details
of increased flexibility and
transparency so that would help in
becoming more productive
then dashboards to manage projects
dashboards which will provide what is
complete what is not complete what is
the status of the project how is the
performance so this would help in having
a quick visibility into the performance
of the project and also the progress of
the project to track them so that what
is complete what is not complete and how
it is progressing is it ahead of
schedule behind schedule is it within
budget or over budget
the visibility to that will always help
in terms of getting better project
management done
then customizable workflows so the tool
should be able to adapt to the unique
process to track work progression so
then if it provides a mobile application
integration so better to have team to
know what is the status of it anytime
anywhere so that ease of moving forward
faster in the project management and
making decisions will become easier
because always having right information
in right time with the right people is
very essential so that decision making
can be more informed and quicker
then collaborate easily the tool should
enable user to share documents files
status timelines and tasks with ease and
quickly with many people then delegating
tasks easily you should be able to
delegate tasks assign roles and then
ensure they have access to the right
information
so that's all about
tools now we'll move to the next
question
so what do you think is the difference
between projects programs and portfolio
so this looks like a very generic
question which is asked by any
individuals during their interview
but even though this question doesn't
focus on project in specific it is very
essential for project manager to
understand the difference between these
three so that hope to ask for what will
be known to the project manager so the
definition of project is like a
temporary end over it's an activity that
is used to create a unique product
service or results we saw that we
understood already whereas program is a
collection of related projects which are
managed as group to achieve better
effectiveness and efficiency so when
which you don't get when you manage a
project individually if you group it and
manage you can share resources you can
optimize
the resources and cost you can
standardize that you can achieve through
program management so portfolio
management is again a group of projects
and programs which may be related
unrelated but strategic objective
accomplishing strategic objectives of
the organization is very essential so
all these projects and programs and
other related works are grouped together
with the common strategic objective
organization
so the project manager versus program
manager versus portfolio managers what
do they do so project manager expects
change and implements processes to
manage and control the project in terms
of accomplishing the project objective
whereas program manager expects changes
from inside and outside the program to
provide strategic benefits as i
mentioned earlier like standardization
optimization so portfolio manager
monitors changes in the overall context
of the strategic plan of the
organization
is this projects or programs or whatever
we do in this organization are they
aligned to strategic objectives are they
helping to accomplish the strategic
objectives
so project managers manages and
coordinate the team to ensure success
whereas program manager manages the
program staff and the project manager
providing leadership and vision the
portfolio manager may coordinate or
manage the portfolio management staff
then monitoring part of it project
manager monitors and controls tasks to
produce the products results or services
of the project whereas program manager
monitors the progress of components to
lead the program to success portfolio
manager manages the aggregated portfolio
performance and value indicators so
planning part of it project manager
develops monitors and controls project
plans throughout the project life cycle
whereas program manager develops the
program plan and performs high level
planning to guide component level
planning whereas portfolio managers
perform plannings at a portfolio level
the scope the project manager will
develop monitor and control throughout
the lifecycle of the project whereas
program manager has a program which has
a wider scope aimed at meeting the
benefits and goals of the organization
whereas portfolio has a scope that
changes with change in the strategic
plan and goals of the organization
so why the strategic goals or plans
would change the directions would change
that has various different reasons maybe
business scenario market conditions etc
the success of the project is based on
time taken to finish the project the
budget within which it is completed the
scope the customer satisfaction the
quality defines the success whereas the
program success is measured in terms of
benefits
it delivered as it expected from the
program then the portfolio success
is the aggregated performance of all its
components programs and projects
question number 12
what are the skills a project manager
must possess
typically a project manager would
require to have effective communication
skills so communication skills help in
terms of establishing better
relationship because it plays a vital
role there what do we communicate when
do we communicate how do we communicate
matters because it's not about just
verbal communication or return
communication
there is non-herbal communication
through body languages through
expressions which individuals do the
communication so it is very essential to
have a
right method and right approach towards
communication so the project manager
should possess that skill good
leadership skills so many times the term
leadership is confused with the position
of a leader
no so leadership is basically a
capability of an individual so if a
specific individual having that
capability can influence people can
inspire can motivate project manager
having a leadership skills it's very
essential it is a must required skill
only then project manager can make
the people listen to him people will
respect him
because the behavior will be guided
through that capability strong team
management skill which requires
a an engagement which requires
communication and leadership skills work
very closely with this team management
skills so understanding the team
dynamics ensuring the right education
right skilled individuals are in place
and they're monitored and managed which
is very important so there should be a
little bit of mentoring which needs to
be done to the people regularly so that
team gets what is expected out of them
and they do accordingly then effective
negotiation skills lot of scenarios
which comes in terms of negotiating in
various different scenarios negotiate to
ensure things have been in place or in
the interest of both the parties
involved in the negotiation it is very
important to involve and make a right
discussion right side of discussion so
that stakeholders are benefited
now who are these
roles we are speaking about who would
involve in negotiation we can think of
customers while establishing an
agreement we can think of teams while
having some conflict resolutions which
you take team will have a conflict you
may require to resolve
so suppliers related issues which needs
to be resolved so negotiation is very
important but always
negotiations would be in the interest of
both the involved parties then critical
thinking so critical thinking in the
sense not just
seeing what is there it's about how to
set it right how to take it forward in
the right direction so what could cause
visualizing things is very important
risk management skills it's quite
obvious the most ignored area what which
i have seen throughout is risk
management so i don't know what is the
reason risk is ignored many of the
projects what i have seen almost like 80
to 85 percent people don't even look at
the risks so it is very essential to
look at the risk and manage the risk
only then project can become successful
so question 13 what will be involved in
project scope management so we already
know project scope means it involves
both
project scope as well as product scope
now scope management basically ensures
project includes all those necessary
things to be done in terms of activities
in terms of processes in terms of
resources
the project objectives can be
accomplished so this particular process
project scope management describes the
project scope and documents how it will
be designed validated and controlled
throughout the project life cycle so it
collects requirement so collect
requirement process engages with
stakeholders discusses with them to
understand what is the requirement
collect the requirements document the
requirements and establish requirement
management plan then based on this
requirement established
has to be defined means the detailed
description of the project and product
has to be developed and a list has to be
created that includes all the
requirements then creating the wbs work
breakdown structure once the scope is
defined so now the decomposition of that
scope definition what is given has to be
taken to the lowest possible level it
has to be like logically further it
cannot be subdivided right
so decomposition basically helps in
terms of breaking down those ultimate
deliverable to multiple lower level
parts for example if i consider a car i
can think about two broad categories
like exteriors and interiors now in
exteriors i can think of a body of the
car the rear view mirror the wheel the
bonnet the glass so i can just decompose
like this now until i decompose to the
mirror further i cannot decompose in the
mirror what are all the things we can
think of mirror cap mirror glass mirror
mount so further can i subdivide this
no so each of the components involved
in all the perspective in the car
perspective broadly initially decomposed
it to the level interior exteriors and
further down the line we took to the
next level of components further down in
the line we again decompose it now at
the lowest level we actually look at the
effort estimation activity resource
required all these we look at and we'll
do bottom up to consolidate to see what
is the scope so which will help us in
becoming scope baseline so while lead
scope is a process in monitoring and
controlling which involves reviewing the
deliverables with the customer or
sponsor to ensure successful completion
and formal acceptance of the
deliverables so formal acceptance is the
key requirements when we validate the
scope if it is not according to the plan
that is rejected and it is sent back for
change and necessary corrections
then control scope so in this process
the status of the project and product
scope is monitored changes to the scope
baseline which is actually defined as
part of the planning if anything is seen
in terms of deviation that needs to be
corrected the change request would be
raised
then next question tell us about some
project management tools so some of the
most common and popular management tools
which have come across are listed here
like pluto basecamp teamwork projects
zoho projects asana jira software trello
i think details of this you might
require to go to individual tool
sections and then review those better if
you can able to create a comparison
sheet always helps in terms of
understanding what is that features
functionality of this tool has so one
more tool which is not mentioned is
microsoft project so which is also
another popular tool which is used and
similarly i can mention like primavera
so each of this has its own advantages
disadvantages so you may require to list
out what do you exactly want in terms of
when you take up a tool for project
management and what each of this tool
has if you can able to create a
comparison sheet that would help you in
terms of selecting the right tool for
your organization and projects
question number 15 what is the
significance of monitoring and
controlling in the project life cycle so
as we know monitoring and controlling is
a process group so this involves
tracking the project's performance
alongside the planned project management
activities this also focuses on
comparing actual and planned performance
so we have defined that in the planning
so what needs to be accomplished how it
has to be accomplished what templates
are to be used what needs to be
delivered we have defined it in planning
so that needs to be compared with actual
thing what is created and what is that
how are we doing this currently how it
is done is it complied with
assessing performance to determine any
corrective actions are identified their
status reported and appropriate
responses to risks are taken so ensuring
an accurate information base providing
information to support status reporting
measuring progress and forecasting
adding forecasts to update cost and
current schedule information making sure
approved changes are being implemented
upon successfully performing monitoring
and control the processes within
monitoring and controlling process group
so the possible outcomes would be like
the change request work performance
reports update to project management
plan and project documents
maybe if everything is okay well for
example validate scope which comes under
this process group so if when we
validate if everything is okay as per
the plan then it is accepted deliverable
which will move towards the closure if
it is not obviously it leads towards
change requests
so question number 16 is what's the key
difference in the roles of the project
and program manager so project manager
is basically focuses on projects and its
success of the project as we know
already whereas program manager looks at
all those projects which fall under the
program are managed together and taken
forward in the required direction so
program manager plans program level
activities and the schedule of projects
so program managers defines terms of
reference for projects the starts stops
and monitor progress of constituent
projects manages program level risks and
issues they set up policies and
procedures for projects they resolve
conflicts they determine the program
standards similarly project manager
focuses on planning a project based on
dependencies and interfaces given by the
project manager so works within the
defined tar terms of references given
for the projects runs a project reports
to program manager manage project risks
and issues and escalates them to program
manager if required if at all a project
is part of a program if it is not then
that escalation goes to sponsor so
project manager runs projects according
to the policies and procedures uses
resources assigned to project manager
and delivers the products that satisfy
the requirements question number 17
what are the types of risks involved in
the project so we know that one of the
knowledge areas in the project
management is risk management it is very
essential for us to identify risk assess
and analyze risk and have the risk
response plans so while doing it it is
also very important for us to understand
categorizing the risks depending on
where exactly what category this risk
falls into
depending on the impacts for example
some of the list which is given common
types of risk there is categories you
can think of it may be related to cost
schedule performance technology or
technical strategic legal market risk
risk related to external hazards and it
goes on so these are the minimum set of
list which we can think of in any
project the the kind of risk are
associated with which area so when i say
cost associated risk it's all about
monetary related where we invest where
we actually monitor that budget involve
that budget incur that cost related to
that schedule in terms of doing it
faster doing it slower doing it as per
the plan so various different details
which are associated with the schedule
likewise each of these types what we
have mentioned will have a risk
accordingly associated with them so
question number 18 what is the
difference between the risk and
issue in context of project management
so when we say risk is always we look at
in the future so it's an uncertainty of
outcome when we say we are looking in
the future it may be next moment in the
future but it is risk which is focused
on the future so risks may be positive
or negative any risk we identify may
have positive or negative impact whereas
risk response will be in accordance with
the risk response planning and this are
documented in risk register
so issue is always the one which we have
in front of us to manage so it is
focused on present always negative it
will have negative impacts so response
will be in accordance to the issue
workaround provided and these are
documented in the issue register so next
question question number 19 how does
project scheduling help in project
execution project scheduling make sure
there is a sequence of how all the tasks
will be performed after the resources
are estimated and plan is made the
schedule plays a very important role
because when to do when it is planned it
is very essential to do accordingly so
providing the sequence what activity has
to be done in what sequence it's also
very important so this must be carried
out first and what should follow needs
to be clearly understood
the optimized scheduling of tasks
provides the best possible output with
the allocated resources and that has to
be done within the scheduled time within
the deadline
question number 20 what do you
understand by quality control now
quality control refers to activities
needed to evaluate if the project meets
all the requirements with respect to the
scope of the project planning now when
we say a control we should think about
the output of a project the deliverable
it has the specifications so relating to
that specifications the features
functionalities what needs to be
delivered is it delivered accordingly so
project managers defines the standard
that the project must fulfill to be
successful quality control includes
validating the deliverables satisfying
the requirements of the stakeholders
identifying the cause of poor project
quality and taking necessary actions to
eliminate problems
right question number 21 explain the
forming in team dynamics basically when
we say team dynamics it involves various
different stages like forming storming
norming performing and adjourning so
farming happens first now this happens
when the team first meets each other so
when they meet each other they get
introduced to each other and get to know
their backgrounds experience and areas
of expertise the team members discuss
about the project discuss the project
objectives and beginning to think their
role in the project they're beginning to
understand they know what is this
project is all about so in detail what
is this project is all about will be
understood by them in storming which is
the next stage in the team dynamics
question number 22 so what is work
breakdown structure and how does it
affect the work estimates of tasks or
activities work breakdown structure is a
hierarchical replica of all the work in
the project for example if i take up a
specific object specific products or
services which we are bringing out as a
result for example if i take a car so
how will i visualize various different
parts of the car it's very difficult in
one go in in execution perspective and
creation perspective we may require to
know every parts of it in detail so work
breakdown structure is established using
decomposition as a technique
which means for example if i take car as
an example car has a hole when you
visualize broadly i would classify that
into decompose it to the first level
like exteriors and interiors after
exteriors i can further decompose the
exterior part of it similarly after
interiors i will decompose it further in
exteriors what are the things i can
think of like exteriors in terms of
glass in terms of body in terms of tires
in terms of wheel bonnet mirror rear
mirror which is outside so likewise
there were various different
decompositions level that is a second
level of decomposition next third level
of decomposition i can go in each of
these parts what i said i can further
elaborate those if i take the rear view
mirror as an example so i can think
about mirror cap i can think about
mirror glass i can think about mirror
mount so these are the various different
decomposed levels below mirror similarly
if i come to interiors we can think
about entertainment system you can think
about seeds we can think about ac right
so we can think about
anything else like dashboards now each
of these components further i can
decompose so the idea of decomposing is
i am going to understand what are the
various product parts are involved to
make a bigger product as a whole so once
i accomplish that i will have a details
at each of these levels and consoled it
upwards as shown in the picture here the
first level task 1 task 2 task 3. before
i assign these tasks i will have the
product breakdown structure first and
from bottom level i start adding up the
activities effort estimation and then i
keep consolidating upwards similarly i
will put the cost components to it i'll
estimate the cost involved with the one
which is required and then i go upwards
and consult it so wbs helps in
organizing the work in a manageable
sections so this would help in
establishing additional details which
would help in defining tasks helping in
estimation helps in when i say
estimation it is not just specific
estimation it's about cost estimation
schedule estimation effort estimation
and then this will also help us in terms
of sequencing further so work breakdown
structure will also have something
called wbs dictionary
which gives the description of all the
wbs elements next question question
number 23 what is meant by the term spi
now spi refers to schedule performance
index
so schedule performance index is a
measure of schedule efficiency expressed
as a ratio of earned value to the
planned value so when i say earned value
earned value is the actual work which is
completed the value the budgeted value
for the actual work which is completed
and planned value is the budgeted value
of the work which is supposed to be
accomplished as per the plan now this
will help us in understanding how the
project is progressing in schedule
perspective if spi is lesser than 1
means it is behind schedule spi is more
than one it is head of schedule if a sp
is one it is as per the plan schedule is
as per the plan question number 24 what
is the significance of agile project
management so when we say agile the
terminology itself refers to quick
response flexible moving faster so while
we do agile project management it is
very essential to look at the various
dynamics around so it may be a quick
response what you need to give right so
predominantly agile methodologies are
today adopted in various types of
industries so currently we see more and
more in it and software industry than
product development marketing campaigns
even in constructing companies some of
the reasons that encourage industries to
take up agile methodologies are
high product quality high customer
satisfaction reduced risk better and
faster roi now let us look at the
question number 25 what is the
significance of agile project management
so the agile project management
frameworks involves continuous planning
and testing so there are various
different frameworks each of them having
their own unique qualities so it is very
essential for us to understand what are
those various different agile frameworks
and how they are going to contribute to
become agile so the most popular agile
frameworks some thoughts which actually
depicts and supports organization to
become agile or one of that is kanban
framework so kanban framework is used to
implement agile software development and
requires real time communication so work
items are represented on a kanban board
allowing team members to see the state
of each work at any time so this means
on the board so work in progress work
which has to be done and who has to do
it all these details are captured in the
kanban board now very important point
here is when these are captured it's
very essential to understand it is a
visual board so when it is a visual
board it's quite obvious anyone who has
actually have a task against them they
don't hesitate they they need to
complete it it forces them since it is a
visualized system it works on their
consciousness so it is also called as
pull system so because people pull the
work from that list whatever is given
and then accomplish it so this will also
help in tracking the progression of a
project how it is progressing how the
project is progressing how the tasks are
being completed how quickly they are
completed so it is easily visible and
that makes things too much smoother and
faster
so scrum framework so scrum framework
helps in dealing with complex problems
and making it possible to deliver high
quality products
at the same time it helps in managing
complex advanced work with little
emphasize on software development so it
uses the terminologies like sprint
product backlog sprint backlog daily
scrum
retrospective meeting so three roles
predominantly we come across that is
product owner stub master and then self
organizing team
so next framework is hybrid framework
that you can think of so it is the
combination of agile methods with
non-agile methods hybrid can handle
requirement changes and it can deliver
products in stages so in hybrid model
planning is done using a waterfall
approach while the agile approach
handles execution and delivery
so lean framework so the lean framework
works on the concept of maximizing
customer value with fewer resources and
zero waste hence lean focuses on the
flow of products and services instead of
focusing on separate technologies
companies can act upon with changing
customer needs and requirements so very
important points to observe here zero
waste means in the flow the way the
processes are connected to each other in
that flow we should identify what are
those which acts as a bottlenecks
resulting in waste so we should
eliminate such bottlenecks so these
elimination of bottlenecks helps in
reduction of waste at the same time
increasing the value to the customers so
in the downstream from the point where
bottleneck you have the entire capacity
will get limited to the downstream
capacity i'm speaking about will get
limited to the bottleneck where that
particular issue exists right that needs
to be resolved elimination of waste
should happen
so waste is a result of anything which
is a non-value-adding activity right so
we need to identify as per the lean
perspective so the defects are not
allowed to move forward to the
downstream that is the whole idea behind
it so next question 26
why does a project manager need to be
proactive okay so we always have this
question coming around proactiveness
versus reactiveness when should we be
proactive when should we be reactive
that we need to understand now more
proactive in nature the project manager
or any manager who is more proactive
will basically visualize the future so
they act today so that tomorrow
something negative in fact will not
happen so a proactive project manager is
actively able to determine the several
communication needs of the stakeholders
so a proactive project manager is able
to identify the risks in the early stage
of the project it is very essential so
what is that going to happen in future
that needs to be visualized act today so
that that occurrences can be handled
better or eliminated
question number 27
what does a critical path method imply
so firstly let us understand what is
critical path means so critical path is
basically a longest path in a given
project network diagram so that would be
the minimum time required for a project
to complete so any delay in any of the
activities or tasks in critical path
delays the project duration so in
critical path method so it is a crucial
tool for determining the progress of the
project to ensure that project is on
schedule so as i mentioned any delay in
any of the activities or tasks in the
critical path delays the project itself
so monitoring on these activities in a
critical path will become more important
so that project can happen as per the
plan as per the date what is given so
critical path method helps in
determining the essential or critical
path by finding out the longest stretch
of dependent tasks so that each
dependencies each flow from left to
right from beginning to end has to be
visualized and monitored very closely so
that project finish date is not uh
delayed it happens according to the plan
so next question
defined planned value actual cost and
earned value so when we say planned
value planned value is the approved
value of the work that needs to be
completed within a given period it
serves as a baseline and needs to be
calculated before work can be started it
is also known as budgeted cost of work
scheduled so formula to calculate
planned values planned percentage of
work completed into project budget
assume your project budget is 10 000
whatsoever the currencies let us assume
10 000 is my project budget so my
project duration is five months each
month i have a plan to complete the work
worth of two thousand so which means
that two thousand is my planned value
the work which is supposed to be
accomplished within the end of that
first month is work worth of 2000
so if i do the work which is lesser than
work worth of maybe lesser than 2000 i
am behind schedule if i complete the
work worth more than 2000 then i am
ahead of schedule so planned value will
become that reference the 2000 what i
mentioned as a planned value the work
worth of 2000 i am supposed to complete
before the end of the month one if i say
any work which is completed according to
the budgeted value i will make this plan
value as a reference to decide whether i
am behind schedule or ahead of schedule
actual cost actual cost refer to the
value of total expenses that you have
incurred for the work done till date for
example in the previous
discussion relating to the planned value
at the end of month 1 the planned value
was 2000 so that is the work worth which
were supposed to complete now let us
assume
we have completed a work where the work
work relating to that actual work
completed is around 1800 means i'm
behind schedule for sure but at the same
time to complete the work worth of 1800
how much i incurred actually so if i
have incurred actual cost also 1800 then
cost wise i'm according to the plan but
behind schedule because i have only
completed the work worth of 1800 against
the work worth of 2000 which is the
planned value and behind schedule but to
complete it the actual cost i incurred
is 1800 so cost wise i'm according to
the plan if my actual cost is lesser
than 1800 then i'm doing very good in
cost perspective if my actual cost is
more than 1800 then i'm using more money
means over budget so actual cost helps
us in relating to planned well to define
whether cost wise how am i doing so it
is also known as actual cost of work
performed so this will be used to
calculate cost variance and cost
performance index
earned value earned value represents the
value produced by a project it is also
known as budgeted cost of work performed
in our example the earned value is 1800
meaning i have completed the work worth
of 1800 that is the earned value which
says behind schedule when i compare
earned value with the planned value it
it will tell me whether i'm behind
schedule ahead of schedule or according
to the plan now for this earned value of
1800 if i incur the actual cost of 1800
then cost wise i'm doing good if my
actual cost is lesser than earned value
then cost wise i'm very good
right if i incur more than earned value
for example to complete the work worth
of 1800 i incur the cost of 2000 then
i'm not doing good i'm over budget so
the combination of earned value and
planned value helps us to know the
scheduled perspective the project is
behind or ahead or according to the plan
schedule perspective whereas the
combination of earned value and actual
cost helps us to understand whether
project is within the budget or budget
or according to the plan question number
29
what is the purpose of procurement
management plan the procurement
management plan defines the procurement
requirements and how it can be managed
from developing a procurement
documentation through to contract
closure the plan identifies and defines
the items that need to be procured the
contracts that need to be used for
supporting the project how the contract
is approved and criteria for decisions
to be made has to be looked at the plan
also includes other items including
considerations for procurement risks and
procurement risk management deciding how
cost needs to be determined standard
procurement documentation usage and
constraints to procurement
question number 30 when is postmartem
analysis performed in the project
management a postmartem in a project or
project retrospective
refers to process that's performed at
the conclusion of the phase for a
multi-stage project this aim to help
identify process improvements that can
prevent future risks and to ensure best
practices are repeated postmartems
involve a combination of quantitative
and qualitative data it also includes
qualitative data like end user
stakeholder and team satisfaction
potential for reuse and the quality of
end deliverable that is pursued
question number 31 what is the purpose
of risk register risk register is
basically a tool that is used to
document risks and the actions to handle
each of those risks the management of
risk is an ongoing process that has a
project team raising risks with the risk
manager or a project manager who then
locks the risks and determines an
appropriate course of action to handle
the risk risk register also needs to be
reviewed regularly to ensure the
appropriate actions are performed it
could be reviewed in every project team
meeting or at the end of each phase of
the project life cycle
question number 32 when do we use a
grant chart so as we are discussing
about critical paths network diagram
critical path method so by using a
project tools we first establish a gantt
chart so gantt chart is basically a
visual view of tasks scheduled over a
period a gantt chart is useful for
outlining all the tasks involved in the
project along with their order shown
against the time scales so since it
gives the pictorial representation it
helps us in understanding what tasks
will be completed after which tasks and
how the dependencies of each task will
be can be easily understood it provides
an overview of a project its associated
tasks and then
when they need to be finished are
clearly understood a gantt chart is
helpful because it provides a detailed
view of all tasks and ensures one can
create a workable schedule and the right
people are assigned to right task it can
be used to determine the practical
aspect of the project it enables to keep
the team and sponsors informed about the
progress of the project
question number 33 what is the
significance of the critical path method
so critical path method or cpm is a tool
that is used to schedule project
activities so cpm is used to create a
model that includes tasks required to
complete the project dependencies
between the tasks the durations required
to complete an activity the critical
path is the longest path in all the
available paths in the project and the
duration of the critical path will be
the minimum time required by the project
to complete
question number 34 what are some tools
required for arriving at improvement in
processes so process improvement
comprises a set of actions implemented
by a company to enhance performance cost
reduction increasing profits etc so some
of the tools some organization can use
to implement a successful process
improvement strategy can be comparing
and baselining a project so with this we
can get an overview of how the process
is performing in comparison with other
similar processes flow charting which
helps them segregating the processes
activities events etc value stream
mapping it helps clearly understand the
workflow and helps organizations
identify waste cause and effect analysis
these help organizations determine the
root cause of any problem hypothesis
testing which helps in testing to
determine whether a hypothesis would be
favorable to the organization or not
question 35 how do you work with three
point estimation method so the three
point estimation method is also called a
spurt estimation which is a tool that
can be used to help increase the
accuracy of cost and time estimates
there are three parts with the different
estimates that is optimistic pessimistic
and most likely the optimistic estimate
is the amount of time required to
complete the project assuming everything
in the project goes according to the
plan pessimistic estimation is the
estimation considering the worst case
scenario and is an estimation given in
everything goes wrong that is the
assumption so most likely estimation so
this is most likely to happen and falls
under the pessimistic and optimistic
estimates it falls in between that
pessimistic and optimistic so the
formula to calculate three point
estimate would be pessimistic plus
optimistic plus four most likely divided
by six will provide the three point
estimation
what do you understand by the term raid
raid log is a project management tool
that tracks risks actions issues and
decisions it provides a simple way to
organize the information so the main
advantages of raid log is to enable you
to think in organized and strategic way
the raid log has all the questions that
could be asked by stakeholders the data
is easily accessible and acts as a
measure for how well the plans are being
carried out the raid locks makes the
process of decision making more
consistent it provides a place where all
decisions made can be compared
question number 37 what are some
techniques used for defining scope so
here are some tools and techniques to
define scope that is expert judgment it
which requires to bring in experts on
domain product analysis which needs to
break down the final deliverable into
smaller components to ensure all the
steps are being taken alternative
generation so in alternative generation
it's need to brainstorm for the best and
most effective way to create it for the
product facilitated workshops which
allow different people with different
ideas to find common ground for a
project
question number 38 what is waterfall
model
waterfall model is a project management
approach in which a project is completed
in several phases a big plan is executed
linearly expecting there will not be any
changes in the plan waterfall model is
in contrast a gel model does not respond
well to frequent changes any changes
which comes in between while following
the waterfall methodologies making that
changes will be difficult and bit
complex
question 39 and what basis would you
decide if a particular risk should be
avoided or mitigated the risks which are
having high impact negative to the
business are awarded by the
organizations usually so avoiding is the
first decision what organization makes
for sure but however there may be some
discussions which are made before the
decision of being made relating to
avoiding that risk instead having some
workaround for that risk or making
certain arrangements so that impact of
the risks can be reduced or bringing
down the probability of occurrence of
the risks considering something which
will have higher negative impact they
may not be worthwhile to take up so in
that case i think avoiding is the best
decision once the organization is
considered to take up after identifying
and analyzing the risks then
organization would work on risk response
plan for all the risks which are
identified
so what is evm the earned value
management so earned value management is
a project management technique that is
used to measure the project progress if
you recall the terminologies like earned
value planned value actual cost
scheduled performance index cost
performance index these are the
terminologies which comes as part of
earned value management it calculates
the project performance and progress by
combining constraints like time scope
and cost
so question 41 what is the difference in
product life cycle and project life
cycle so project life cycle refers to
the sequence of stages or phases the
project undergoes from the time it is
initiated till it is closed so this
project life cycle involves five process
groups which is initiating process group
planning process group executing process
group monitoring and controlling process
group closure process group which should
be there throughout the project life
cycle along with the 10 knowledge areas
and 49 processes product life cycle
includes all that phases that define the
growth of your product so creation of
the product till expiry of the product
so within the product life cycle we may
have multiple project life cycles so one
project life cycle for introduction of
product one project lifecycle for
modifying or updating the existing
product one project lifecycle may be for
improvement one project life cycle may
be for removing the product from the
production so in product life cycle
there are four phases that is market
introduction market growth market
maturity and decline and saturation
stage
question 42 define capability maturity
model so capability maturity model is an
approach to improve or refine
development process in an organization
so it is an elaborated structure of
elements that helps in defining the
features of an effective process
next question 43 what do you know about
triple constraint the triangle in
project management so basically the
triple constraint refers to scope
schedule and cost right so it helps in
actually analyzing the project status
the way project is progressing and these
are the three critical considerations
mainly which needs to be made so further
to these triple constraints scope time
and cost quality resource and risks are
also considered as a constraints so any
change in any of the constraints would
have an impact on other constraints
question 44 what is a decision support
system decision support system is an
information system used in decision
making activities in an organization or
a business it analyzes data sets and
extracts information that may be used to
solve complex problems and take
decisions
how many types of dss are there so there
are several types of dss that is data
driven model driven knowledge driven and
documentary one
question 46 what are some general
metrics that are used to calculate if a
project is progressing on track so if a
project is progressing on track it is
very essential to consider the
productivity which means units of input
units of output actual cost that is
total cost per time period to time
period cost variance which refers to
budgeted cost of work versus actual cost
of work schedule variance
which is
the difference between budgeted cost of
work perform and budget cost of work
scheduled cost performance index which
is earned value to actual cost
question 47 what is meant by a milestone
in a project a project milestone
provides a way to observe measure and
monitor the performance progress of the
project these represents intermediate
stages that needs to be fulfilled before
getting to the final objective or goal
milestones can provide a basis on which
progress can be monitored they can also
proof for explanation while reporting on
project status
it can be used to provide course
corrections and learning experiences it
can also be used to maintain
accountability and motivate staff
question 48 how can you estimate the
activity time of a project the activity
time or duration refers to the process
of evaluating the number of work periods
required to finish individual activities
with the resources available these help
achieve the project objectives on set
dates and delivery schedules decided by
project management team and key
stakeholders here are some tools and
techniques to calculate activity
durations so those are expert judgment
analogous estimation pert method three
point estimates parametric estimating
alternative analysis published
estimating data vendor bid analysis etc
question 49 what do you think about csf
critical success factor in a project
management so csf or critical success
factor are found in the project
management plan and can define what can
be defined as success for the project
some characteristics of critical success
factor involve for example time was the
project completed within the given time
period
cost did it stay within the budgeted
cost quality did it meet the
specification level stakeholder was the
result accepted by the end user project
changes where scope changes are minimal
and are agreed upon performing
organization did it affect the corporate
culture commitment is required from team
members clients top management all
stakeholders which is very essential and
it is one of the main critical success
factors goals must be specific
measurable attainable relevant and time
bound there must be process for quick
identification resolution of conflict
good project leadership is to be
established risk management policies
have to be established there must be
proper project planning that needs to be
done then best practices need to be
applied at all stages proper
communications might takes place to
ensure information is passed across
question number 50 what do you
understand by the term sow so sow
or statement of work is a document that
includes and define each aspects of the
project it is a foundation for the
project plan so before planning and
executing the sow lays down the entire
landscape of the project so it consists
of introduction the purpose of the
project the scope of the project
when it is done where it is done the
tasks milestones deliverables schedule
standards success how are you going to
determine the success means how do you
know the project is success what is that
you are going to measure or consider for
measurement requirements then any other
things which needs to be considered as
part of sow as part of that specific
project and then closing so sow can be
of three categories which will have
design details level of effort time and
materials which defines an hourly
service and the materials required to
perform the tasks which may be
performance based focuses on purpose of
the project resources and quality
expected from the output
question 51 what is a fishbone diagram
and when is it used so fishbone diagram
which is also called as ishikawa diagram
is a visualization tool that used to
categorize potential causes that is
problems for an issue to identify the
root causes so fishbone diagram is used
in product development and
troubleshooting processes
it helps in team brainstorming for
potential causes and then represents
them in a diagram based on their degree
of importance so when this diagram is
used it helps us in identifying the
possible causes of an issue to develop a
product that can address issue with
current market offerings to several
areas of weakness or bottlenecks in the
business process to handle recurring
issues or employees burnout to ensure
any correction will resolve the issue
so question 52 what is the parito
principle or 80 20 principle so as the
name itself indicates the pareto
principle states that 80 percent of
consequences come from 20 percent of
causes indicating an unequal
relationship between inputs and outputs
it can be applied to range of areas like
manufacturing management and human
resources it is usually focused on
businesses that are claimed based some
of the advantages of pareto principles
are increased productivity increased
profitability identifying and fixing
problems and improved customer service
question 53 can you tell us about your
past project so now while answering
these type of questions firstly we need
to understand this question is open and
generic in nature so while answering
such questions following points has to
be considered so identify what is that
project you have done so state the
objective of the project project
deliverables your roles and
responsibility in the project and what
have you achieved in that project what
was accomplished what went well what did
not go well then project duration
project budget and actual cost incurred
in the project question 54 if customer
is not happy with the project what will
you do as a project manager so in any
given project customer satisfaction is
very important to ensure success of a
project in the scenario where customer
expresses their dissatisfaction one has
to ensure understanding the reason for
dissatisfaction so are all the
requirement fulfilled or not project
manager has to confirm that first was
customer involved in all decision making
activities etc to confirm that his
customer is informed about everything so
before customer is dissatisfied it is
always good and important that customer
is satisfied that needs to be ensured
so it is very important to be customer
to understand and customers pulse is
understood and handling the customers
accordingly
so allowing customer to become a
dissatisfied customer is not a choice to
have so one is to ensure customer is not
at all dissatisfied in the first place
beyond your control if customer is still
dissatisfied better you work on it to
understand why the customer is
dissatisfied what is the cause of it and
address it
question 55
what are the different kinds of project
you have worked upon so these type of
questions are again generic in nature
while answering those questions please
ensure you speak about various different
domains of the project which you have
and that should have variation in
different say different domains of the
project what were the deliverables of
those projects projects nature and
complexity unique challenges in each
different type of projects then project
duration budget and actual cost
question 56 did you ever face the
situations where the project team was
demotivated and what did you do to bring
them back on track so as we know project
team plays very important role in
success of any project it is very
critical to keep them motivated the
demotivation may happen for various
reasons so one is to keep the following
points in mind while dealing with the
team that is team engagement so
engagement may be both formal and
informal so rewards and recognitions for
the team for the good job they have done
conflict management wherever the
conflict occurs it is quite obvious
whenever the team is involved conflict
occurs performance evaluation and
monitoring mentoring is very key so
wherever it is required to mentor
wherever it is required to give them a
good perspective of the project and
their learning and capability so
mentoring and coaching is very essential
and also providing opportunities for
education and training so that they will
have a better learning and accomplish or
acquire the required skills
question 57 if you get your dream job
and i assume this is your dream job what
value you think you will you be adding
to the organization so this question is
very tricky one and also a generic
question so one needs to ensure while
answering this question to discuss the
following points why the job is your
dream job whatever the job you're
speaking about why do you say that that
is your dream job what is the reason why
what would be your motivation point in
this dream job what exactly is
motivating you there in this particular
job how this dream job can link to
objectives of organization and the
profession and roadmap of the job role
so what is that you are going to become
while you become this in future what
could be the roadmap of this role
question 58 what challenges have you
encountered while dealing with other
team members as already mentioned
project team plays very important role
in success of a project each team member
comes with the different skills maturity
mindsets and background which put across
many challenges some of the important
changing scenarios means challenging
scenarios is team not collaborating
individuals performance and motivation
levels in each of the projects role
preferences and the allocated roles
performance appraisals communication
gaps various things which actually
brings the challenges and also motivates
people to behave way they are behaving
question 59
share from your experience the
challenges you faced while using project
management tools so we all know that
tools plays very important role in our
management activity similarly the
effective management of project requires
an efficient tool every tools has its
own uniqueness and has its own
advantages and disadvantages so some of
the challenges one would face while
using the tools would be selection of
right tools for the given project tools
features and functionalities
customization of tools the dashboards
and reports teams ability to work with
tool their skills and capabilities
matters
question 60 can you tell me about the
most difficult complex project you have
worked on this question is open and
generic in nature again while answering
such questions please ensure you discuss
the following points what was the
complexity in the project whichever the
project reference you are taking why do
you consider that project as complex or
difficult what was the size of the
project in terms of deliverables budget
geography team tools and techniques etc
was the project successful or not and
why
question 61 when do you know the project
is off track so it is very essential for
every project manager to ensure project
is going as per the plan so there should
not be any deviations from the actual
plan so every project will have a set
plans based on which project have to be
completed successfully due to various
different scenarios projects go off
track recognizing and correcting those
is very critical and crucial so one
needs to follow a specific approach to
ensure project will not go off track so
but we need to understand whether
project is going off track or not so one
of the key thing which we need to know
is spi and cpi so spi is the scheduled
performance index the cpi the cost
performance index so when spi is lesser
than 1 which means project is behind
schedule when a space
1 then it's as per the schedule if a
space greater than 1 which means project
is add of schedule similarly for cpi if
cpi is lesser than one project is over
widget cpi is more than one project is
under budget recipe is one project
budget is as per the plan so similarly
the results of audits and testing done
as part of quality management also
reveals the details related to
compliance and of specifications which
needs to be corrected if they are not
expected
next question have you manage remote
teams and outsource resources so these
questions come from the scenario where
you have to manage the team not
reporting to you directly and they are
managed by different individuals while
having such resources the dynamics will
be different so while managing such
resources one has to
ensure the engaging with them is
different than the way the individuals
are engaged the internal teams so it is
required to engage with that team more
often the performance of the team
members has to be well known to the
reporting manager and that needs to be
communicated regularly
the next question if you could go to the
past and do one thing differently as a
project manager what would you do and
why so every project manager who has
managed several project earlier will
think of doing better which they have
done already so this is because of the
experience they had while doing the
project and the insights there today
compared to the day they did that
project so while answering this question
following points has to be kept in mind
what went well and what did not go well
why do you think they happened and what
would have been the better solution why
do you think it could have been done
better why did you not do it earlier the
way you're thinking the right way of
doing it today so what was the cause
were you not informed about it or there
was some force which was working on you
to take it in that way what made you to
do that way so why are you thinking that
this is the better way to do it what are
the reasons that you need to mention
so next question as a project manager
what is the most common challenge that
you face so obviously when you say take
up a project as a project manager every
project manager will come across various
different challenges every project will
have various challenges to deal with
project managers has to prepare
themselves to handle those they should
not shy away from those so typical
challenges which project manager would
come across would be the scope
perspective not clearly defined so not
having proper sign off between customer
and project organization then the
deadline dates or schedules which are
given are not realistic low budget
allocated low cost allocated
capabilities and skills of the team then
project environment etc
and with that we have come to an end of
this pmp fill course i hope it was
informative and interesting if you have
any questions about the topics covered
in this video please ask away in the
comment section below our team will be
happy to solve all your queries thank
you for watching stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here